foreign
[Music]
just
relax
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
relax
thank you
foreign
[Music]
day I hope you guys at home are having
that Good Friday feeling we actually
warmed up here in the studio with a
pizza party and something smells really
good in the kitchen come join me in here
see what's happening in here David
what's up Kaya it's the Grand Final it's
Magnus against Maxine so we're getting
the popcorn ready it's gonna be exciting
oh I like it
[Music]
good block pasta ah oh I wish you guys
at home could just smell what I'm
smelling right now popcorn lean back
everyone get your popcorn going it's
gonna be so much entertainment today
welcome to the Grand final of the AI
couple
[Music]
execute an attack and finish the game
this is the chaos button that he's just
pressed what has this kid got in store
he's so good he's so good at thinking on
the Fly Checkmate on the board
oh hello
he is so stressed out he knows he's so
close in this one this is a game-ending
move
it is the very final day of the AI cop
today either Magnus Carlson or maximum
will be crowned the winner of this great
tournament the last tournament in the
Champions chess store before the tour
finals that will be played in Toronto
still three players fighting for that
one ticket to get to Toronto and here
today to guide you through the Grand
Final
the grinder the great the Grand Master
David Howell and my fellow lady in red
The Marvelous former Asian Champion
Tanya sachdem and Tanya is this a day
where it's basically about getting the
popcorn out leaning back enjoying some
fantastic chess absolutely Kaya the
popcorn's ready we're already what we
witnessed between these two was perhaps
the most thrilling match of the season
so far are both clearly the players who
played their best chess throughout the
AI cup and we get a dream final yeah and
I'm almost halfway through this bowl of
popcorn already yeah been enjoying that
and we want to see how you guys are
following the grand final today so share
your picture a selfie on Twitter using
the hashtag chess champs for a chance to
win an air things wave mini we really
want to see how you guys are watching
this and enjoying this great great grand
final together with us and David it's an
uphill task for maximum
speaks in the favor of him beating
Magnus in two matches today that's right
it's not going to be easy on paper it
looks almost impossible having to beat
Magnus first in a Four game match and
then a two game match but he should take
inspiration from the way he's been
playing not just in the in this
tournament but in over the last few
months Maxim's accuracy has been one of
the highest of the whole event he's
nearly never a blundering and his Killer
Instinct is on point he can do it but he
needs to strike first he cannot allow
Magnus to get the first win okay
let's look back to yesterday it was all
about the losers bracket yesterday with
the three players fighting for that
final spot here in the Grand Final
oh yeah I'm doing yantings or not seems
to be the answer there wow that's an
aggressive move
five seconds it's not much time and the
pawns are rolling and it's just so much
easier to play with white right your
moves are so much easier just keep
pushing the pawn meanwhile what's
happening anything oh I think he's just
losing weight can continue pushing the
Pawns
white has got this in the bag it's gonna
be game over any moment Jan is bobbing
his head here
Anish knows it Anish knows this is these
are his last few moves in the AI cup and
it's over
fashion he's got this in the back if he
can stay calm control his nerves he's so
close whoa wow why why what a move this
is a really strange one normally a
knight Never Lands on the Square it
looks like a fianchetto a night on B7
but I think he's about to win the piece
I think the punish he's gonna resign
there's a sneaky night check involved
also the black H porn that's sorry porn
that we've been talking about for ages
it's about to finally drop off Yan is
gonna click that resign button
Queen takes Queen the only move
otherwise white is winning whoa the
drama is not over in this game and he
makes the blunder oh the bar jumps up
for you on the ponyachi oh and Jan
frowns suddenly a new lease of life for
him
whoa I'm surprised
wow another blunder it keeps going that
part this is crazy the black king is
hiding Behind Enemy Lines it's even
taking pawns and black is actually going
to be the one delivering Checkmate the
checks are gonna dry up and white king
is at the enemy's Mercy tracks dry up
it's game over and Yan loses on time
Maxine progresses
and Maxim he started out in the
quarterfinals winning again Sally Reza
farucha then he won against chakrian
mamajaro he did lose that Winner's final
against Magnus two days ago but in the
losers final yesterday mvl did knock out
Jana pomniacci and Magnus Carlsen he
started out with a match win against
Hikaru Nakamura then he knocked
napoleonji down to losers bracket he won
the winners final against MBL yesterday
was a rest day for Magnus and here he is
ready for his third consecutive Grand
Final it's going to be an exciting day
it's not only about winning the Grand
Final you guys this is the final day
after six events before the tour finals
and still one ticket is up for grabs in
the tour finals for Toronto seven
players are ready but who will grab that
final ticket we have to go through the
scenarios David what can happen who can
make make it how can they make it yeah
this is a big day for that final spot
three players are still in contention
two of them will be involved in today's
play of course Maxim vashilograph we've
mentioned it he'll take on Magnus
Carlsen he needs to win he needs to
defeat Magnus if he wants to qualify for
Toronto in December fedes is also in
action he's playing the division two
grand final right now if Maxine
vashilograph doesn't win then feder save
has a shot but he needs to win his match
and there is also janapomnishi watching
from home maybe with some popcorn as
well but he's going to be hoping that
both mvl and feathersev lose if they
both lose neponishi will be the one to
steal that final ticket can you believe
it Tanya that's it went through all the
way to the final day in the sixth event
and we still don't know who's gonna be
that eighth player in Toronto how cool
is that right it just shows us the kind
of close fight that this has been and
three players fighting it out for Maxine
vashiella grave in one way the part is
the easiest but also the most difficult
he wins the tournament he makes it
through to Toronto but he is playing
against Magnus Carlson he has to not
beat him once but has to do it twice
meanwhile Jana Palmer she is the one
who's just sitting back at home and
probably enjoying with a bit of popcorn
himself yeah and federal save he has to
work hard he needs to win division two
he is playing the Grand Final in
division two right now actually the
first game against the uh
vladislavartamyev has finished with a
draw so game two will start there and we
will of course update you on the action
in
division two it is uh all about for
these three players now to bank that
final ticket to go to the tour finals in
Toronto
six events
eight players
we are nearing the end of the 2023
season and the fight to secure a spot at
the 2023 tour finals is on
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura and
nordebec andu satorov have already
qualified through winning individual
events Wesley so Fabiano caruana alireza
farouza and Denis lazovic punched their
tickets with tour points and now only
one spot Remains the tour finale will be
played from December 9th to 16th in
Toronto Canada
foreign follow to see who will get the
chance to fight for the 2023 Champions
chess tour title
you also a chance to go to Toronto
because you can bid for a chance
for the AI Cup trophy which is an nft
trophy and owning this AI generated
trophy
comes with a ticket to the 2023 tour
finals in Toronto in Canada in December
so go to chesschamps.io and make your
bid and we did see those seven players
that are already ready for Toronto what
do you expect for that big final that
will be played in December Tanya it's
going to be awesome just the stages that
only one more seat remaining we've seen
the players who've made it through uh
it's such a cool chance for everyone
watching to actually see these players
live in action in Toronto fighting at
that the whole tour of the season is
design Kaya to Crown the ultimate King
in online speed chess and we're gonna
find that out when it happens in Toronto
yeah and later in the show today there's
actually another Trophy up for grabs
because uh it's going to be in mini golf
David challenged Magnus Carlsen in sport
he has newly found interest for golfing
okay this one is hard
oh that's a terrible mess I can get it
there and then through
four
oh wow no no oh
I did not realize it could even go off
the edge now yeah that's pretty bad oh
that's that one yeah that's one that's
another one okay
I'm starting this home now you're on
like someone like five five yeah that
was my fourth day yeah okay
yeah
or we've seen on magnus's Instagram that
he's uh started to play golf what's your
golf skills like that was the first time
I've played in years and uh it wasn't an
easy course let's just say that but it
was a lot of fun it just makes you feel
better David yeah thank you Daniel don't
take away from me you're gonna see my
hand today oh like this all day long all
right anyways that's coming later today
we're gonna see what happened when David
and Magnus played mini golf but now
we're looking forward to the Grand Final
and only two days ago Magnus Carlson and
maximum played the winners finally here
in the AI cup and it has been described
as maybe the best match so far in the
Champions Chester season
yeah there we go it's on the board
Magnus will he Retreat his Queen
as we're expecting the fact paused Queen
sacrifice
Magnus Carlson surprising us not
retreating to a passive Square gives up
his Queen and then Maxine gives the
queen straight back that was crazy
suddenly magnus's Queen side pawns will
run black is too slow in this race and
Maxim knows it he looks away and Magnus
takes the win Maxine resigns wow we have
the first decided game
a rook sacrifice instantly from Maxim
vashilograph
this is crazy this is genius there's
checkmating ideas all over the place one
move now for Magnus Carlsen and he finds
it wow and he finds it in less than a
minute
Maxine meanwhile going forward with his
King wow look at this if he pushes his
Pawn will he get mated Magnus Carlsen on
the edge of the board we all know Queen
vs Rook how hopeless that is fangness
allows a Checkmate on the board and we
have on again
it is a dead drawn position we should
clarify the departure of knights Magnus
gave up his extra point to get the
knights off the board means it's a dead
draw and Maxine doesn't try to flag
that's the office the draw and Magnus
progresses today I mean I made mistakes
he made mistakes
we both found resources it was it was a
lot of a lot of fun today great match
and uh I thought Maxim
played the way he plays when he plays
well like uh giving it a really really
good fight I think I can play even
better but I'm I'm fairly happy
considering the complexity of the
positions
even Magnus Carlson happy with his play
these are the stats from that match in
five games overall the accuracy almost
94 for minus and over 94 for maximum
underground David how incredible is that
accuracy these are simply two
world-class players these stats are
incredible because Magnus himself in the
interview described the games the
positions as complex and in complex
positions you expect the accuracy to
drop you expect that to be blunders
inaccuracies but these guys they were
playing the best moves consistently and
in the end it was just a tiny margin
just the Armageddon was the only way to
separate them yeah
this is play in this tournament has he
impressed you more than he even usually
does
it's been amazing uh he's in the Grand
Final and I think the most exciting
match that he had in the whole event was
against Maxine vashiraga but it's not
just been this tournament this entire
year for Magnus Carlsen to me it's
reminiscent of his performance in the
2019 and I think we spoke about this
earlier in the broadcast as well 2019
was the euro Magnus Carlson he was
winning every single tournament that he
played and 23 as well he this is his uh
potentially his fourth title in the
Champions Chester he's won three already
the World Cup performance the
grantchester performance uh the guy
looks Unstoppable right now yeah it's
gonna be a tough one for maximum he
played fantastic two days ago got so
close to beating Magnus so what is that
little inch that he needs today to be
able to beat Magnus what can he do
differently oh it's going to be a tough
car imagine playing your best playing at
such an incredible high accuracy and
still not uh pulling off the victory
it's gonna be tough he needs to maintain
that level and hope Magnus drops off
slightly and if he gets even the
slightest even a half chance he has to
jump he has to bounce I think striking
first getting the first win will be the
key and then just clinging on taking it
game by game uh move by move
I actually think if Maxim is able to
take this first set and go into the
Grand Final reset he would become a
favorite it's only a best of two in that
and I agree with David it's about trying
to get that first win we spoke about
this when they played against each other
two days ago try to get Magnus into
those tricky complicated chaotic
positions it worked really well for
maxim the first time around when he
succeeded in doing that uh today will he
be able to get that coffee house chest
going on the board at a superficial
level it looks crazy now we see Magnus
Carlsen uh he's ready to go but crazy is
the only way you can beat this guy yeah
he did the over sleep actually two days
ago even if it's uh six o'clock six
o'clock in Norway but Magnus Carlsen is
now ready by the computer with the white
pieces in game one against
what should we expect opening wise in
this match for Magnus he's been really
ambitious in the opening both with both
colors uh usually kind of with most top
players with white they'll push they'll
press for an advantage with black
they'll be solid but Magnus has been
going for it going at his opponents and
it's given his opponents chances Maxim
was able to get one of those games like
this giving us a tour of his room I
spotted some food but there was some
takeaway there's a lot of takeaway and
the big takeaway I think from Maxine
from the other day was that he needs to
get those wild positions as Tanya
mentions he cannot go for anything too
slow too grindy uh against Magnus it
won't pay off yeah he just needs that
chaos two very different setups Maxim
very clean everything around him Magnus
it's just a mess
mess on the board but in his head things
seem to be seem to be Crystal Clear yeah
yeah start you guys this is the Grand
Final in the AI cup Maxim vashiella grav
is not only fighting to win this match
he is fighting to get that final ticket
to Toronto it will be best out of four
rapid games here in the Grand Final with
a potential Armageddon to decide the
winner if the winner is Maxim then there
will be a grand final reset because
Magna still hasn't lost a match he has
been on the winners bracket this whole
tournament and in the Grand Final reset
at its best out of two rapid games and
here we go this is game one it has
started this is game one and David we
already have a switch up from what we
saw in their first Clash already a
switch up where we did not see the
Queen's Gambit in their first Clash now
it's the Queen's Gambit accepted and
Magnus will have to hope that his
opening is uh better than his air
quality which is pretty poor right now
Magnus is the first one to pause Maxime
switched up his opening repertoire we've
talked about it throughout this week no
more grenfell defense which was his
habitual go-to weapon now Queen's Gambit
accepted and uh Tanya is it strange to
see Magnus pause already
I think it's strange to see a Maxime as
well go ahead with this qga the accepted
Bond sacrifice in this Queen spawn
opening this is definitely something
that Magnus was not expecting probably
he was hoping for more of a grun-filled
the traditional Maxim approach uh but
Maxim spoken about this that he's
actually worked on making his opening
repertoire more versatile harder to
predict and it's been paying off so
really interesting because their first
match it always started with the
kingspawn opening went completely wild
but Magnus perhaps trying to keep things
more in control get more of those
strategic battles yeah and the reason
I'm surprised Magnus paused at all there
is because Maxim's been relying on the
Queen's Gambit accepted throughout this
event and throughout recent tournaments
and had a lot of success with it so uh
Magnus he had a day off yesterday I
would have expected him to do some
homework here again he's kind of
fidgeting around here not yet settled
into the game he's burned around one
minute despite this being a very well
known position White having won back the
gamuted porn the Queen's Gambit not a
real Gambit uh whisper it quietly
everyone you win the pawn back usually
with white and here okay white is the
first to Castle but black is going to
strike in the center now often we see a
symmetrical Pawn structure after a few
trades here and there
and uh very level play but okay Magnus
now expanding stopping actually the
black pawns from pushing on the queen
side and for the first time it's mvl in
the tank
he's still ahead on the clock though and
with that last move by Magnus it takes
away certain possibilities for Blackbird
in contrast gives away a key Square in
the position long term which is that B4
post often used by black for the Knight
to jump in eventually from B8 to C6 to
uh the spot which has been left behind
by magnus's last move I'm also expecting
a trade in the center to create some
long-term weaknesses and Maxim he's
thinking about it the question here for
Maximus does he immediately trade in the
center or delay it with developing the
Knight because you want to and he does
go for the night development you want to
delay the development of the bishop on
the king side to save some tempos yep
still a well-known position actually
this is also a known position from a
slav defense with Black's Pawn on A6
being back one square so the players
they use all these patterns and Magnus I
know has had experience there he brings
this Rook across now again a temporary
Gambit temporary sacrifice but he'll win
it back due to the Rook wearing down at
the black queen there's a pin he'll take
back the pawn the next move and now
vashilograph should most likely just
hurry get developed get that black king
to safety he's going to move the black
dot Square bishop and there we go after
white recaptures in the center
safety for the black king still well
known territory the players thinking a
little bit though maybe some nerves at
these early stages
settling in into the big Grand Final and
once again with that last move that
Magnus played it's an option it's a
choice for white in these positions what
do you recapture with in the center and
Magnus eventually decides to take with
the pawn so we see these Dynamics with
an isolated Queen spawn and there we
have it the Knight jumps to the square
that I was pointing out earlier to
actually eventually land on that D5 spot
in front of the Central Pawn it's going
to be about whether white is able to
create attack on the king side peace
activity in return for this Pawn
weakness out of the opening yeah and
Magnus is the type of player who doesn't
really like taking on the responsibility
of Pawn weaknesses unless he knows what
his compensation is and unless he knows
there's a kind of specific plan uh to
activate his pieces to go for the attack
and the fact again that he's pausing is
slightly concerning right now white has
this isolated opponent Center it will be
blockaded by a black knight in the near
future and therefore it's time to bring
pieces into the action white dark Square
Bishop most likely about to come out why
it's Knight on the king side can jump
into E5 lots of potential plans here but
this is the type of position he could
have predicted Maxine plays the Queen's
Gambit accepted this is a position you
could get almost by force it's really
strange to see Magnus thinking we're
used to these top players in the world
just bashing out the moves to move 10 15
20. instantly if they know what their
opponents are going to do it's going to
be interesting to find out what was the
mindset for maxim for Magnus going into
this position and then taking his time
in the opening wonder if he was maybe
more expecting the grunfels setups but
as you say that Maxim has been playing
this so it should have been something
that Magnus expected in any case these
kind of positions are not something that
Magnus is not familiar with he I mean
every position he's familiar with but
the plans are so clear for white in this
one uh bring that Knight to The Outpost
on E5 bring that Bishop to G5 eventually
uh get the A1 Rook to the C1 open Line
develop your pieces and try and look for
player against the blacks King side
meanwhile for black for maxim also the
next few moves are pretty automatic to
make you want to develop the light Squad
bishop and see it so ideas like B6
Bishop B7 I actually play these
positions with white David and I kind of
really enjoy the Dynamics of keeping the
pieces on the board yeah it's uh
interesting telling you most of the time
these days I play this opening from the
black side uh I used to my whole opening
from these isolated Queen's pawns I love
them in all sorts of opening Sicilians
caricons as white French defenses just
pushing them forward trying to break
trying to get active and then I decided
nah it's too much fun for me and uh I
prefer the long positional grind where
black often tries to park a piece in
front of the isolated form blockade and
uh goes for a slower game and okay the
most natural move I think the most
popular move at least in the position
white tonight jumping into the center
and now I'm expecting Maxine to go for
one of those two plans you mentioned
either uh pushing the pawn and trying to
bring the bishop to the long diagonal or
doing it this way with his Bishop still
a well-known position I've had this
actually many times myself this exact
position but with the black pawn back on
A7 from a different uh branch of a
different opening and there
um yeah the plants are basically
identical and you'll move on the boat
Tanya he's getting ready to think his
Bishop he's ready to finish that
development meanwhile now for white uh
can you be the one who takes control of
that diagonal with the queen move it can
be tempting to a lot of people watching
a lot of the chess audience there move
like Queen to F3 but David then black
just sidesteps with the rook and the
bishop eventually will come out in fact
hitting that Queen so uh it's a double
double head sword to move uh the queen
there and I think for many you know it's
hard to imagine that how do you beat
Magnus in a mad situation right the
maxim has done everything in this
tournament to get this far and then he's
playing against Magnus has to beat him
twice how does he do it but let's let's
just remember that actually Maxine has
done this before in 2020 in the speed
Chess Championship he actually knocked
out Magnus Carlsen in the semi-finals
with a 13-11 score
but Magnus didn't have to wait too long
to get revenge for that one yeah he uh
he does have the upper hand Magnus in
general historically in the head-to-head
here but Maxim has won that big match uh
in the past so can take hope inspiration
from that meanwhile I don't really like
magnus's last move I've got to admit
unless uh he's got something up his
sleeve here because trading pieces in
this exact Pawn structure will only
accentuate only highlight the weakness
of White's isolated Central Pawn uh if
all the knights disappear if all the
Bishops disappear only black can ever
win uh because the more pieces disappear
the weaker that pawn becomes we have a
question David uh from a viewer uh just
wondering but why do players take so
long in opening prep
that's a good question I mean there's
there's kind of two schools of thought
here
um there's certain players Jana punishi
for example usually Maxim vashlagrav and
others who just if they know what
they're doing they play instantly they
make moves bang bang and then there's
players like me who if even if we know
what we're doing will take a bit of time
we'll pretend that we don't know Lala
opponents into a full sense of security
and then uh kind of up the speed a bit
later in the game and then there's also
the situation where you simply don't
know what's going on and you're
freestyling making it up as you go and
that often costs a lot of time too but
yeah slightly surprising Magnus knows
these types of positions as Tanya
mentioned he knows all the ideas maybe
he's just trying to get Maxime out of
his preparation he's trying to get his
opponent guessing
thinking for himself and this is an
interesting maneuver he's found a rare
idea here lifting his Rook it really is
and it's uh as I was saying that I've
played these positions started them but
this is not an idea that I am familiar
with as well but it really shows
magnus's understanding in this we were a
little critical about the decision to
trade off a pair of knights because when
you have this isolated weakness in the
center of the board you want to keep as
many pieces on the board for those
attacking chances but Magnus has that
attacking chance in his head but in a
different way he wants to get the queen
side Rook all the way across to the king
side with this Rook lift Rook from A3
super flexible can go to that G3 Square
lining itself up with the king or even
to that H file eventually lining up with
the queen to hit that pawn on H7 I think
this could be a very new idea on how to
handle this Queen's Gambit accepted
position trade off one pair of knights
in the queen side and then get the Rook
into the attack okay yeah he needed to
get his Knight out the way uh White
previously had a night sitting on the C3
Square so he has cleared this third rank
for his Rook but I'm skeptical once you
have traded a set of pieces you have
fewer attacking pieces left for yourself
and black for example at some point
we'll just push a pawn to G6 and uh okay
I don't think you'll do it now but this
structure in general is known to be Rock
Solid it's extremely hard to break down
and uh okay Maxine going for the tricky
tactics already uh the tricky Frenchman
has uh he has been called by some of his
Rivals sacrificing a pawn here and what
is the idea after Rook takes rook in the
corner black will recapture it with the
queen and hit this Pawn he's also
hitting the white Bishop so I don't
think Magnus wants to do this he takes
the pawn immediately and I guess Maxim
wants to threaten Checkmate oh wants to
threaten it in one move look at the
battery now along this diagonal Queen
and Bishop attacking just a pawn this
would be Checkmate if the queen can
capture but he's allowing The Rook to
come across and defend really surprising
I don't see what the pawn has been given
up for here Tanya and The Rock was
headed there to start with with the Rook
lift Magnus had it in mind to get it to
the G3 square and the good news for
white is that the bishop on B5 is
defended with the queen on E2 so it's
not really a double attack and I think
we're gonna see this being played out
Rick G3 feels like the most natural
response in this position and I wonder
if Black's compensation here is based on
one of the Rooks taking on the open a
line and the other coming on to the open
C line trying to infiltrate from that C2
Square yeah control over these two open
files looks really really nice here for
black so your guaranteed compensation
White's extra Pawn is going to be
isolated two isolated pawns here uh mean
that long term actually in an end game
white is far from guaranteed to win even
with the material advantage but still
slightly curious didn't feel that
necessary uh he just wants to distract
magnus's Army on one side of the board
no more attack
um interesting Maxim he's known for his
Pawn sacrifices uh this kind of
intuitive initiative based porn
sacrifices
but yeah he could have maybe played a
safer way a safer approach though but
safe never works with Magnus and I think
this is exactly what we've been talking
about from the start of the show right
it's about trying to get this these
chaotic complicated positions on the
board where sure the evaluation bar or
an engine it just grabs the pawn and
then defends perfectly but from a more
human perspective you can expect more
mistakes on the board you can't expect
your opponent to go wrong uh playing
against Magnus I think you have to have
that brave that gutsy approach that if
you see an opportunity to create the
chaos you just go for it
what do we think is Magnus gonna spot
that Maxim is threatening Checkmate in
one move question can we just sit back
with the popcorn and wait sir
do we already have that match that we uh
kind of wanted just these two going all
out
feels like it's starting it feels like
it's simmering slowly at the moment
Maxim he's the first one to sacrifice
he's given up a pawn we saw some crazy
sacrifices the other day Magnus throwing
away his Queen then fash giving it back
so I think this is the beginning still a
long day of Chess ahead of course but
Magnus is the one to start on the back
foot he's a pawn up but defending
reacting it's never where the top
players want to be they want to be
dictating the pace of the game and easy
the out of the opening now with Maxim
sort of playing that a little bit a
surprising move yeah I think we're well
and truly out of the opening usually
historically we said once both sides of
castle that's the end of the opening
phase but with the dawn of computers I
think now we're a bit more flexible with
that it tends to be when uh the kind of
last player is out of their homework
their preparation now for sure both
players are on their own okay and that's
what makes it so exciting right out of
opening preparation but you still come
up with this really creative idea to
build this initiative with the black
pieces to give up a pawn right out of
the opening against the world number one
it requires a lot of guts and it was so
nice to talk to Maxim yesterday after he
won his match against janapomnia he was
almost a little bit emotional we could
definitely see that this means a whole
lot to him after a few years with uh not
the results he wants basically and I I
understand he's been struggling a little
bit but now he he is here showing that
he he really is one of the best in the
world he really is and uh yeah I think
Maxime has been pretty vocal about his
struggles over the last few years not
getting the kind of performances that he
was looking for or what his strength
really is and it had a lot to do with
his decision to get new openings into
his repertoire yeah to try to just
become a more versatile player out of
the opening he's been one of the best
using these night offs and these
grunfeld but over the last couple of
years we've seen a big shift in his
opening repertoire and I think it takes
a little time to kind of just find your
balance in that and all that hard work
and that prep I think eventually it's
kind of the puzzle is coming together
for Maxima Sherlock it's not just this
tournament the last few months we've
seen just just incredible chests from
him once again starting from the Tata
steel chess India rapid with the best
players he won that field convincingly
his performance in the speed Chess
Championship uh yeah it's uh it's been
awesome to watch Maxime back at his best
yeah yeah learning new openings it's
like starting a new job or it's like
learning to walk again in a way
sometimes it's a bit slow at first but
now he's well and truly kind of
remembered how to walk and he's running
at high speeds now with these new
openings uh these new openings they seem
to suit his strengths really well I
think he's picked really wisely he had
these Dynamic openings in the past and
look at the position he's got now
Queen's gonna be accepted known for
being solid but it's got Dynamic
potential and all of Black's pieces
really active I think he's loving his
position Bachelor it's a very maximum
position and what I also really loved
hearing from him yesterday was that how
this year and his performance has
actually motivated him for the
candidates yeah the tournament in
Toronto which the players really want to
get to and he's got the grand Swiss
coming up where you can make it to the
candidates if you finish in top two so
this has given him a lot of Hope and
motivation to fight for that and yeah
that's awesome to hear because he's been
playing fantastic chess yeah and we
enjoy that when we can watch mvl and
Magnus at their very best fighting it
out today this is only the first game
out of at least four games or maybe even
just three in the Grand Final and we
want to see how you guys are watching
the grand final today so share your
picture or a selfie on Twitter RX using
the hashtag chess champs for a chance to
win
this tiny little ear things weigh the
mini to monitor your air quality at home
we will choose a winner and we really
want to see how you guys are watching
this and enjoying this Friday with the
best chess players in the world and the
best chess commentary thank you guys
while the air things device is a mini
one I think this match is not going to
be a mini match because uh I really like
what we're seeing on the board right now
and the clock Maxime twice the amount of
time almost compared to Magnus so he's
forced him to think quite early on and
it's again all about the initiative that
Rook on the c-line looking to infiltrate
into White's Camp the last move by
Magnus developing the bishop does hit
the Knight on B4 so you need to be just
a little careful about whether you have
the opportunity right now David to
actually come in with the Rook to pin
that Bishop do you think that might work
out I think it's definitely something to
calculate here and fashion is so good at
calculation it's on his radar of course
if he brings the rook in he pins this
trip he doesn't win it of course but
he's actually attacking at this point
that's the secondary Motif the one
downside I think instinctively in Rapid
chess Blitz chess is you don't really
want to leave a king on the back rank
exposed here white cannot deliver a
check a check would be deadly at this
point so it looks fine it looks
acceptable here but somehow alarm Bells
might be ringing in his head and there
are safe options as well uh he could for
example just move this Knight to this
Knight could go back he could maybe
defend the Knight with his Queen I like
that yeah just going active feels right
here I mean this was the first move that
was I that I was drawn to as well Tanya
I've got to agree I would love to see
that on the board really trying to
invade White's uh Camp here but this one
might be tempting uh for fashion grub as
well just hitting a pawn and if white
tries to defend it with his Bishop then
the Black Knight simply tries to remove
the defender it feels really loose for
white actually and Black's pieces are
creeping in uh don't be surprised as
well if in the near future both sides
take a timeout with a pawn push just to
clear the background to give the Kings
some breathing space really tense
position but Max seems definitely
cooking up something he's trying to find
something creative uh he doesn't just
want to retreat this Knight it's not a
maxi move even if it's a good one a safe
one uh to drop back right now
I was thinking that you know your knight
is hanging loose pieces drop off and as
you said just intuitively you want to
keep things more in control especially
with less than eight minutes on the
clock a back rank weakness the night
hanging I loved your suggestion of
actually jumping in with the queen uh
felt a lot more attractive once you
pointed it out David but this one Maxim
isn't backing down he goes for the most
direct approach attacking the B2 Pawn
pinning that D2 Bishop uh wow this is
once again quite a brave decision by
Maxime and now the big question is can
white actually take advantage of that
weakness that you pointed out the back
rank weakness I was thinking offer a
trade on C1 but Magnus just simply
sidesteps with the pin now saying that
actually black can recapture that pawn
on B2 and restore material balance yeah
I think Magnus is setting a really
sneaky trap here a really cunning trap
in this position there was a pin the
White Queen was slightly vulnerable so
she's dropped back she's also defending
G2 note that now the White Knight is 3
it's no longer pinned on this diagonal
to the G2 pawn and if fashion the graph
gets greedy here and recaptures his Pawn
look at the evaluation bar it would
shoot up because white can suddenly
initiate a double attack hitting the
rook and the Knight the black Rook is
only one square to keep defending uh its
Knight and suddenly a second double
attack look at the Bishops hitting the
queen hitting the rook and it's this
queen hiding away in the on the back
rank defending the bishop that plays the
star role and black would lose material
next turn so he cannot get greedy rash
the gruff of course he should spot this
uh it's a 2-3 move tactic here but
taking the pawn would lose it would
backfire immediately but do you think he
missed this do you think he missed that
Magnus could actually just sidestep with
the pin and keep all the threats on the
board I think that's an easy move to
miss backwards Moves In general are hard
to spot and especially backward Knight
moves backward Queen moves I noticed
they catch out a lot of top players
Maxim is lucky here that he has options
uh but he has to worry about how to
defend this Knight the one thing he
probably doesn't want to do either is to
drop his Knight back because suddenly we
we would see the black Rook trapped
Behind Enemy Lines suddenly there's no
way home no way to safety and White's
Bishop will simply Come and catch you in
the next few turns actually vashilograph
we might need a clue here we might need
a hint from the computer how narrow is
his path uh this Rook dive into the
position into C2 it was Brave but oh
okay he has a few moves to keep the
balance none of them are obvious though
bringing the Black Knight to A2 uh looks
bizarre that's the second best movie
coming to the computer maybe the best
move okay he finds it it was the most
natural of those suggestions just
defending the Knight
and at least now you are also opening up
your Bishop to strike and ruin the white
Pawn structure if black gets time to
capture on the F3 Square next
suddenly the tactics is in the back of
your mind as soon as tactics work for
your opponent you get a bit worried you
get a bit scared so vashilograph
retreating as well not a good sign
will be slightly happier with that
little kind of transition of moves but
what's a good sign is that Maxim finds
the best move in the position because
there was a big threat of actually
trapping that black rook and now I think
uh those moves just don't work out for
Magnus because it was to step up with
the bishop and we need to do a deep dive
into it because it's such a critical
moment for this game one if white was to
step up with the bishop to C3 Maxim has
the time to First destroy the pawn
structure on the king side and now step
back with the Knight to that square that
we're pointing out in the opening and
white doesn't have enough momentum to
trap the bishop you can come back Bishop
to D3 but Black's the one to White's
request so simply take on C3 hit that
Rook on D1 that's an Intermezzo and
everything is solved in Black's favor
yeah the very end I mean there's a lot
of tactics a lot of moves but we would
just do a quick count it's level pawns
but it's the quality of Pawns here all
of White's pawns shattered uh doubled
isolated and despite the opposite color
Bishops black is in full control so I
don't think Magnus will find that too
appealing but then again how to deal
with this threat on the White Knight
it's not easy this Knight is tied down
defending some key pawns and if black
ever captures wrecks the structure then
it can only be Maxine who can ever win
with a safer King
so yeah suddenly Stakes are high I said
retreating not positive professionally
graph but actually Magnus still has to
be careful has to be accurate here and
I'm I'm not sure what he will try
actually Magnus Carlsen three minutes it
gets almost six yeah it's getting
dramatic on the clock oh it's dramatic
on the board and dramatic on the clock
and I'm just wondering if it's time for
Magnus to neutralize that really active
Rook of blacks on the second Rank by
offering the trade with his own Rook to
see one uh David taking advantage of a
point that you made earlier that black
does have a back rank weakness to deal
with yeah I think we might see that
Tanya just offer of a trade there we go
on the board and Maxine has to be
slightly careful don't move this Rook
out the way white will infiltrate
White's Rook we'll be ready to to jump
in and okay who do you hold is the
favorite here Tanya Black's still a pawn
down but good compensation who would you
pick really good activity and tough to
call a result I think this is a game for
all three results uh I'm gonna predict a
drawing this one okay well how are you
David oh it's still my answer Tony
um I think a draw is still the favorite
because neither side has made any clear
blunders any clear mistakes it's still
very very balanced black will likely win
back the pawn sooner or later
but I'll say okay I'll say Maxine just
because of the clock situation and uh we
saw a message from the twitch chat a
moment ago saying Magnus maybe not quite
warmed up yet I have the same feeling
and he did have a rest day yesterday I
heard you guys talk about uh previously
in in the tour that you know that can
sort of ruin your routine a little bit
maybe
it's all about momentum right when
you're in the flow of things when you're
playing well very often you don't want
that recipe you don't want to pull in
those breaks uh but on the other hand
when you're having a tough tournament
you always want to take that day off and
get back into it so I think it could go
either way but the thing with Magnus is
this is just so uh so typical where he
does start slow any kind of event any
kind of match or situation we've often
seen Magnus have a slow start and then
just go full speed so if you're able to
really catch him early on in the match
uh that's where your best chances line I
think Maxim knows that better than
anyone else which is why he's gone for
this kind of a Sharp tactical approach
in the game and even this last move he
just keeps the tension on
and really giving Magna some problems
taking down now to two and a half
minutes left on the clock Magnus could
that be eventually a big problem for him
it definitely could especially if it
remains this tense and I love Maxine's
last move the bishop in the corner not
doing anything it comes to defend its
Rook just as Tanya says keeping the
tension and that's the key when you want
to trick your opponent especially if
you've got half an eye on the clock the
biggest mistake is actually to rush to
clarify things to trade-off pieces
because then it makes the opponent's
position simpler but by keeping pieces
on not necessarily trading look at this
Magnus is the one actually panicking and
trying to force the issue uh he's really
trying to kick out that black Rook from
his camp and uh yeah Maxine's done
everything right every time I think
there's a mistake that could trip him up
he finds the best reply and okay a rook
trade was eventually forced now watch
out for the White Queen coming to C8 to
the top of the board checking that black
king the black king has no Escape
squares that would be a deadly check
therefore he blocks the file again
Maxime just spotting everything uh
keeping control and look at the Black
Knight The Black Queen the black dark
Square Bishop they're all pointed
towards White Central Pawn and I think
the material balance will be restored
shortly still a level position but all
three results possible yeah and what's
so impressive is that Maxim is finding
these best moves in the position with
the speed with which he's doing I mean
he is a 2021 World Blitz champion and
we're clearly seeing why that's the case
so but this is not an easy position to
play just every move is a high
responsibility move in these kind of
situations where you're down upon and
you're fighting for the initiative but
Maxim just on his A-game plays on equal
ground even against the world's best
player this last move Knight to C6 it
takes care of White's Queen not jumping
into not infiltrating blacks Camp blocks
up the C file now and it's never a happy
option for white to trade this night uh
David I'm just wondering Magnus up a
pawn you don't want to take that Knight
I think that's something that would give
black more than enough compensation and
it's hard to imagine this extra Pawn
really coming to anything because B4 is
all always met with this F3 night
hanging in so many situations on the D4
Pawn coming under Fire as well yeah this
would be simply disastrous as you point
out Tanya note how this check now on the
back rank is not Checkmate anymore
because Black's Bishop can actually drop
back and block defended by the queen and
suddenly Black's attentions would turn
towards the white king and uh Magnus
does play a move he hits the black queen
and the black queen doesn't have too
many squares uh actually she has to
defend her Knight so you might have to
be a bit careful here and play Queen to
the center and now Magnus if he is
feeling scared he's only got one minute
on the clock if he wants to bail out and
play safe and probably head for a draw
then he can actually Force the Queens
off he can take this Knight forcing a
queen trade and here it should
eventually fizzle out white has an extra
Pawn still but the two Bishops should
compensate and uh eventually this Pawn
will most likely fall off or we'll see
an opposite color Bishop position and uh
yeah safety for both sides Sonia
is
Knight takes spawn completely crazy here
wow giving up the black queen we've seen
Queen sacrifices between these two
before and of course the black queen is
actually hit right now and you don't
care you want to ignore that I care then
you know exactly why I care yeah but you
can get away with it the bar doesn't
react Knight takes Pawn is a queen
sacrifice because if the black queen is
captured suddenly a fork and you regain
the material and at the very end still
Level pawns but actually black is very
active and he doesn't go for it this is
a lot to calculate maybe the one thing
that scared him was that a check could
have been given but now Black's Queen
could drop back and block I think this
was an opportunity to force the issue
but we go for that other variation we
mentioned now it's level material black
is threatening this night if we see
actually it's Black's move right now if
we see Maxine fashion graph take this
Knight I think we'll see a draw very
shortly level pawns now and despite what
White's fractured pawns on the king's
side not enough material left but he
shouldn't do that right he's so much up
on the clock you guys said it he needs
to take his chances if it's going to
beat Magnus but he did Gaia the kind of
position that he got out of the opening
and this is Maxime going for the draw on
his terms he's up on the clock
absolutely no problem out of the opening
with the black pieces is the one who
fought for the initiative so in some
ways as we like to call it in the studio
some kind of a moral victory in game one
okay
more Victory and I think the longer he
thinks uh he kind of spends mulling over
this position the more tempted he'll be
to bail out the there we go the problem
is there were no active ideas left and
he was just calculating there maximum of
the black king is quick enough to
actually make a dart for white b-pawn
if anyone I would still take black I
think it's because of the healthy Bond
structure we talk about Barna Islands uh
an easy way to see who's got the
healthier position Maxine Bashir Le Graf
four pawns on the king's side no
weaknesses at all while each of magnesus
born is a target for black the only
thing you need to watch out for is this
B faster so Maxine very rightly just
quickly rushes with the King to stop any
activity on the queen side or that pawn
becoming dangerous but do you think he
can get ambitious in this position with
black yeah look at the bar I'm a bit
surprised it looks like a dead draw as
soon as the black king tries to make its
way over towards the white B Pawn uh
White will give a check and block its
advance but actually it's sneaking
around the side maybe Magnus has missed
something he doesn't look too happy this
is where the clock really will come into
play no matter how good you are in games
no matter how genius you are like Magnus
Carson uh you do start to get nervous
when the momentum turns and maybe this
is what he missed the king did his bit
of a zigzag it tried to go one way it
was blocked by the white Bishop then it
went the other way and it's coming
towards that white Magnus will go down
upon this might not end in a draw okay
wow Magnus is the one who has to be
really careful right now he's under a
minute on the clock and equal Pawn so
far but with a with every single pawn
and White's position being a weakness
the king stuck to defending that F2 Pawn
can't really get active meanwhile black
you can actually just Advance with your
king closer to that white Pawn force it
to push up the board one more square and
David yeah we I think we're going to see
this being played out B6 is the only way
now to fight losing a pawn but it
doesn't last long because black can then
come back one step with the King and
eventually win that pawn anywhere yeah I
think we'll see this on the board Magna
says nothing else to do you have to just
keep your Pawn alive one more turn at
least but under 30 seconds now about to
drop opponent oh my gosh
oh
second Pawn Magnus is just going all in
but he's going to be two pawns down yeah
what is this he's just
I think he's lost his head here a bit
and porn takes porn here is as the
computer says a winning move there's
actually two winning moves they're both
to do with reacting to this Pawn push
you either take it or you bypass it pawn
to E5 also winning what's Magnus doing I
don't understand and both these moves
are so natural I would be so tempted to
just go E5 to create a passer but you
can also trade that F5 pawn and these
are really the only two moves you have
in the position so Maxima is just going
to choose one of the two and keep his
big Advantage who will it be enough to
win and those extra seconds on the clock
so critical for maxim right now yeah
I've got to say I think the second move
might be more natural pushing the pawn
forward uh just because you keep more
pawns on the boards the one downside
with taking is that what king might
zigzag in and behind and start munching
on some of these black pawns so you have
to calculate here the computer says it's
winning after for example black just
takes the pawn hits the bishop and uh I
think you can just come back and defend
everything but okay it's on the board
he's going for the win here for actually
the graph he's got to be careful though
he's got to be careful because also
watch out for that age being the wrong
color on H1 that's a light Square color
Maxim has a dark Square Bishop it if
white gives up the bishop for two of
black spawns and is able to get his own
King to that H1 Square it's a
theoretical draw even if black has an
extra Bishop on the board and that's why
he's found this really clever move maybe
the Clincher Maxim vashilograph maybe
what Magnus missed he's defending this
Pawn meaning the white Bishop cannot
give its life for two black pawns as
long as you keep one of these two alive
that issue never exists and white has to
go in simply has to go behind and try to
win right now but Black's King is coming
with gain of time and as soon as the
king moves the black pawn will be free
to run this is going to be game over
very quickly
what a start to the Grand Final Maxim
with more time on the clock it's looking
so good for him and you can see it on
Magnus he looks a little bit frustrated
and he's gonna have nine seconds when
it's time for him to move
what a start to the ground finally you
guys what a crazy start with the black
pieces so close to a victory a bit Maxim
just has to keep his cool and his
composure I love what he's doing he
keeps the pawns defended and then just
slowly he's marching the king towards
not only White's H2 Pawn but assisting
this half Pawn he doesn't even care
about giving up that H Pawn because
David I think this F Pawn will decide
the game Maxi Magnus has to stop it from
advancing but now the king moves forward
and eventually blacks Bishop will block
out this diagonal King to E2 transfer
that Bishop to this diagonal and then
just start pushing well he does it
immediately Bishop e3 coming next this
is game over I think Magnus will just
resign yeah three seconds for Magnus
Carlsen he does make another move but
his Bishop will soon be kicked away off
the diagonal uh and the black pawn will
March through to Glory you can do this
in a few ways right now you can just
challenge this white Bishop there we go
it could not take the black Bishop the
black porn would have promoted and now
just one or two accurate moves should
sort this game out you can even just
take the white Pawn right now this is
just going to be game over you can take
the white Pawn you can also slide all
the way to D2 and he does it David I
think this is game over on the spot
because the bishop comes over to that E1
square and that's it Magnus resigns wow
maximum he takes the first point in the
Grand Final here in the AI cup no
reaction from the cool Frenchman
but look at him oh wow what a start to
the Grand Final you guys he takes the
lead mvl he puts pressure on Magnus to
make a comeback I mean we were talking
about this is what mvl has to do he
needs to strike in the beginning and
that's what he's uh just done Tanya what
can you say about his performance here
we were talking about it Maxim knows it
better than anyone but you have to start
early with Magnus you got to take those
opportunities when they come and for me
the Highlight was just sacrificing that
bond out of the opening for the
initiative it was incremental pressure
after that David uh all the whole game
just an excellent play what stood out to
you
so many moments I just want to highlight
where Magnus actually let things slip
Maxime had been turning things in his
favor for a long time first from an
active opening middle game into a
slightly better end game and remember
not many people beat Magnus Carson in
the end game and it was here that Magnus
eventually went astray this Pawn is
dropping Magnus should have just let it
fall just retreated his pieces and
actually uh with just pawns on one side
of the board it is a draw it's
unpleasant to defend but it should be
holding instead Magnus went it all in he
gambled giving up a second pawn and here
Maxime clinched it with this classy move
Bishop back to H4 holding on to this
pawn and if we fast forward the final
position Magnus resigned because next
move Bishop to E1 is simply coming and
this Pawn will push just beautiful end
game technique play through it again at
home oh yeah definitely and this is the
action you get if you subscribe to
chess.com on Twitch you guys and don't
miss out on September through the end of
this month claim up to 30 off on all new
Subs on Twitch subscribers gain access
to X exclusive break time content during
broadcasts and score an ad free
experience on chess.com so don't miss
out on the deals you guys on September
and uh wow game two in the Grand Final
will start in a few minutes maximum in
the lead with the white pieces we will
be right back with that foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things anyone who has played even a
small amount of Chess especially online
is familiar with the concept of an
opening trap we've all fallen for one at
some point or another in many cases a
failed opening trap will leave you with
a terrible position but not always we've
compiled 10 opening traps that are not
only guaranteed to work but if your
opponent doesn't fall for them exactly
you'll still have a decent position
number two leg owlsmate this opening
trap if your opponent cooperates can
lead to one of the most beautiful and
famous checkmates in chess named after
sir de legal it dates back all the way
to the 18th century it occurs in an
Italian game and in this position we
play Knight C3 Black Knight Bishop G4
pinning the Knight to White's Queen and
we can play H3 forcing black to make a
decision about the light squared Bishop
if they retreat with Bishop H5 this
allows the brilliant Knight takes E5
where a free Queen is offered if black
takes the bait and grabs the queen can
you spot the famous mate in two
that's right Bishop takes F7 King E7
which is forced Knight D5 mate so if our
opponent does not take the queen bait is
this a dubious position not at all
Black's best response is Knight takes E5
allowing white to win the light squared
Bishop with Queen takes H5 and after
black takes the bishop on C4 white can
win the piece right back with a queen
check on B5 picking up the Knight on the
following turn no matter what Black's
response is white is up a pawn with
control of the center a great place to
be out of the opening
[Music]
eating popcorn it's impossible when the
ball is here right in front of you and
it smells so good as well and okay you
guys this is the AI cop and we are
teaming up with uh Oprah for this
tournament chess.com is and we're super
excited about this partnership with the
browser maker Opera it is something for
chess lovers this browser chess
specified you can have
chest basically at your fingertips no
matter where where you are so download
this uh new browser by Oprah we need to
talk some more about what just happened
what we have just witnessed Mel taking
the lead in The Grand Final against the
amazing Magnus Carlsen that means right
the mvl must have played some amazing
chess in this first game what what
happened here
I'm still thinking about it I've never
seen this happen before where Magnus
Carlsen in any match format has lost the
first game with the white pieces
Maxime has done what I think many would
consider just impossible at the very
start of the game get this momentum
going take the early lead in the match
and the thing is right now it feels like
we have a real match on our hands
because at the start you think okay how
do you beat Magnus not once but you have
to do it twice how do you do it when you
get this win in with the black pieces
you know that it's possible it's within
your reach and uh Maxim not only
tactically very sharp but taking some
really key strategic decisions and
showing extremely good technique in the
end game so an overall excellently
played game I would love to see the
accuracy of this one oh yeah do we know
that actually
um we can check that but I just want to
mention we meant we kind of discussed
before the show Magnus does start slow
sometimes you have to catch him cold and
that's exactly what he did when Magic is
happy to play for a draw he's nearly
impossible to beat so you have to take
the lead in a match that's the only way
to pretty much to beat him and now
Magnus will have to take risks to
straight back but Magnus was
uncharacteristic in that game he could
have actually forced a draw I was just
playing through he could have pretty
much forced to draw in a very simple way
at the beginning of the end game but he
took a risk and Maxim immediately
punished him um it was just a bit of a
strange one definitely feels like Maxim
has started hotter here he started
faster fresher sharper and uh he
deserves the lead so so what's coming
through magnus's head now he didn't seem
very happy obviously with losing but
just throughout that game didn't seem
that comfortable maybe I think it's
about getting into the Rhythm and again
we keep saying this right even
throughout the tour the first game is
always a little shaky but you never see
him actually losing and we are getting
an update on the accuracy of the players
uh almost 92 percent from Magnus Carlsen
and 98 for Maxine washer like incredible
98 you have to play a perfect chess to
take down Magnus and that's what uh
Maxim did but coming to the point that
David was making about this
uncharacteristic play in the end game I
also think that it's a lot to do with
how Maxim handled the opening and the
middle game because at this level it's
never a one move mistake or a one move
blunder right it's always incremental
it's always incremental pressure and
Magnus for the most part was forced to
find good moves pretty much out of the
opening once he did grab the pawn uh and
you you know you know you can sometimes
do it once you can do it twice but to do
it to find 10 to 15 good moves in a row
can be difficult even for the world
number one yeah definitely wow he has
taken the lead maximum and he did it
with the black pieces in game two
starting in a few minutes he's gonna
have the white pieces so let's get to
know mbl's opening strategies
[Music]
mvl Maxine battery or as his fans call
him the Frenchman with three names
mvl is one of the best players in the
world he has been for the past decade a
former World Blitz Champion mvl is
especially known for playing quick
tricky and precise chess mvl has a
degree in mathematics and this really
shines through when it comes to
calculation in chess you do not want to
get him in a forcing sequence where he
can work it out till the very end
the following position really
demonstrates the strengths of Maxim
vashilograph
in this position as Black coming this
way he found a killer sequence actually
Checkmate in five moves
this began with a night sacrifice the
most accurate way the most precise way
first taking a pawn checking the white
king and forcing white to recapture
to show off his calculation skills he
had now worked out that Queen takes Pawn
was the final blow with the key fact
being that if the white king moves
forward to any Square then the queen
drops back with a checkmate
instead the white Bishop threw itself in
the way to block black took this pawn
and after the king moved forward he
spotted this check
here Jeffrey Zhong resigned because no
matter what white does black gives
Checkmate on the next move the white
king is trapped Maxim calculated this
five move variation and one a really
impressive game fascular graph is quick
tricky and has a rock solid opening
repertoire his opponents better watch
out and if they want to have any chance
of beating him they have to avoid these
strengths
so that's what Magnus calls and can't
expect when he now plays with the black
pieces fighting for a comeback MBL with
the white pieces he's had some great
results in his career but this would
mean a whole lot to maximum if he wins
the AI cup after a few years with some
trouble
he's not only fighting to win the grand
final year he's also fighting to qualify
for Toronto maximum he has to win the
Grand Final to do that and if he doesn't
there is a chance for feducev to make it
to Toronto he will have to win division
two and he has taken the lead in that
Grand Final against artemiev We are
following that as well but now we are
getting ready for game two Magnus
Carlsen now with the black pieces he is
down by a point point mvl took uh game
one and now with the white pieces always
seems so calm the Frenchman but uh you
think he's feeling excited now Tanya I
think he believes now that it is
possible to do it today to make this
happen uh that Magnus Carlsen just gets
so much more dangerous when his back is
against the wall uh it's uh no it's
still far far from over and we see
Magnus with an opening approach where it
implies that he wants to just stop the
bleeding he's gone for the Berlin yeah
the most solid opening in
uh Rock Solid here known for its drawish
Tendencies and we do see a very very
level uh position here with uh
symmetrical Pawn structure white
slightly head in development so white
has a small Edge often especially if you
can keep pieces on the board but uh
definitely it feels like a case of
Magnus just trying to get on the
scoreboard trying to stop the bleeding
trying to get a result with black and
fashion graph not taking too much risk
here in the early stages with white
fashion graph I will mention has been
known throughout his career as the
Berlin Slayer he's often gone into the
Berlin end game and won countless
victories against the world's top
players but here going for something
slightly more uh full of life Tanya do
you like the fact he's kept pieces on
the board rather than uh go into that
in-game I do I like the fact that the
Queens are on the board in this Berlin
and we have none of that Berlin
repetition stuff that we see quite often
actually in the past in the Champions
Chester which actually means that Maxim
with the white pieces wants to keep the
game alive I don't expect him to take
very risky decisions in this one but if
the opportunity was to come we might
just see his intuition and his natural
style of play coming in so I do like
that we don't have the end game yet but
still a very solid position and why is
madness thinking after this small pawn
move on the king side it is very strange
I must say Magnus again could and should
have predicted this exact position uh
still very well known Theory and uh
especially with vashi the group who is
quite predictable in the opening you
could have pinpointed this and you could
have said okay I know where I'm going to
put my pieces
I know how I'm going to develop I know
how I'm going to uh end all of White's
potential pressure but Magnus it feels
like that rest day has really caught him
cold and okay he just needs to unravel
his pieces here the more pieces you take
off as black the safer you get due to
the symmetrical Pawn structure due to uh
the safe nature of this type of position
but feels like he's trying to Freestyle
Maxim I would recommend trying to keep
going try to build the momentum strike
while the iron's hot I do feel if the
next game is drawn I mean this game
maybe the next one nerves will kick in
the stakes will be so high and if it's
just a one game shootout that's when you
start to get affected I think he needs
to continue trying to catch Magnus while
clearly he's uh not in the flow right
now that's really interesting because
you're up a point against Magnus and
many would just think okay take a solid
approach take a safe approach but David
I think you're absolutely right that
when you're playing against Magnus
Carlsen any opportunity you get you have
to take it the next game Magnus will be
white and he will come come out all guns
blazing so in this one to not let Magnus
just feel safe to get into that safety
zone that safety net uh I think it's
it's quite key so for maxim if he gets
the chance in a Berlin but where do you
get your chances in this kind of a
position it's just a symmetrical Pawn
structure on the king side on the queen
side it's just about a fight for the
e-line usually in this opening the only
file that's open and it's about the side
that's able to get full control of that
yeah right now that is white White's
Rook nicely placed on that open e-file
and uh there's other small advantages
that you can hope for just to show a
quick outline of the ideas here for both
sides white does have a small edge here
traditionally symbolically at least due
to this Pawn dominating the Black Knight
the Black Knight here is actually very
misplaced uh it's in the way of a black
pawn which wants to use this square and
therefore at this point in the center is
slightly vulnerable uh meanwhile we see
Maxine bash the graph bring his Bishop
to the center Magnus going for exactly
what you said Tanya fighting for this
e-line here trying to trade Rooks off
the board trying to take pieces off I'm
expecting them to disappear these Rooks
I'm not sure on Whose terms for example
let's say they go and then white will
activate these pieces there's two ways
to do this either white tonight takes
the long way around it goes up back and
into the center or you can push upon and
bring the Knight around and try to creep
it up around the side of the board
either way these are still well-known
plants and both players just taking a
bit of time trying to maybe think what's
most testing for their opponents still
no forcing Lines no big tactics but it's
all about maneuvering right now do you
think it's important for Magnus to make
an immediate comeback after that first
loss or do you think he's able to keep
his calm maybe wait for game three with
the white pieces again I think you're
right guy that's his strategy his
strategy with the Berlin and not going
for a sicilian a more Dynamic opening is
that I just want this one to stop get
your mind get your floor going and then
with the white pieces uh to strike so
that's what I would say that he's hoping
for I think his opening Choice has
revealed his strategy uh sometimes you
want to keep your opponent guessing you
play a flexible opening and then keep
retain some chances of a counter-attack
but no he's just saying let's get out of
this game let's move on and that's not
very Magnus carlson-esque but that's the
way he's chosen to play this one and I
understand it because he is facing an
informed opponent and fashionograph is
his kind of uh he's famous for his uh
White wins just his white repertoire I
think uh almost uh incomparable uh in
World Chess
yeah but we have seen I mean when you
play too much for a draw it does give
the other player some opportunities does
this give mvl some chances to to go all
out in this game
maybe later yeah yeah still early days
but it will be a sign of weakness well I
say weakness it's a sign of what you
want and once your opponent knows as you
say Kaya once you know your opponent is
playing for a draw you take a bit more
risk you push them you kind of bully
them in directions they'll take passive
decisions I'm not sure you can do that
against Magnus because he's very in the
moment he's very spontaneous on the
chessboard uh he can react if you're if
your opponent attacks you you could he
will find ways to kind of Slither out
and uh he always has a win in his mind
and that's a great point you make and it
will come down to this inner game right
because you're up in the match you've
got this extra point uh how much risk
are you willing to take against a player
like Magnus uh knowing that you can play
safe and keep everything under control
and going one game closer to that Finish
Line without things going too wrong so
for Maxime again it will be a
psychological battle but it does look
like he still wants to keep the game
going uh you know when I just again
saying what I did earlier that I don't
expect him to go extra aggressive in
this one to take unnecessary action and
I think it's really hard in these kind
of positions and in these kind of
openings but he's going to keep the game
going and again the moral Victory will
come in if he can end this
on his thumbs or even if it's a draw
that let Magnus fight and earn that draw
and Magnus is currently trying to fight
to earn that draw he's traded off the
light squared Bishops that tends to
favor Black uh because if you compare
the remaining Bishops on the board
White's Bishop potentially will be stuck
behind his own Central Pawn Mass Black's
Bishop looks pretty nice controlling
both flanks now Magnus also offering a
queen trade I think if Maxim takes the
Queens off it's going to be close to
zero chance of grinding that one out or
Victory I think we will see a draw uh
and look at Maxim he's not even
calculating right now he's going for
it's a moral debate do you play for the
draw or do you keep Queens on and try to
win oh Mind Games I think he's going to
trade it I I think he's going to trade
the queens and I that's just looking at
Maxime oh it's on the board he goes for
it but I was going to say imagine going
2-0 up against Magnus that would be
incredible for maxim and I bet he was
saying that to himself as well but then
well
yeah I think too much focused on the
result it's natural it's very human
traits we've all been there when uh we
know it draws enough or you're playing a
higher rated player or if you're in the
lead in the tournament and you think
okay let's just take it easy this once
but will that come back to haunt him
I don't like that decision I think he
could have kept the Queens on still with
minimal risk and still with the very
very decent chances of uh pushing for an
advantage now we will see most likely
both Rooks enter the e-file uh the
e-line and trade-off for each other
we'll see Knights disappear off the
board there's just no Pawn breaks no
open Lines no weaknesses in each side's
camps
dead level this is uh the epitome of an
equal position yeah we might even see a
jaw for really soon our all pieces will
trade off into a pure King Pawn ending
symmetrical Bond structure really
nothing to fight for that last decision
by Maxine definitely implies that he's
getting ready for game three yeah and
his task in game three with the black
pieces will again be to make sure that
Magnus doesn't get his chances with
white Magnus Carlsen has given even one
chance that it's pretty much game over
for you and if if they do sort of decide
that they want to go for a draw now
quite soon how will that actually work
with many pieces left on the board
what will they actually do to will
someone offer that draw or will they do
some repetition yeah I was just thinking
about it this season on the Champions
Chester draw office have been few and
far between they've been very rare
actually I think again it's just neither
player wants to show weakness uh or kind
of blink first they never want to be the
one offering a draw uh here I think Kai
it would happen for example let's say
the white king moves and the line it's
standing on right now the e-file White's
Rook will occupy that and because it's
such a nice line Black's Rook will
challenge we'll see the Rooks disappear
once Rooks disappear if it's just minor
pieces on the board just Knights and
Bishops there's really no weaknesses to
look at and I think we'll see a few
night trades maybe the Bishops are the
hardest pieces to trade off right now
but if it's just Bishops and pawns left
at the end then it will be deadlocked
we'll see the players just go back and
forth and repeat so that's what I'm
expecting but then again I would maybe
choose black I would maybe choose
magnus's position okay just because it's
easier to push pawns on the king side uh
around the black king you can throw
those pawns forward gain a bit of space
there I've seen stranger things happen
I've seen Magnus uh he quite enjoys
these positions that's another reason I
would have kept the Queens on the board
just because you know the opponents
Magnus lost the last end game but this
one's a very different one it's a very
slow maneuvering grind type of position
and we know who the best player in the
world is there who knows how to Grand
like a Grandmaster he does
but David I you know the more I look at
it I I think I think you're right uh
Magnus might actually be the one who
might be thinking are there ways that he
can create some chances because he's got
easier play with his Knight and the
pawns on the king side also notice how
that F4 Square can become a Target the
F5 a square for the Knight to jump on
with a check uh I wonder if he's at all
getting ambushes here but the moment I
say that I also feel where where do you
actually end up hitting a White's
position here he does start pushing the
pawn so maybe Magnus is looking at a
long game and it might be Maxim who
might have to earn that draw now we call
it the tickle when you're not really
doing much you're just kind of teasing
your opponent you're saying okay I'm
going to push my pawns you decide how to
react you decide how to fix the
structure and then your opponent Burns a
bit of time there if they fix the pawn
structure in a bad way sometimes you can
take advantage if they find the right
way okay then it's a draw and the tickle
ends but you just uh yeah you just
maneuver it around keep the game going
forever frustrate your opponent and also
when you have the white pieces you have
this moral obligation to play for a win
as soon as you take the Queens off and
start playing for a draw which version
of is clearly trying to do right now
suddenly the mentality switches and uh
kind of viewers can assert your
dominance slightly over your opponent I
don't expect this one to be anything
dramatic but already Max seems to play
some slightly strange moves yeah putting
his Rook uh on its starting Square the
starting to grab the other Rook kind of
going all the way across the board uh
but it's on a locked up file right now
he's just hoping Magnus continues
advancing I don't think Magnus was
intending to do that anyway so I would
say a bit of a wasted move there from
Fashion to graph now Magnus will start
improving the Black Knight maybe the
black Rook
but it's not tickling then by mvl or
even like a little bit like flirting no
you show me what you want no you show me
what you want exactly pieces right now
that's pretty much what they're doing
yeah and uh I would say Magnus is the
one doing the tickling and Maxime is not
reacting in the best way uh he's kind of
sitting there just letting his opponent
to do this right now there's no way to
foresee issue there's no way to force
the draw and that's a bit uncomfortable
psychologically strange moment in this
match then we're just waiting for
something to happen or to get inside
their heads then I guess right now it's
not really easy I guess to to understand
especially what's going on in magnus's
head yeah Magnus he's gonna be feeling
ambitious and this last move is
provocation uh I was a bit surprised by
this it looks like he's trying to ask
Maxime to come forward now with some of
his porn centanya the most obvious move
in the position to me would be to attack
this Knight Magnus is saying please come
forward this is the tickle he's like
tickling he's like please react strike
me back and uh right now what would
happen if the pawn pushes
I think the point is uh you don't want
to take on G4 because then suddenly the
H1 Rook makes a lot of sense you're on
exactly the square that you want to be
what Magnus has done is exactly that
it's a provocation you go G4 you provoke
the weaknesses and then you simply come
back with the knight uh the point is yes
you can go to G7 but maybe even to E7
and I was eyeing the F4 square at some
Far Away distant future to land my
knight on and I'm also hoping that you
actually grab on H5 so that then my Rook
can slide all the way to h8 and this
one's a far more active move than the
one that Maxim made once I take on H5 H3
is weak as well uh so Knight to F5 I
think G4 exact is exactly what Magnus is
hoping for and maxim of course doesn't
go for it yeah and retreating the night
you mentioned passive uh it's really
really not a pleasant move to play the
idea is to come round and then into the
center to challenge the Black Knight
very logical plan if the knights both
disappear then it will be a dead draw
but
why white is really really kind of
crawling right now really not pleasant
and black at the moment has the better
night has the better Pawn structure and
Magnus does have the luxury of two moves
before black uh before his opponent
finishes that plan
these last few moves that Maxime has
made it almost feels like the path to
draw is just getting narrower and
narrower he needs to be more and more
precise and more concrete with his
defense in a position where it felt like
concreteness would not be the name of
the game but now he has to find ways of
exactly neutralizing Black's pressure of
trading pieces as quickly as possible uh
Rook to H1 Knight to E1 these strange
looking moves gets you the feeling that
something's gone wrong do you think
Maxine's feeling that as well or or for
him everything's still under control and
he's confident of it yeah it doesn't
look as energetic or as optimistic as
focused as he was in the past game uh in
the previous game Maxine barely even
blinked he was just sitting there stoic
and he took advantage of his chances as
soon as they came here it feels like
he's a bit uncomfortable he's been
moving back and forth in his chair
changing his posture a bit and these
small giveaways they're not much but
they do really signal his mindset
um I think he would just love to get out
of this game with a draw if Magnus
answered Maxine would click yes please
draw immediately and uh yeah it's just
really tense but uh Magnus enjoying the
tension a bit more yeah everyone is
tickled by the tension in this game I
completely agree with you there
so it really feels tense right now it
feels like I mean this could potentially
be very decisive right in the match
Magnus making a comeback or not making a
comeback and I I think Maxim is perhaps
regretting that Queen trade decision
that he took because that's the moment
that he really gave the chances to
Magnus to feel safe and to be the one
who starts pushing and in any end game
where Magnus feels he even has the
slightest opportunity the slightest
chance which many can't even see can't
even fathom but for Magnus it's about
playing it out then and this is that
kind of position right now he's gone
into a bit of think and I think that has
something to do with him deciding
whether how does he improve this
position whether he pushes those pawns
further clamping down on White's King
side but those are committal decisions
do you go without H Pawn to H4 and then
maybe even at some point go Rook to G8
and open up the G line to create some
weaknesses or do you keep things more
flexible in this this position and
improve your Rook already he takes
another Pawn decision he first makes
sure that everything is defunded on the
queen side because it's just harder as
white to make moves than it is for black
hair yeah it's much harder for white
right now we're expecting wow Maxim
rationally grow up yawning maybe that
reflects his views on the position and
uh the move Knight to C2 coming around
is indeed played part of the plan
initiated by his previous move and
Magnus now instantly reacts again
provocation forcing a reaction from
these pawns and maybe forcing a weakness
now which way will Magnus drop uh back
his night or will he come into the
position there is a bit of a hole right
now and if you jump in maybe the one
issue is this Knight will get traded uh
either White's night will come back or
uh maybe first moving the bishop next
he'll trade off these Knights by four so
the Knight drops back from Magnus and
this offer of a trade allowed but on his
terms this is really instructive note
how a nitrate offered here black does
not take because this would only give
white time first he says okay you can
take me but look how active the black
king is going to be and still I feel
this should be a draw but uh Black's
King now clearly Superior than the white
king more active at least Black's Bishop
can look at both sides of the board
White's Bishop stuck behind its own
Pawns in the center and blacks are
potentially much more flexible to come
to any of these squares that you
mentioned earlier Tanya still a small
Advantage but
I think The Disappearance of the knights
will give Maxim a bit of hope uh sigh of
relief there how often is it when Magnus
is playing and we say this should be a
draw but it isn't it so he does make
that magic happen it does feel as if
black has made a lot of progress in the
position in the last few moves the King
has become more active the black pawns
have moved forward gaining more space uh
threatening further upon moves ahead
meanwhile white has been struggling to
get pieces off the board and has managed
to do it but then again David as you
said on blackstorms making sure that the
black king gets to activity on F5 uh
annoying Magnus Carlsen he sees that as
progress he sees that as something to
fight for Beyond but how do you what are
the plans in which you can look at
actually improving this position further
let's say the knights were to come off
and your king does land on F5 and we see
that being played out what because if
Brooks come off David I think it would
be easier for white to hold this
position then yeah dead draw if the
Rooks ever come off if the bishops come
off likewise should be a dead control
like what Maxim's done he's taken the
open file he's saying okay if the black
Rook ever goes away I'll come in if the
black king ever moves back I'll come in
uh Magnus meanwhile shift his Rook to
the other side of the board uh again the
tickle continues will he push this Pawn
will he push this Pawn uh just teasing
and now Maxim's saying okay I'm not
going to commit but I might push this
Pawn uh they're kind of playing a
guessing game right now white might push
on the queen side black might push on
the king side I think ultimately none of
these plans are too scary if black
pushes right now white will happily lock
up this side of the board notice how you
never ever want to trade here and allow
your opponent's pieces activity so you
just block the structure block the
structure and end the opponent's winning
chances Magnus mean while trying to lock
the other side of the board trying to
clamp down and uh at least deter white
from pushing I'm slightly surprised it
looks like white can push anyway but at
least asking questions
yeah
but I was just gonna say that I'd love
to push C4 right now uh try to create
some weaknesses on the king side uh if
you trade everything on C4 white skin
gets Super Active
but yeah we'll see what my Maxim decides
I was going to say that they're
definitely keeping the tension and uh
while they do uh you guys remember to
take a picture of how you are watching
the Grand Final maybe it's a selfie and
share it on Twitter using the hashtag
chess champs for a chance to win this uh
air things wave mini we are enjoying
this day so much here in the studio
watching the best chess players in the
world and we hope you guys are as well
we are enjoying watching it with you
guys and we want to see your pictures so
please share them for a chance to win
that air things okay so moves is that
tension going away anytime soon slightly
less tense now after this Trader pawns
any trade any pieces pawns disappearing
uh means that the tension is abating
slightly but
I'm very very surprised Tanya that
vashtag has allowed blackstruck an open
file you did not need to do this you
didn't need to rush to do this you could
have done it in maybe uh more favorable
ways and now maybe Invasion From the
Black group threatened I agree with you
and whoa what oh my gosh but I love it
David but I was just gonna say it before
we Deep dive into this last move that A4
it just reminds me of their last match
where A4 turned out to be a big mistake
by Maxine washer legraff you're right
gives the B file but the actions moved
over to the king side it looks like a
pawn sacrifice but it's a temporary one
uh if Magnus was to take on G4 and I
think we're seeing this line being
played out the Rook can jump to E6 now
hitting the bishop and eventually
winning one of the two uh one of the
pawns back here and uh it's all about
the point you made the more pawns that
come off the easier it gets for white to
hold this position so G4 a very concrete
direct way to do that yeah now Maxim has
to be a bit careful though I'm really
shocked he rushed into this because look
how active the black king is there's a
clear Target now black is temporarily a
pawn up and I think the one thing you
maybe shouldn't rush to do is trade off
these Bishops he doesn't go for this
because now the black king has somewhere
nice and safe to hide in front of its
own pawn and this one is ripe for
picking off next move uh instead he
keeps the tension between the Bishops
this one despite the evaluation bar same
level I think we might see some twists
and turns ahead suddenly because Black's
King is coming in the black Rook is
coming in white meanwhile has him come
to play against this Pawn all three
results possible Magnus quickly
defending and uh he might even go after
this loose Pawn on the flank here
I would not like like to be Maxim Ashley
grav right now it feels like it's all
about the activity of Black's pieces
this is a classic Magnus Carlson I've
seen him win countless games in this
type of scenario oh wow and Maxine's got
to be feeling the pressure now because
again he needs to be really precise
because of all these dynamics that David
just pointed out but I do like what
Maxine's done he's forced blacks Rook
into the corner of the board and to
activate that there will be more Pawn
trades what Maxim is relying on is that
once uh black does take that pawn on A5
you'll pick up that pawn on C6
eventually a C4 break can create your
own counter Chances with a deep Pawn
being the passer up the board uh and uh
all of that might very well happen
because Magnus needs to activate that
Rook by capturing on A5 yeah but uh how
does white wait it's pretty much waiting
for black to move and maybe we can pull
up the computer suggestions just before
we uh uh drop the board here to see how
narrow is the margin is white keeping
the balance with lots of different moves
yes is the answer still a draw but uh
okay dropping back with the king I would
say not 100 obvious the idea is to stop
the black king coming in actually the
more I look at it the more I like that
one very human stop the opponent's plan
but trading off also fine maybe Then
followed by the king dropping back and
the last move I would say that this is
never ever gonna happen Pawn to C4 it
looks like it simply Blends as a pawn
pawn takes Pawn you cannot take back
because then your Bishop would fall so
the third move on that list never ever
but it's interesting you say that
because for me that is the most natural
idea but after trading on F4 so that I
don't end up losing the pawn but I want
to get as many pawns off the board as
possible so what I'm looking at is the
possibility to actually get the Bishops
off the board first and then go C4 David
does that work this makes a lot more
sense from a human point of view not
allowing any nastiness now after 0.6
porn you can happily capture back with
your king and this game should fizzle
out all the pawns will disappear black
can take a pawn white can take a pawn
black can come in uh White will start
pushing and eventually both sides will
have passports I think it just will end
up with King versus King uh
so Maxim he's doing the right thing
finally he's calculating and I think
he's gonna go oh okay he drops back
and uh slightly more passive than your
approach Tanya but probably just as
effective black is a bit stalemated with
his Rook pretty much have to take a pawn
to get the blackrook active and that
will lead to similar lines that we just
showed the only reason that I was
hesitant about this was because it gives
black the opportunity to come in with
the Rook with the check you take on A5
and then you drop down with your Rook to
the second rank driving the king away
but I think this is key this is really
important first you do an Intermezzo
driving blacks King away so that the
white King has another more active spot
when Magnus does give a check on A2 so
Rook G6 was precise there yeah and uh
the previous comment here on the twitch
chat Maxime is a genius I agree the way
he's played this I mean only he can play
chess like this where he forces the
issue so violently yet it still always
works out uh often kind of sensing that
moment when you initiate the play
especially against the top players in
the world it's so so tough but he does
it so naturally calculation is such a
big strand for all these players who are
the very best in the world but it all
comes down to the small difference of
speed how quickly are you able to
calculate precisely and Maxim is just
really up there when it comes to the
combination of these two you know when
he pushed that eight Pawn forward you
mentioned a really committed decision uh
what was that move uh that was about 10
moves ago I pretty sure he had a
position like this in his mind just he
saw that he would force the pawns off
the board maybe Bishops off the board
and he knew the end game was likely
holdable likely drawn Magnus now
threatening a check I'm not sure how
much of a threat that is but after the
game of tickle continues a few checks
here and there eventually all the pawns
will disappear and I think you can see
on Max magnus's body language right now
he's resigned to the fact that this is
likely going to fizzle out yeah he
pushed he tried his best in this one
when he got the chances uh he kept the
game alive but Maxim not only really
good today on converting a better
position but also holding a difficult
one and he must be very happy if this
ends with a draw because actually that
means game three could be decisive if he
wins that game we're gonna head straight
into the Grand Final reset Magnus
Carlsen he cannot lose game three of
this one and it's in a draw so that's
going to be intense
it's going to be intense it's a very
different type of match so far though
Tanya compared to two days ago when they
first faced where it was just fire on
the board opposite side castling Mutual
attacks Mutual races here it feels like
the first game was decided in that
in-game here it's another grindy
position uh do you think that's a
conscious decision from the players or
just because it is such high stakes I I
completely agree with you the first one
was so felt so much more random on the
board just then moves into the game and
we'd never seen a position like that in
every game in their first match but this
one feels like a more strategic fight uh
yeah I think you're right that it's more
controlled by Magnus but David I'm just
wondering if in the next one given the
math situation we might just see another
Sicilian I think Magnus might just
decide to start with the King spawn
opening we would love that another wild
battle just like we saw two days ago it
might be incoming this might be the Calm
before the storm we might need that bowl
of popcorn yet again in the next game
it's not going to stay there for a very
long David I'm constantly eating I can't
blame you guys
and uh meanwhile a pawn drops second
Pawn can fall though white can go
hunting uh right now it's level material
but that F Pawn looks ripe just go for
it why not attack that I think Magnus is
basing all of his counter play ideas on
running with his a pawn forward the
passport yeah and the move that you're
talking about with the Rook you could
either do a sideway attack or go to E4
and just win the F4 Pawn he goes with a
rook to F5 Magnus can start with some
checks along uh the second and the first
Rank and the a pawn is pushing that is
the counter play it does feel like it
should be enough against these separated
bonds uh if they were connected it would
be a totally different game yeah and if
White's King were more centralized more
active it would be a totally different
game the white king is cut off on the
back rank okay I think Maxine with this
last move indicates he's going to be
happy with the draw here white king
slowly inching its way towards that
black pawn the only dangerous uh factor
in the position this will neutralize
that White's King will blockade the
black porn Black's King will blockade
the white Pawns and uh Black's Rook
eventually will help to trade everything
off yeah so so how will this game end
will this be moved repetition King
versus King I oh what happened draw
offer okay fashion graph offers a draw
Magnus accepts and just like that we
have a result Maxine was like I'm done
with this tickling this is a draw Magnus
let's just finish it and look at him so
calm he is still in the lead maximum
after two games here in the grand final
game three he will have the black pieces
again and if he wins that game we are
heading straight to the Grand Final
reset to decide the winner Magnus cannot
lose the next game but this game I mean
you guys you guys were saying the Berlin
you guys were saying it was George from
the start Magnus did seem to have some
ambition though yeah Magnus was working
his magic doing Magnus things just
grinding away looking for Avenues into
the white position and actually here as
black I would have been getting
ambitious I would have been getting a
bit excited I think Magnus in his mind
thinking okay I can come in the black
King's really active but this is where
Maxine fashion growth is so strong is so
genius he out of the blue he sacrificed
a pawn just like he did in the first
game giving up this Pawn nearing the
black king away from the defense of this
E6 square and suddenly for the first
time in this game white got active
White's Rook started munching on pawns
and as we saw later The Disappearance of
Bishops marked a drawn end game
all right uh it's heating up you guys
game three is uh coming up uh shortly we
want to remind you guys there is
something else very cool going on the
very cool Chief chess officer Danny
wrench is taking on the entire world
actually in a chess game and you can
join our team to take him down Danny has
made his first move that was 184 and how
should we respond uh you can head over
to uh gochess.com play Danny or use play
Danny here in the chat to make your move
would you make Tanya I was just thinking
I think Danny's Gone With The King's
phone opening E4 David my pick is C5
what about you okay I rarely play C5 but
I'll I'll say C6 oh just to slice things
up Kaya break the tire no I'll go with I
like you at C6
take your move uh as well now what moves
will be made in game three it's uh going
to be Magnus Carlsen with the white
pieces and he cannot lose it that game
is coming up shortly after a break
[Music]
foreign
just played an exciting game and wanted
to see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
ah we need popcorn do they because uh
it's entertainment in the Champions
chest or Grand Final in the AI cup and I
want to challenge you guys first one to
be able to throw up the popcorn and grab
it with the mouth
oh
two times in a row can he keep going oh
wow oh my gosh yeah
I'll close Tanya up close oh yeah
ah it's a day for popcorn you guys and
uh you're gonna eat the popcorn right
now because we have something fun coming
up we're gonna see what went down when
David and Magnus played mini golf did
you enjoy that day David I did more than
I thought I would uh I'm a less
experienced golfer Magnus is a bit of a
pro uh relatively and yeah it was uh
memorable as people will find out all
right we we just have to go there let's
see what happened when David challenged
Magnus who is now a golf player recently
started playing the game uh but what
happened when David challenged him and
mini golf
we all know Magnus can beat me at chess
but can he beat me at golf we're gonna
find out who the better putter is
wait a sec okay uh cheating cheating
oh that was horrible now this is very
hard
oh
that's terrible
hit it as hard as I can
oh wow that was bad no that's okay I
think
oh my God
[Music]
okay hole in three yeah boys all levels
so far
oh really what the am I doing here
oh wow
look at this amateur
ah I'm gonna channel that famous golfer
David Howell he's actually a real person
okay
[Music]
thank you
if I don't get this I should retire
okay this one is hard
oh that's a terrible mess I can get it
there and then through
four okay
oh dear
oh wow no no
I did not realize it could even go off
the edge there yeah that's pretty bad
well that's not one yeah that's one
that's another one
okay I'm starting this home now you're
in like I'm on like five five yeah that
was my fourth day yeah okay now it's
fine
oh yes boys
nope it's gone
somewhere down there where on Earth is
this one
is the ball it came down this thing so
it's where's the bottom of this
I think it's supposed to come down here
actually through
yeah okay but that's that's just fun
[Music]
nice
that was not great
[Music]
I didn't prepare my shot
okay so now it's even we're level oh my
God I just have to try oh
[Music]
oh is this the right that's not what I
meant
three you're two ahead yeah
so this is just one yeah it's hole in
one or nothing so basically if you make
it and I don't then you win I win
otherwise I win oh my God good luck how
on Earth am I gonna that's just a
massive red light this is pretty dumb I
think I have to hit it a little bit a
little right
no that's the wrong way okay for All the
Glory Days okay one shots it's all been
leading up to this moment my career it's
my one shot my one opportunity to seize
nothing I Ever Wanted okay which way
around does it look up because I'm good
how am I supposed to do this though but
there's a massive thing in the way so we
have to go around ready
to do this
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
it's all in the name David Howell famous
golfer I think I've played this course
twice before none of the guys have ever
made this one
I can't believe it the grinder he always
makes a comeback David Howell wins the
match never underestimate a grinder we
always pull it out when we really need
to but I don't think it can get better
than that how do I top that and the
thing is the thing is so this is only
mini golf but you you mean it when you
celebrate there you just I don't know
anyone who loves winning more than you
do it's a chess play I think Winning is
Everything no matter how sneak you are
dirty about it like uh winning it's all
about the result we've seen it with a
go-karting the mini golf
we all want to win don't we Tanya so
competitive yeah I've seen it even it
was in this mini golf when you guys were
racing outside
magnets just got so competitive with
each other yeah
all right well it's all about becoming
competitive now for Magnus Carlsen he
needs to make a comeback in the match
against Mexico if he loses this game
three it's going to be over we are going
to head to the Grand Final reset MBL
will win this first match in the Grand
Final if he wins this game's read Magnus
calls he needs at least the door and he
has to make a comeback at some point
here uh this could be the game he will
have the white pieces snacking on
something right now Magnus to get his
energy levels up
and to get that win he needs what should
we expect then Tanya for 24. oh one D4
he goes for the same recipe the first
game it was exactly the Queen's Gambit
accepted but it's Magnus who switches it
up with a more attacking approach with
the move that we just saw on the board
yeah a much more ambitious approach here
Magnus Carlsen he seizes the center
black is still a pawn art but look at
all of that tension we talked about
tickling in the last game this is not
tickling this is just brute force in the
middle of the board and uh it is Maxine
to think first
this is still well known I'm expecting
Black's kingside Knight to develop right
now but there are solid ways to play
this depending on how Maxim is feeling
depending on his mood his preparation of
course uh Magnus
we're going with the golf analogy this
is more of a hole in one attempt you're
going really direct uh straight for
Glory none of this kind of slow
maneuvering none of the end games that
we've seen in the previous battle for
example
and this is much more aggressive chess
and Tania shipping up nicely but he
needs to at least get on par because uh
bogie would mean that Maxim barcelograph
can potentially take this in game three
and this kind of an opening is one for
all three results this has gone crazy
from the start yeah this has gone crazy
from the start and this was popularized
by uh mama jarrov when the with the
black pieces Jordan van Forrest where
the black pieces and very aggressive
players and that's why I think Magnus
has chose this uh it's now level
material he's won his Pawn back in the
center White's Pawn structure is
beautiful strategically long term white
is just winning but white is also behind
the development giving black some
chances Maxime leaning back looking
confident
um this last move Magnus just trying to
solidify his Pawn Center and black has
to strike quick remember white doing
well long term therefore Dynamics
short-term energy required from Black
yeah I'm expecting uh that c Pawn to
move up the board at some point I'm not
really sure how you actually set that up
but like you said that black needs to
strike quick uh to neutralize the spawn
Center that Magnus has managed to get
out of the opening C5 would be a break
that I would be looking for with the
black pieces in this one it also seems
like the kind of opening where you
really need to know what you're doing
because uh is just such such an
attacking position in what the first 10
moves yeah and uh for Maxi vashi degrov
slightly concerning that he doesn't
immediately recall what he should be
doing here as far as I remember this
last move for white maybe not the most
popular
so it did take him a little time to
adjust and eventually it Retreats this
night makes a lot of sense eliminating
White's powerful piece in the center of
the board we'll see a trade of knights
in the next turn
and uh okay Magnus is the first to pause
looks logical to me notice how Maxim
just for a few seconds he kind of had
his head and sounds looking down away
from the board away from the screen no
distraction just pure uh kind of delve
into the uh the Mind Palace the memory
banks and night back to D7 I believe is
his preparation yeah I think he knows
what he's doing but it's just about
recalling exactly how you want to
continue in this kind of a really
Dynamic approach by white uh because
again it's the kind of opening where you
if you make All the Right Moves you get
out of trouble really quickly but one
inaccuracy can mean you won the defense
for a really long time and we see a bit
of a pawn chain being formed there by
Maxim again I feel at some point you
have to get that C5 break in to get the
pawns rolling on the queen side and uh
let's do a bit of a deep dive here Tanya
I want your opinion first of all uh
we're gonna look at moves but also Pawn
structure who's do you prefer White's uh
nice Center here in the middle or do you
prefer this Pawn chain clamping down on
the queen side for black usually this
kind of Pawn structure happens when
white has an extra Pawn in the position
and it took me a while to realize that
actually it is materially balanced white
has uh sorry black has an extra Pawn
usually in these positions but it is
materially balanced I do like the center
I like that uh White has got full
control of the center and for maxim he's
got that double Pawn weakness it's not
it's not the typical forward system it's
a three and a half versus two yeah three
and a half versus two a nice way of
looking at it because it will be
difficult for black to actually push
those pawns long term whereas it's quite
straightforward for white to push these
pawns later
um you don't want to rush of course you
want to get your pieces into the game
maybe move the White Queen just connect
the white Rooks bring them towards the
center but uh yeah it's looking very
balanced right now and the big question
is how does white kind of Advance later
do you ever break this structure do you
ever try and break uh Black's pride and
joy you have to prepare this last move
of course maybe Quincy 2 and then point
to B3 or do you push the pawn to A4 and
for me I would love to break down this
strong point uh starting with the head
of the pawn chain but I don't know
whether you rush
that's the big question and when do you
exactly strike and speaking of striking
do you think on Maxim's radar is also a
strike in the center on the other side
of the board this last move of fan
countering the bishop to B7 is F5
something that he's thinking about makes
a lot of sense especially now you have a
piece it's staring at a concrete wall of
Pawns right now you need to break the
concrete erode it in order to give this
piece life uh so yeah Pawn to F5 is
blacks
agenda basically right now and maybe
Pawn to A4 on White's radar I'm
expecting Magnus though to take a time
out just move his Queen uh at least kind
of improving your pieces before the
action begins but Magnus looking down
now he's kind of replicating uh kind of
copying the post that Maxime showed a
few minutes ago
because he was trying to remember
something I have no doubt that both
players are familiar with the types of
plans the types of ideas we did see a
pawn push and black
he's locked in his Bishop Tanya slightly
surprising but it was more important to
keep that pawn chain intact yes
absolutely because if you did push the
pawn it might be tempting to go ahead
with that b-pawn hit that white knight
but you create so many weaknesses on the
king's side so really important to keep
things solid on the queen side so it's
temporary that you've put this bishop
behind your pawn it does look a bit of a
big Pawn right now rather than a bishop
but black always has the option to open
it up at the right time with the c Pawn
moving forward and this last move to me
seems to imply that that other break
that we're talking about with the F Pawn
moving forward targeting magnus's Center
we might see that at some point in the
game I think it's very likely and wow
it's Magnus to step forward first uh not
the type of move you would usually see
it looks a bit Hasty here looks a bit
premature because you're kind of losing
lots of flexibility now your Pawn
structure is fixed you won't step
forward much further in the center but
he's clearing a nice Square for his
Knight Tanya he is carrying a really
nice Square for the Knight and there's a
nice Square cleared for Maxim's 9 side
as well I'm looking at ways of actually
forcing white to take a decision on the
queen side and especially this last move
that Magnus has made really invites
Maxim's knight from D7 to jump to B6 I'm
now targeting your A4 Pawn so first you
need to take a decision around that and
then I'm also eyeing that D5 square that
your last move has left behind yeah and
outposts are the name of the game when
it comes to Knights this is a beautiful
Outpost for black snipe it can never be
challenged by a pawn and this is a nice
post it can be challenged by a pawn for
white but you will jump in it's kind of
a launch pad for even stronger squares
so it's really unclear who this favor is
it's committal by Magnus Carlson maybe
he's just trying to cut the board in
half here he's only playing on the king
side and he's thinking okay I'm going to
start pushing pawns towards the black
king
I think in this kind of almost muscle
situation for Magnus he's just got
aggression on his mind nothing else and
I think this must be his plan it looks
like cave Manchester's push bones go for
checkmate but sometimes it can be
effective especially with this type of
structure okay the bar slightly going up
for Magnus here with this Rook move
definitely dramatic in any way I
wouldn't say dramatic it just feels slow
from Russia the graph for this last move
he played it very kind of quickly he
leans back he looks very comfortable but
it doesn't really threaten anything it's
kind of a move you play when you don't
really want to calculate and I think
this type of position you have to be a
bit more direct a bit more active all
right well this is uh the Grand Final in
division one I'm gonna give you guys an
update on division two and three now
there's some drama going on in division
three first of all Sam Savion coming
from the losers bracket has just won the
Grand Final against Ralph mamadom and
that means that is going to a grand
final reset to decide the winner and if
the winner is Sam Savion that's actually
going to be his third division three win
this season uh incredible stuff from The
Young American so that's going on now
the Grand Final reset in division three
in division two we have fedosev of
course keeping a close eye on him
because if MBL does not win this Grand
Final in division one
a chance if he wins division two to be
the one to grab that final ticket to
Toronto and last time I checked he was
in the lead in The Grand Final there
against artemiev is he still he's still
in the lead they're playing their fourth
and final game of the Grand Final if he
draws that one he looks like he's in a
good position as well if he draws that
one he's one division two and that means
all hope is out for Jana palmyachi
sitting at home uh if Federal Sev wins
division two and Miel does not win
division one then it's Fantasia going to
Toronto then if MBL wins division one it
is MBL going to Toronto we are keeping a
close eye on all the action happening
mvl he is in the lead in this Grand
Final against Magnus and he has to win
this match to take it to a grand final
reset what do you think will happen in
this game three will we have this match
decided mvl win it we will have the
reset or do you think Magnus will make a
comeback black
feels like a decisive result is brewing
its incoming Magnus okay going pure
aggression now throwing all the pawns
forward it's just so hard to imagine any
scenario where this is a draw unless
both players somehow come up with
counter play unless it heads down to an
end game but we're miles away from that
Tanya really I I agree with everything
that you just said I think decisive
result is what's going to happen here
and that last move by Maxime of getting
the root card I just wonder if we saw
the eval bar shoot up because it's just
a tiny bit slow the position just
demands so much action uh from black
immediately trying to create counter
Play Because magnus's idea is clearly f
is clear F4 F5 F6 go for Checkmate on
the king side and he started he's on
that path already meanwhile the big
question is what did Maxime achieve with
moving that Rook from f8 to uh to the
Central Square and that could be the
critical moment because it feels as if
Maxine had to get his counter play going
on the queen side before Magnus starts
with the spawn roll yeah I remember when
I was a young player and I used to play
moves like Rook to E8 because they look
nice they improved the pieces but one of
my coaches said that's just the lazy
move what are you doing you're not
calculating you're not actually uh kind
of reacting to your opponent's threats
and here it's as if this Rook is on a
nice file but it's staring against the
wall of Pawns maybe it all come in handy
later it is on a better Square than it
previously stood but black could have
been using that time to break in the
center to improve this Knight to an
outpost and now the problem for maxim is
if he does continue moving his Knight
then uh firstly this Knight is jumping
into the center into some holes and
actually this black Rook is a target if
anything exactly that's the other
drawback of the move Rook to E8 and you
also have the option of just advancing
the F Bond but Maxim takes a huge
decision I think he's he realized all
these dangers that exist with the Knight
jumping to E4 the F1 advancing and we
see him do that himself so F5 on the
board it's a break that we were talking
about early on well this time it's more
of a defensive move than an aggressive
move stopping White's play onpassar is
not an option because notice how the
bishop on E3 is tender so things have to
be kept locked up in the center and for
now at least magnus's pawn star has been
stalled it has been installed but now
any end game will be favorable for white
due to this protected past Pawn in the
center uh you can never ever trade it
away and it will be ready to run if all
the pieces disappear or tie down Black's
pieces forever so end games will now
favor white maximum he's banking on the
fact that he can get his Knight to D5
and just blockade in this middle game
just set up a wall and uh yeah it's all
on the light squares it just depends
whether Magnus can break through if you
can't capture on person I'm wondering in
a must-win situation whether he starts
throwing other pawns forward uh Pawn to
G4 for example just get rid of this one
and just throw everything towards the
black king risky but it's a very kind of
typical thing to do when the center is
locked to start switching your attention
to the flanks and risk is the name of
the game for Magnus right he has to
create his chances uh David we are going
to see G4 I think at some point in this
game because it's really the path to
open up your pawns moving forward I I
won't be surprised if we see it on this
very move G4 it does look very scary
because you're potentially opening up
that Bishop on B7 for black as well once
that c pawn moves forward you've got to
watch out for any ideas on this long
diagonal but with all the squares under
control the central White's Bishop
coming to defense on F3 it doesn't feel
like it will be enough to actually
create a checkmating attack for Magnus
the big question does he make a slower
move like perhaps Queen coming to C2
targeting that F5 Pawn which has been
just pushed forward provoke Maxim to
make some more weaknesses on the king
side provoke him to play a move like G6
before he does strike with G4 or does he
play it on this move yeah I like your
idea a bit better might as well just
improve the queen and get this Rook
closer to joining the action for later
and then you push and like you said
you've slightly loosened slightly uh
eroded the white uh the black King's
position as well evaluation Bar says
very strong for Magnus Carlson it's far
from uh obvious for any human that it's
this good for white but uh those plans
we mentioned pushing the pawn it would
mean that things get really spicy and it
looks like the structure does favor
white so vashilograph he's kind of
gambled on this blockade
it should be broken by Magnus Carlson
right now I think Magnus due to the fact
he's one point down will go for this
idea if it was level scores he might
play a slower more strategic
kind of approach here but go for it G4
for the score G4 for the score and Maxim
is definitely on the back foot in this
one and he's got to be feeling the
pressure because he's got his bond
majority on the other side of the board
on the queen side but he hasn't really
managed to make any progress no pawn
move is actually possible on that side
of the board meanwhile Magnus is the one
with all the flexibility on the King's
Island that's the side where Maxim's
King is on so this is looking very
dangerous for black it might just be the
game that Magna Strikes Back enjoy that
message from hello kittycambe when you
got a shower before work but Magnus is
about to play for a win with the white
pieces and remember we want to see your
pictures of how you are watching the
Grand Final share them on Twitter or X
using the hashtag chess champs for a
chance to win this everything's wave
mini we want to see how you guys are
enjoying this Friday with some great
chess so please share
Magnus has spent again more time Dan
Miel in this game I feel I remember from
the winners final that it was NBL
playing slower today it seems like
Magnus is the one playing slower yeah it
definitely feels like magnus's
uncharacteristically slow at this point
uh often he's playing quite
instinctively and keeps the time
Advantage into the end game pressures
this opponents there but I think he's
spending time because this position is
really reminiscent of two days ago in
the fact it's just wild imbalanced it's
a bit crazy you rarely see the type of
Pawn structure and Tanya we were both a
bit surprised I saw your reaction uh
just after white pushed in the center D5
yeah one thing's for sure this is the
wildest game that we've had uh so far in
today's matches both games have been
strategic fights before this one and
this is blowing up it's got everything
to do with the math situation David D5
did take me by surprise you were looking
at the other break with the Jeep on
moving forward and the first thing that
crossed my mind here was that isn't
white just losing that Central Pawn
because notice how two pieces defend it
and black has got two pieces attacking
the D5 square but you can actually trade
the bishop on A5 for the Knight on C3
and I see the evolved by this approves
but the point was that if white was to
recapture on C3 black picks up the D5
pawn and wow seems to say that this is
really bad where is the compensation
here yeah I mean you have control you
have nice dark Square control this
bishop has a nice home in the center
Tanya I think we're going to find out I
think we're going to see this exact
variation Maxine did capture the
alternative I will just mention was to
drop back and actually start trading
pieces off I would have loved to trade
off this bishop but Maxim he's going for
the material everyone here and Magnus
has paused because after Bishop takes
Knight it's not obligatory to recapture
the top players in the world they always
look for options in every position they
don't automatically play uh the most
obvious move sometimes there's a hidden
resource and he could take on C6 making
sure that he doesn't lose a pawn now
this is a double attack I think black
should just take back and it's the same
position essentially Tanya but without
Black's d-pawn on the board but that's a
decision that black would be really
happy with because your Bishop is
suddenly Super Active so Magnus can't
have that in his mind at the back of his
mind that seems to work in Maxim's favor
and I think we're getting moves in that
Magnus actually intend on sacrificing
that Central Pawn it has been captured
and now Magnus has to prove his
compensation here he has to prove his
compensation is that going for the
Central Pawn is that again going for
this idea we mentioned earlier going for
the black king
Magnus has to be really quick he's just
a pawn down there are some tricky double
attack ideas such as this move maybe uh
just the queen to B1 hitting this Pawn
putting some pressure here the
evaluation Bar says no
maybe these pawns aren't the most
relevant factor in the position the one
thing Magnus has to watch out for is the
Black Knight rerouting to f8 and then to
sit on this Square any past Pawn should
be blockaded by Knight and if black gets
his Knight round I think black is doing
extremely extremely well so Magnus only
has one or two moves to strike
the evaluation bar otherwise will drop
back down maybe even in Black's favor
Big Stuff happening in this game and I
have big news division two is finished
the federal Sav has won the Grand Final
and that means if mvl does not win the
Grand Final it is federal sale going to
Toronto all hope is now out for janachi
fedozer will now sit down and follow
this match so closely he needs Magnus
Carlsen to win the grand final he is
probably liking what he is seeing right
now the bar is way up for Magnus at this
point 100 I think if he would have
joined the match a little earlier he
wouldn't have been too happy but it's
too soon for farazier to start
celebrating he's done his job what
needed to be done and now it all comes
down to this one so Maxim his fate is on
is in his own hands but the position
seems like it's completely out of
control right now uh Maxine up upon
Magnus with the bishop bear with the
initiative the time is of the essence
here he needs to make sure that Maxine
doesn't manage to reroute his Knight to
the center of the board David is it time
for Magnus now to go ahead with that
break that we're talking about is my
first question and second would you
rather be white or black hair
oh I think I would need all of magnus's
remaining time to correctly assess this
one if I were playing if I didn't see
the evaluation bar
um the thing is I would take white Now
with uh full knowledge of what the plans
are with a bit of time but if I were
playing this over the board I'm not sure
I would think that black has a very very
safe healthy position here it looks like
the black king is not going to come
under Fire it looks like you simply have
an extra Pawn Black's Knight is coming
around to some good squares as we
pointed out and there we go already the
bar starting to drop down Magnus maybe
should have taken that one opportunity
to start throwing his pawns forward
against the black king because now black
will be reacting and uh okay a very
natural move at least a hit on the black
F5 Pawn do we expect black to defend it
you've got to defend that if you lose
that pawn then you just allow a Magnus
to storm through on the king's side G6
would be the first move that comes to my
mind just join the party defend your
piece your pawns On the Border I think
G4 the other idea that we've been
talking about hoping to be played on the
board we're gonna see it at some point
but Magnus delays that decision for now
the other advantage of this last move is
that it connects to Rook so now you can
also look at The Rook coming onto the
d-line if Magnus wants a slower approach
and start targeting that D5 Pawn but it
just looks like a slower approach won't
cut it in this one once Black's Knight
lands on that E6 Square I would really
start liking Maxim's position so it
really boils down to the next three
moves yeah this is the critical moment I
think everything will be decided in the
next few turns at least two holds the
advantage and uh just to show what
Magnus couldn't should have done he
should have thrown the pawn forward
first I can understand why he was scared
here because the white king looks like
it's really open this diagonal about to
explode the black queen may be coming in
but after a trade of Pawns here white
simply is too quick I think he he would
have been able to force his pawns
through maybe with the help of his
Bishop in the center but he didn't go
for this and now the key question okay
he does he does now finally go for it
Magnus Carlson he's playing for the win
G4
butterfly for the win and this is a move
that we've all been waiting for and it's
happened G4 Magnus delayed it but
eventually it's on the board and this
gets absolutely out of control now David
we've got to do a deep dive on the
options that Maxime has here yeah and
whose King is weaker that's the big
question we'll most likely see this Pawn
captured uh the white Bishop will take
back and now white is seriously
threatening to stop pushing some pawns
forward if white gets time to blockade
with his Bishop in the center for
example if black plays a slow move if
white gets the time to plant this bishop
then Black's counterpart here this black
Bishop will be dead is staring at this
pawn and there's no way to fight the
advance the Avalanche and look at this
Maxine vashilograph such creative play
amazing play right now he doesn't even
react he throws a Pawn off the board he
says take my pawn and look at this
Knight to C5
wow this is crazy he's giving up a whole
night now a sacrifice if this Knight is
captured Queen to D5 threatens Checkmate
on G2 using this battery he actually
used in the first game to and uh now
taking this bishop back next move this
is just another level Tanya of tactics
the Knight giving itself up on an empty
Square this is another level of Chess
that we're seeing Knight C5 a move that
had to be preempted by Maxim vashiella
grab as a resource in this position to
go through with it to give up that deep
on in the center opening up his own
Bishop this is Maxine really at his best
and Magnus has been talking about his
tier one Rivals I think today what we're
seeing this is tier one Chess at least
for this day Maxine washer is a tier 1
rival for Magnus for sure and I think
throughout this tournament he's proved
himself tier one Maxim vashilograph and
Magnus should not take this Knight do
not get tempted it is poisoned I think
this would actually give black the
advantage and uh taking this bishop next
move the threat of Checkmate it would be
too much for Magnus to handle uh too
much of a turn I think you should ignore
this and maybe just capture this Pawn
because he can meet this threat of
checkmate with a block White's Bishop is
able to block the queen and this would
be white Advantage so I think right now
Pawn takes Pawn is the key move and uh
will he find it will he play it that's
the big question
even if it means double pawns even if it
means
and okay he doesn't go for this uh very
tempting as well to take this Pawn
instead he wants to maybe trade Rooks
first and only then later take on the F5
Square yeah and it's so important that
when the Rooks do get traded Maxim has
to recapture with the bishop and not the
queen because remember the queen needs
to land on that D5 Square to make all
the tactics work for the attack on the
king side Maxim has slowed down because
there is an option there are inter
methods that exist including that Bishop
from B7 in the live position in the
current position to actually jump over
to E4 and hit a white screen taking away
some of the pressure from that F5 pawn
and only then do you start thinking
about maybe even another Intermezzo with
the Knight jumping on to B3 David I'm
attacking your Rook I'm attacking your
Bishop so many options and about five
and a half minutes on the clock to make
a decision yeah I think we need that
popcorn where's the popcorn things
gonna sit and watch because uh Maxim
here's a big decision to make
[Laughter]
David we need you to to stay with your
analysis board this is just crazy what's
going on and I'm looking at the clocks
as well Magnus is down to two and a half
minutes on his clock and this must be
tense and difficult to play yeah really
hard to navigate so as tania's pointed
out there's three or four options for
black here alone and uh every move for
white as well there are several tempting
moves and they'll all lead to different
types of complications okay Magnus does
go for this and Maxim throws another
spanner in the work he jumps in with his
Knight oh blunder
okay he's trying to break the connection
between White's Queen I've got so much
popcorn in my mouth
he's trying to break the connection
between White's queen and the rest of
the position and wow
Tanya just pulled into F6 just so calm
apparently he's winning for Magnus just
push those Pawns in the center I was
actually going to suggest the second
move as well you can just take on G6 he
goes with your idea upon moving forward
because the last one that Maxim just
blitzed out he played it so quickly
which was so surprising in a high
responsibility position like this one it
doesn't really attack anything that
night on D3 looks really pretty but your
move Queen to D5 can be stuck with the
bishop jumping onto that F3 there are no
checkmates on that diagonal it just gets
challenged immediately uh did Maxine
just rush in with the Knight rushing on
to D3 yeah I think uh it's a blunder not
for kind of tactical means here it's
just a long-term strategic blunder
you've allowed White's pawns to live and
advance and you have no come to play
yourself I think he's just missed
something here Tanya I think he was
relying on some tricks and tactics so
let's just jump back to show the mistake
from vashilograph we were praising him
and rightly so uh in this position he
had some tempting moves he could have
brought his Bishop to the center as you
mentioned hitting the queen maybe taking
this Pawn next move he could have jumped
the other way with the Black Knight
hitting this bishop at least now white
wouldn't have the luxury of time to push
pawns instead he moved his Knight into
the center but this does nothing it
threatens nothing and these pawns now
are going to prove decisive
I understand nothing to do I understand
him wanting to block the queen and the
pawn putting pressure on the king side
but this just allows a really strong but
and also an extra Pawn for white and a
really strong one on F6 and like you're
pointing out the white spawns are coming
down the Pod the other Pawn joins the
party with F4 the only counter-attacking
chances that I see for black is this
open diagonal the long diagonal but
that's easily defended by a White's
Bishop yeah I don't understand what he's
missed Queen to D5 Bishop blocks and
it's game over uh you cannot give up the
black queen right now as soon as you
start retreating White's pawns will be
decisive now any end game white is
winning as well
I think he was just hoping in this
position that white would get uh naive
here get greedy and take this Knight off
the board and suddenly opposite color
Bishops black would be the one striking
on the light squares coming in and uh
big attack but here we go Maxine Rachel
grub has to fight he's trying to get his
Queen into the position and look the
computer just for a second there showed
the winning move block this diagonal
stop the black queen coming in continue
pushing your pawns go for the black king
it is winning for Magnus can he finish
it off that's the big question
hey it looks like he's super close to
doing just that and I think the point of
going ahead with that pawn is not only
to block the queen a Magnus is thinking
about it but if Maxime was to recapture
it it gives white the option to actually
jump in with the bishop onto an attack
Bishop H5 looks like a really strong
move here David you're not only hitting
the Rook but the F Pawn is moving down
the board yeah this would be a decisive
track any pawn track now would end the
game and Magnus Retreats his Queen he's
allowing The Black Queen in this is
really risky from Magnus
counterintuitive he wants to use his
Bishop along this diagonal to block kick
her out maybe but Queen to H3 would
threaten Checkmate and he would be
forced to trade off Bishops Maxim though
wow he's going all in
why is he not looking at the white king
why is he playing on the other side of
the board this is really inconsistent
he's playing on the king side then
suddenly switching to the queen side and
now Magnus has the time to kick away the
black queen this is gonna be game over
this Pawn is going to advance then this
one is going to advance
yeah he's trying to destabilize that
Bishop in the center but he doesn't have
any time to do
that you can move to the center of the
board and now Magnus will drop back with
that Bishop hit the queen defend the
Checkmate in one Maxim has nothing
better than to retreat with the queen
what he's counting on is that you can't
take on B4 because the bishop on D4 is
hanging but now the strongest piece on
the board from Maxine washer is no more
on the board yeah the Bishops have just
been traded and now I'm expecting
magnets to start going in moving in for
the kill is all to do with these pawns
these three pawns are gonna clinch it
for him okay first he improves the queen
very logical but those pawns will start
rolling soon and that will spell the end
of this game
the magnets down to about a minute on
the clock uh still some things to play
for here that as long as that Knight
stays on D3 you've got Queens on the
board it's maybe not completely over
David and we know that Maxine plays for
tricks yes and one minute off one minute
I think if this were a classical game a
even a rapid game Magnus would uh cruise
to Victory here but yeah nerves could
still kick in especially when it's queen
of night versus queen and Bishop great
combo there and I have to say in my film
he has shown uh Fearless in this game
right he has played uh just throwing his
pieces in this in this game and it was
perfect play till that moment that he
rushed in with his Knight to that D3
Square where where we see it we're doing
a little bit too much and I think he
played it so fast that is what was
surprising to me Kaya because he had
about five and a half minutes on the
clock at that time Magnus was down to
about two and a half a really wild on
clear position and I think it was that
moment that it all turned around giving
Magnus the possibility to build this uh
these three pawns down the board that
we're seeing right now and Maxine is he
thinking about jumping in with the Rook
to the second rank or is he just
regretting some of the decisions of the
past probably a bit of both probably
getting a bit nervous now and he doesn't
go for something active those were the
two options to go active with the black
Rook or to go into a passive post and
wow Magnus is thrown up way upon to get
at the black king where is the finishing
touch the black king Now is really open
those two pawns around it as well thorns
in that black king side feels like
checkmates somewhere Tanya but where is
the killer blow Magnus needs to get his
queen or his rook in to check that black
king somehow you you won those pieces on
the G line uh and it's so tempting to
start with a check with the queen
because I don't think that black skin
can actually go to h8 but Magnus has a
difference
why is he going into an end game he
could have gone for checkmate now black
has some really dangerous pawns oh the
bar goes down bar goes down there was a
threat white was threatening towards F7
with a deadly check so black had to take
out the time to block allowing Magnus to
trade something but okay it's only a one
Pawn advantage and while the evaluation
bar is completely gone oh and Magnus
reacts I think he's just lost control I
think he's annoyed at the type of
position he suddenly got black has a
blockade on the light Square suddenly if
the Rooks are gone it is a draw and it
was so tempting to just give a check and
try and at least think if there's a way
to end the game on the spot but Magnus
going for the same game and Maxime is
back now he's touching the one minute
Mark but it all relies on this counter
play with the c Pawn moving forward
Magnus with a big threat he wants to
give a check with the rook and then push
the E Pawn for the further up the board
is it time to actually challenge The
Rook David like you said if the Rooks
come off it could very well be the end
of the game yeah I think he would love
to trade Rooks off right now he can't
quite because white would give a check
with his uh Pawn so I think maybe just
enter the center Black's King can act up
to blockade there we go if the white
Rook tries to sneak behind the Black
Knight is actually able to control some
checking squares there we go there's no
way to check the black king anymore
black has a perfect light squared
blockade white only has a dark Square
bishop and can't stop the march of the
Black Sea Pawn wow and the king and
Knight playing in such Perfect Harmony
defending everything on the center while
The Rook assists the black pawn down the
board it feels like all of Maxim's
pieces are suddenly in the right spot
Magnus looking for a check along the
flank he needs to find a way to start
pushing that E Pawn
I've got the black king it shouldn't
walk back it shouldn't Retreat right now
because it would walk into a check
therefore it goes forward and Magnus is
banking everything on his pawns but this
is risky Magnus is playing with fire
Suddenly It's a race could MBL even win
this game definitely yeah it's okay
position for three years old and I think
what Magnus is counting on is if MBL
pushes that c Pawn he wants to go Rook
to C6 on that c line let's show this
Tanya that's an amazing spot a great
tactic right now if black pushes this
might backfire if my if fashion isn't
careful The Rook was at would act as a
deflection giving itself up in order for
white to make a new Queen now the black
Rook would no longer cover this square
and the evaluation bar going crazy there
but uh this queen check notably it comes
with checks so black has no time to
promote the next move white can stop the
pawn from pushing and okay he didn't go
for this really surprising it feels like
both players are missing stuff right now
uh the white Bishop drops back the black
Rook attacks this pawn and Maxim now I
think he's trying to play Safety First
chess he's just trying to remove the
white pawns if white steps forward with
this one think he can Retreat his Knight
with a double attack just about holding
and just by the skin of his teeth saving
the draw and it's so important that
white can't go E7 right now because then
you just simply take that F7 pawn and
the Knight also controls the very key
queening Square on E8
beautiful flexibility there from Ashley
Graf but let's get that popcorn back out
will he find that move he has to retreat
his Knight does it he does find it the
only move to draw there I believe and uh
of course these top players they find
the best move time and time again
he's got to make a move he does he's
still keeping his chances alive but not
anymore this is going to end in a draw
whoa
what a game and I think we have we do
have our results we have a result it's a
draw wow that was up and down Magnus
about to make a comeback but mvl saves
the game he is still in the lead here in
the Grand Final and that means with a
draw or a win in game four we are going
to the reset it is going to be must win
for Magnus Carlsen in game four what
happened here Tonya I mean it looked
like certainty that minus would win this
game at some point it really did uh he
played incredible chess and then Maxine
played that and some Moira but Magnus
was in driver's seat for the most part
of it and it looked like this was going
to be his comeback game but some key
resourceful moves by Maxim save the day
and now he just needs a draw and I think
the craziness continues but the good
news for maxim is he starts with the
white pieces the next one oh that's true
this was a golden opportunity for Magnus
yeah huge opportunity and a missed
opportunity in the end for Magnus
Carlson but well done to vashilograph
for fighting uh like a lion there to
save it and Magnus the key conceptual
mistake was trading the Queens he had
the safer King keeping the Queens on the
board should have guaranteed a Checkmate
and it was here where he made the
Fateful decision to take this pawn and
as we saw later after the Queens
disappeared black was able to set up a
blockade on the light squares and save
the draw If instead he had kept the
Queens on actually multiple winning
moves here for example giving a check
then surely he would have clinched the
full point the king moves and suddenly
White's Rook could enter the other side
of the board crashing through
infiltrating the seventh Rank and this
would be decisive maybe what Magnus had
missed was that after Rook to G8 looks
like a pin there was the winning move
Pawn to E6 a check deflecting The Black
Queen suddenly another check and blacks
defenses collapse this is a very natural
play he would have found it but the
clock played its part wow and the drama
continues you guys game four in the
Grand Final is coming up if Magnus
Carlsen wins we will head to Armageddon
if he loses or MBL uh or it is a draw
then we are going to the Grand Final
reset so more games to come stay with us
we'll be right back
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things have a friend or family member
who loves chess give them a chess.com
membership today and see them take their
game to the next level you can choose a
gold platinum or Diamond membership for
one month or one year
want your gift to arrive on your
friend's birthday or on a holiday gifts
can be scheduled to arrive up to 90 days
in the future
all premium plans include an ad-free
experience unlimited puzzles and lessons
and unlock all Bots go platinum to add
unlimited game review or Diamond to
unlock insights and Coach explanations
give the gift of Chess today
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the AI Cup in
this tournament we have been very
excited that chess.com is partnering up
with the browser maker Oprah Making
just a chess themed browser it's awesome
you guys and it is something for chess
lovers everywhere it truly puts the game
right at your fingertips and that's
exactly what's gonna happen right now
using the Opera browser David is now
going to play bullet chess again someone
you know very well David you have
received a challenge from our main man
in the control room Oscar oh are you
nervous now I am a bit nervous I must
admit I don't have the best mouse in the
world but we're gonna dive into the up
for browser yet again and uh I'm gonna
play this bullet game against my good
friend uskill who's actually a very
strong player a speed demon so here we
see the Opera browser really slick
really nice and uh the chess.com
shortcut for anyone who wants to play
chess sneakily at work and
okay hopefully he's challenged me I
don't see it right now I might have to
jump in and challenge him where are you
asking Connie and I are eating popcorn
okay I'm gonna type in this is gonna be
everyone gets asking his username now
there we go here we go I'm sending off a
challenge because I'm desperate to play
some bullet and game on
my favorite caracon defense I'm gonna
take trade off some pieces hopefully
and I'm gonna go with all the pre-moves
hopefully he's not watching
have you ever beaten you David
um yet not yet there's the first time
for everything though and okay my
beloved carry Khan
I'm gonna keep pushing
and okay
oh
he's coming for my king he's coming for
the black king I'm gonna threaten a
sneaky attack now on the A2 Pawn he
blocks
oh I've won a pawn Tanya
what do you think this is getting super
tricky I've never seen David So
competitive in one of these he knows
he's playing Oscar he's ready for this
one while David really going fast
because Kenya you seen you saw the golf
you know how competitive I am I'll never
live it down if I lose this game but I'm
trying to get four uh trying to get to
that white king nice move that if I
asked killed it makes David pause really
nice move he's gonna attack my queen and
now I'm gonna move it and hope and now
okay I've got a pawn chain
how am I gonna be boring here and try to
grind it out oh okay let's go
you know me Tanya Queen's off the board
just like Magnus did in that last game
this time I'm a few pawns up though and
okay 27 seconds against 21 he's so quick
our skill I'm a bit nervous oh this is
going to be about flagging it has to
pre-move he has to pre-move Bishop
barefo has killed a few extra pawns for
David okay rolling
pawns are coming
uh how flashy can I be here no that
doesn't work I was gonna try something a
bit sneaky okay I'm gonna take this Pawn
he sees it that's going to use the big
threat he sees all the threats
okay I was nearly gonna play it Rook to
d8 that would have Blended a whole Rook
oh my God the tension he's coming for me
he's coming for me but the clock though
nice nice one okay good playing there I
was like I wish we had an image of you
in the control room right now good game
good game against Grandmaster David
Howell all right this is the AI cup we
are waiting for game four in the Grand
Final before the tournament we called up
some of the players and asked them if
they are skip sorry scared of robots
taking over the world
are you scared of robots taking over the
world uh like intuitive I think it's a
matter
of for everyone like it's
really not robots taking over the world
doesn't really occupy my Minds
I do accept that it may be a possibility
so you know for this sort of stuff I
have very you know
pragmatic way of saying you know it's
absolutely out of my control so whatever
happens happens and if you could program
a robot to do anything in your
imagination to do one thing for you
every single day what would that be well
you know I spent so much time analyzing
chess uh it would be nice if the it will
be like a good
robots I would analyze chess like it
would be nice then I you I could focus
on uh playing Blitz you know and
spending time with my family and uh
and get all the all the good Novelties
you know right in my in my inbox I don't
know work until so please probably
it's a cleaning I mean that's the one
thing I cannot do for
for the life of me
bring me my slippers now
she has slippers all right it's about to
get very dramatic but we are so much
enjoying this final day in the AI cup
and we are enjoying seeing you guys do
the same thing let's take a look at some
of the pictures you have shared on
Twitter using just Champs
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome to see the kids also enjoying
the chess I also loved some of you on
the train home from a long week it's
Friday some of you still at work but
remember weekend is coming in right now
game four is coming here in the Grand
Final mvl is in the lead that means it's
must win now for Magnus Carlsen to take
this to Armageddon this is definitely
not the last game of the Grand Final we
will either go to Armageddon or we will
go to a grand final reset so lean back
and just buckle up because this is going
to be interesting Magnus is snacking up
getting his energy levels to the top
it's going to be MBL with the white
pieces he only needs to join this one to
go to the reset so what should we expect
I think he'll stick to his guns and
continue playing this strategy we saw in
game two of the day he was able to get a
relatively painless draw uh quite safe
play there
just two games ago and Magnus switches
it up no more Berlin defense of course
it's the curry Khan he can't affordable
in defense he goes for the same opening
I think he was inspired by a bullet game
right now against saskill so we're
seeing the Carol again and this one and
we've seen Magnus have this approach
with the Carolina must win situation
that's right and actually the players
already have had this exact position
against each other in this tournament in
the Armageddon game two days ago uh
Magnus also employed the karakan it will
not have come as a surprise and they had
this position against each other okay
there Maxim pushed his H Pawn went
really aggressive of course in a
situation where a draw is enough he
doesn't need to do that and okay a pawn
push Magnus playing very much in the
style of AI Alpha zero pushing pawns
gaining space on the flanks computers
really endorse this especially when the
center is blocked interesting play Tanya
really interesting play and uh Magnus
just blitzing out his moves Maxine the
first one to take a think right now
Maxine needs only a draw in this in this
game and that psychologically is such a
battle because when the chances happen
do you keep it safe you try to keep it
safe because that can backfire
especially against the against Magnus
Carlsen or will he try to take those
opportunities uh and make the position
Brash because a Carol and this A5 A4
approach by Magnus surely signals that
Magnus wants a long game
I think it's an inspired Choice by
Magnus no matter what the result
eventually because here at least he
keeps pieces on the board and yeah we
said this time and time again when
players are in muscle in situations I
think this goes for everyone at home as
well if you're desperate to win and uh
don't want to risk any end games any uh
kind of simple draws or allow your
opponent to force the issue then you've
got to pick your openings wisely but
keep his Thunderball tends to be the key
so just a and deep salt here from the
corner so Magnus would he actually
prefer the Armageddon or would he maybe
even prefer the reset another match with
two rapid games
I think he'll take the Armageddon purely
because he knows that worst case he'll
have that reset um
if he didn't have the reset I think
he'd prefer more games rather than one
one game shootout hmm and it was the
Armageddon that got him the win last
time in his match against uh Maxim so
he's definitely looking for that win
there's no question about that he hasn't
given up on this match just yet okay and
that's very clear from his opening
approach because if he was getting ready
for the Grand Final reset he would have
probably just gone ahead with the Berlin
approach but karakan means he's up for a
fight in this one and we're seeing a
very imbalanced position already where
black has got this eternal control over
that Central D5 Square bit is slightly
behind in development and Maxim should
try and make the most of that lead in
development over the next few moves and
how would you start in trying to achieve
that yeah I was going to say this move
is very tempting uh trying to create
another imbalance and this time Black's
most active piece most valuable piece
right now is the light Square Bishop and
he's hunting it down he's going to trade
it off guaranteed now for one of the
white Knights Pawn structure tends to
favor knights in these types of
positions Natalia so I don't think it's
the end of the world from Magnus Carlson
but that light Square Bishop was really
strong uh makes a lot of sense to do
this I think if White had been too slow
just over the last couple of moves let's
jump in and show this uh then Magnus
would have been able to create a bind uh
right now that's not possible because he
has to deal with this threat but if
Maxine for example had been a bit lazy
here and just moved his Bishop then
suddenly the Black Knight is coming into
the center this is a uh just beautiful
Outpost the night supported by its other
Knights and black will simply move the
bishop out and Castle instead we see
some developments the Knight did hunt
this bishop Magnus forced this uh issue
here by pushing a pawn threatening now
trying to retreat this bishop it was of
course chopped off Maxim defended his
Pawn in the center and Magnus now
continuing to gain space
really thematic stuff he's trying to
develop this bishop to a really nice
Square either this one or activate his
Rook even and uh do you really want to
allow this Pawn to live Maxine says no
because this Pawn might even become a
queen later in the game yeah that's such
a big
ger would be the natural move the
natural response but that Bond on A3
will give black so much so many chances
throughout even in the end game and
Maxime wants to keep that pressure I
think the move that you were alluding to
is still possible developed that Bishop
to B4 a really tying down a White Queen
side there and also threatening a a
trade on B2 next yeah that would be a
really nice move the most logical reply
would be White's Queen for example
coming forward and Magnus would have to
evaluate the consequences of this one
the one thing you don't want to do as
black is ever trade because then now you
open up lines while you're undeveloped
while the black King's still stuck in
the middle and suddenly threats appear
um so Magnus has to be careful he has to
develop I think this is the most natural
move uh it's the move he wants to play
but if he can't make that work maybe
he'll just develop and get his King to
safety before worrying about any
concrete action
yeah and even the white has got the
bishop as black you never really want to
take on E3 unless there's a concrete
follow-up to that option because you end
up giving wide a lot of activity on the
F line The Rook is already lined up F7
becomes a really tender point in that
situation and in this opposite color
Bishop the light Square Bishop that
white has it will have a clear Target
even in some positions Landing up on H5
or D3 as you're pointing out so you
really have to wait before you uh
capture that Bishop on E3 I do like that
Knight on F5 that's placed Magnus does
develop but to another Square he starts
with the move Bishop to E7 and this
gives Maxim some time to respond now
yeah some time to respond one option for
example would be to open up the B file
but I don't think you really want to do
this while the black Rook can pounce and
come into play with gain of time and uh
therefore he plays a really cunning move
I was going to point this out this
relies on a really sneaky trick Maxim
he's in top form just the way he's
playing the speed he's playing because
now it he is giving up a pawn even
though he only needs a draw the idea is
now that white can launch a double
attack jumping out with the queen
hitting this weak Pawn a vital Pawn in
Blacks camp and also hitting this Knight
a double attack and this would be
decisive this would be a blunder if
Magnus gets greedy and takes this point
it's the move he wants to play but he
cannot get away with it I think he just
has to ignore Bishop takes Knight as a
threat and castle
but that's fantastic awareness right
there by Maxine because when you pointed
out there's a trick in this position I
automatically started looking for
discovered attacks on that D4 square but
it's actually got this idea that the
king is completely safe there are no
checks possible in this position so
Queen to G4 is the real trick uh setting
up this uh big threat of winning the G7
Pawn just incredible tactics here and
very possible that Magnus actually
missed this move uh we don't tend to
play the same piece twice in the opening
so Bishop D3 a really nice uh a nice
play there by Maxim I don't think Magnus
will be happy about castling and giving
this bishop F5 Bishop takes Knight
option to uh White yeah for example just
uh to show quickly he could now just
take for example move his Queen forward
and white has this beautiful Center
actually something we saw Magnus with in
the previous game a very similar Pawn
structure there and white if anyone has
the advantage not a good news for Magnus
Carlsen in this must win situation
yeah wow uh looking at this position
that we have out of the opening
I think uh Grand Final reset might be
the most likely outcome
it's too early to call and of course
anything can happen but I would take
white hair with this last move that
Maxim's played threatening to win that
night on F5 and if Magnus is forced to
take that Bishop on E3 which he does you
simply recapture with the pawn Open up
The Rook the bishop is nicely lined up
the queen and the bishop can become a
battery on this diagonal threatening
mates on 87 it's an opposite color
Bishop how on Earth does Magnus create
his chances in this one David
it's gonna be hard for Magnus you can
see in his body language he doesn't look
too optimistic right now he just has to
keep the game going we know his skills
his expertise in the end game
I think it's a distant dream right now
winning this game with black but he just
has to keep the game alive that's all
you can do in must win situations just
hope that your opponent's nerves kick in
eventually or hope that they try to
force the draw force the issue too soon
yeah right now though white has done
everything right Maxim not just winning
on the board winning on the scoreline
he's winning in terms of air quality it
looks so much healthier for him maybe
that's giving him the edge over Magnus
Carson that's why he's in top form this
whole tournament maybe Maxine but he's
just so professional right now and he
looks calm he looks composed he looks
yeah he looks ready for that Grand Final
reset he's been
so far and he's winning on the clock as
well amongst other things uh it's
leveling out a little bit but it's
important for him to try and keep that
edge and even use uh the 17th piece
against the world number one we've seen
that be a big factor in those critical
moments who has those extra seconds to
take those decisions uh uh and I wonder
if the last game was really magnus's big
opportunity the golden opportunity that
just ended up turning to dust it felt
like he was so close to delivering
Checkmate he was he was just one or two
accurate moves away from winning that
game Magnus Carlsen and now we would see
a totally different scenario with both
players going for each other uh
potentially the Armageddon as well where
Magnus actually has a phenomenal score
uh score historically in Armageddon um I
remember commentating on norwichs this
year Magnus won seven armageddon's in a
row against world-class oppositions so I
think that would have been almost
hopeless for Ashley Graf but with the
lead now he can bully Magnus he can kind
of keep the draw in hand and he's
actually maybe even hoping for more with
this last move Tanya this is the idea
that we've been discussing right set up
the battery between the bishop and the
Queen and watch out you don't really
have time to jump in with the Knight to
C4 it's a move that you want to make
hitting that pawn on video hitting that
pawn on E3 but now Queen D3 is just the
double trouble for black because you're
threatening Checkmate and you lose the
Knight on C4 so regardless of whether
Magnus jumps in with the Knight or not
Maxim is making his intentions clear and
you're right if the draw happens it
happens but he's getting ambitious in
this position he wants to go Queen D3
next provoke some more weaknesses on the
king's side eventually think about maybe
doubling up the Rooks on the F line once
the tension on the with the B and the a
pawn are resolved but even a potential
B3 uh move and then now you're looking
at targeting black skin yeah looks like
one-way traffic to me I just don't see
what Magnus can really hope for here
sooner or later you mentioned the
weakness he's going to have to create
he's going to have to put a Pawn on G6
just to block the uh strength of this
diagonal but then it's really really
loose this structure for black white
bring the queen out this way threaten
all sorts of sacrifices on the G6 Square
uh White can later throw this Pawn down
the board to try and loosen things up
we see so many ideas here for white do
you see any for black Tanya
it feels like Magnus getting that apron
up down the board should be able to
create some counter play on The Queen
side but right now he has to take care
of things on the other side of the board
so while there are ideas that exist with
the tension that we see on the left side
of the board Magnus has to be active on
the other part and he does he starts
with the move Bishop to G5 I think the
move that you were pointing out with the
pawn push it will happen once Maxine
does threaten that Checkmate but right
now there is a direct threat of picking
up that pawn queen to D3 played g6play
these are ideas that we've been looking
at and now I really like this Rook lift
that we were alluding to earlier uh
exactly why you're pointing it out it
not only clears the space for the other
white Rook to join the party but also
really over defends that E3 Square yeah
you have so many tempting moves right
now for white you can push this Pawn one
or two squares just to clarify the
tension you can maybe go for the black
Bishop in this way pushing some pawns
here later you have a nice Square for
the White Knight
he's in the driver's seat he's done
everything perfectly and uh yeah Magnus
he's on the back foot it's just all gone
wrong for him and imagine poor feder say
of watching at home doing the hard work
winning division two uh incredible
played by him but he's watching this and
he's thinking Magnus you're letting me
down he's uh yeah really cheering
against MVR right now for that spot in
the tour finals and probably in a
fantasyev's head it must have been at
the start of the day if I can do my part
of the job you you know that should be
that should be deal done because Magnus
of course is a big favorite especially
when you have to beat him twice so right
now phariseev is definitely feeling a
little a bit of the pressure as well but
a big congratulations to him a fantastic
performance in division two but will it
be enough to get him through to Toronto
right now Maxie making sure uh that that
doesn't happen playing excellent chess
David he goes for your idea I like this
move a lot because now you're coming in
with the tempo the H Pawn will not only
go to H4 but also Target that hook that
has been created with the Jeep on moving
forward H4 H5 coming up I think black
has to stop it perhaps with his own age
Pawn moving forward yeah massive threat
winning threat actually on the board
from vashilograph it looks innocuous but
pushing this Pawn forward would end
things for example if black gets
gradient plays on the other flank Pawn
to H4 kicking the bishop back and just
continuing to break down uh the blockade
of this target what Magnus Carlsen he's
just calling the bluff he's just
ignoring the safety of Black's King how
can he get away with this but it's not a
bluff right
Punta H4 the evaluation Bar says white
is just winning here and it's very
obvious it's very natural the black
Bishop only has one safe Square the
white Pawn pushes forward for example
you cannot take now you cannot take this
Pawn let's just show that Checkmate the
black king court uh really caught
embarrassed here and how else do you
defend simply Paul takes Pawn next move
looks devastating Magnus is gonna try
and hold this somehow but
the only move that comes to my mind in
this position is to try and defend the
G6 Pawn with Queen to E8 but it looks
like such an ugly move in the position
such an ugly move and not just are you
getting attacked on one side of the
board at the right moment white can even
just recapture this Pawn what is black
even trying to do on the queen side and
uh there's a Target here there's a
Target behind it
I don't understand in the computer there
we see the engine suggestions below the
board it does confirm Pawn to H4 the
most natural move that has just been set
up uh by pointer G3 it's also consistent
it gives an over plus two Advantage for
fashion right now
and Maximus pause and he plays it he
finds the move H4 he doesn't
automatically capture on the queen side
we might be going into a grand final
reset with Maxim winning this one as
well wow but is this Magnus also you
know it doesn't matter if he loses or if
it this game is a draw is it just him
Taking Chances especially on this last
move I would say yes up until that point
he was playing quite objective chess he
was getting frustrated that vashilograph
was shutting down anything he tried but
this last move it just feels
I mean the fact that he's even thinking
now after
kind of basically asking for white to
push the pawn forward it's bizarre it's
very strange it's been just
uncharacteristic just from Magnus from
the start if we think about game one
which he lost that end game that should
have been so easy for him to hold David
uh so many options uh having that extra
Pawn he loses that one the second one
ends in a peaceful draw and then the
third one where he had this golden
opportunity to actually win and Magnus
culture doesn't let go of winning
positions he's somebody who's able to
win losing positions as well and that
one gets out of his hand and look at
that he's giving up right now
reacting there on the camera briefly
Magnus and this is desperation this is
not uh inspired decision right now he's
giving up his Bishop he's trying to get
the black queen in to go for an attack
against White's King but the queen will
be attacking alone white king will have
some Defenders around it White's Rook
whites Queen they can act uh as shields
in front of this white king
I don't see it I don't see any
compensation right now it is a bishop
for three porn sorry but one of those
pawns will drop the black B2 pawn and uh
first I think Maxine of Ashley Graf will
lift up his Rook or bring his Queen to
the defense
yeah you can just stop there is a threat
the only the biggest threat that black
has in this position is to give a
Perpetual which guess what is good
enough for maxim even if there is a
queen to G3 and a queen to H3 repetition
that we see on the board a draw gets
maximum through
so it's not even the end of the world if
he was to allow that but I like your
idea just get your pieces to defend
because the B2 Pawn uh you can
eventually pick that up rook have to or
with the queen moving forward and but he
does he does the professional thing
you've called it there Tanya he's going
to allow a draw we're going to see this
repetition of moves and we will be
headed for that Grand Final reset wow
over not yet Magnus gave a check he's
just a piece down though if he doesn't
take the draw Magnus can pretty much
resign
and a draw is enough for white Maxim so
professional here Magnus head and hands
he knows there's nothing to be done
because there's no other piece that can
join the party with the queen nothing
else that assists in the attack and
Magnus there Kaya he's getting ready and
look at that he's giving away another
Rook checks to follow there we go it's a
draw and that means we are heading to a
grand final reset Magnus Carlsen loses
the match here in the Grand Final
against mvl he is on fire the French man
taking it to a grand final reset he
still has hopes of winning the AI cup
and he still has hopes of going to the
tour finals in Toronto five minutes now
you guys before game one in the Grand
Final reset that will be best out of two
rapid games if that is tied Armageddon
will decide the AI cup okay what do you
think about the situation right now
Tanya
thought of the day that if Maxine takes
the first set for me he becomes a
favorite in this match and it's not just
the scoreline it's not just him taking
the first step I'm gonna go as far as
saying Maxim has been the better player
today
does that mean he is the favorite do you
agree with that David I'm not sure that
he's the favorite I would still say it's
50 50 because Magnus does have extra
gears and he's not been himself today
Magnus Carlson that is clear he's missed
opportunities he's played really
uncharacteristic and really slow I have
a feeling he'll still go up uh he'll his
form will improve but Maxim he still has
enough in the tank as well it looks like
he hasn't had to go into any effort I
think it's just a pill 50 50. anything
enough I'm taking David up on this one
David let's have a bet on this I uh I
think Maxine's gonna get the job done
today Kaya wow what about you
know I cover green because I've been
listening to you guys momentum is a big
thing and momentum is definitely now on
maximum
side he won the first match now one
match to go to the side d a i cup only a
few minutes until it starts get ready
you guys we will be right back foreign
[Music]
spells jump or freeze the hairs start
with two jump spells and five free
spells which recharge after five moves
you may cast your spare whenever you
wish before making a regular chest move
jump is a spell cast to one square
wherein if there is a piece on that
square other pieces can jump over the
Charmed piece the freeze spell is cashed
over a three by three square area and
the pieces in this area are temporarily
Frozen in place
your powers of Chess and surgery to
defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
available now on chess.com
[Music]
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carson and Michiana
this course is generally about examples
like this common knowledge that's used
on on the highest level
good intuition comes from knowing a lot
of examples from having seen examples
thought about them and perhaps tried to
implement the principles but on the
different circumstances having thought
about it having tried to implement it in
a way and having debated it so that's
more or less what I try to do with this
course
basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in many
players
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone it is a grand
final reset Magnus Carlsen will have the
white pieces in the first out of two
games to now decide the AI cup and it's
not only about winning the tournament
it's also about going to Toronto because
Vladimir fedosev has won division two
and that means he is the one going to
Toronto to the tour finals if MBL does
not win division one he is rooting for
Magnus Carlsen to now win division one
in the AI Cup and the the Grand Final
reset will be a best out of two rapid
games we start from scratch zero points
for both players
the winner will be the winner of the
tournament if they are tied after those
two rapid games with 15 minutes plus
three seconds increment we do head into
Armageddon where there is no increment
and uh the winner in Armageddon will be
the winner of the AI cop only five
minutes is what the players have had to
just reset get ready zero points so uh
what do you think is happening now with
Magnus Carlsen getting ready with the
white pieces
I think for Magnus is just about
switching things up completely we were
talking about this right Maxim has not
only won the previous game but in every
aspect of it whether it was the opening
the middle game the end game whether it
was tactics or whether it was defending
difficult position in every aspect it
felt like Maxine was doing something
better than Magnus but Magnus with his
back against the wall how many times
have we seen him make the comeback just
too many to count so too soon to write
it off but momentum is definitely on
maxime's side he's got to be feeling
confident after the chest that he's just
played he's finding all the accurate
moves he's doing it fast he's doing
everything right he just needs to I
think not let the pressure get to his
head right now
they have been Rivals for so many years
they are good friends
Magnus Carlsen both born in 1990 so
focused right now both of them getting
ready for the reset white pieces for
minus crawls and what do you think will
happen now David well Magnus I think
he's gonna go for it he doesn't want
anything boring he's got a bit of Pride
to save now so I think he will want to
get his first win of the day for him a
five minute break maybe wasn't enough I
think for the two players Maxine is the
one as you said with momentum he wants
to keep going Magnus needed a bit more
time potentially but it's a repeat of
the Queen's Gambit accepted it's a
repeat from game three of uh the earlier
final still all the same moves that we
discussed earlier that we saw earlier uh
nothing different that's why the players
are playing so quickly up to this point
and Magnus hope
is different because this is
this a chance at Victory but now we do
see a deviation from that game 3 of set
one A different position so it looks
like Maxime has done some damage control
has done some preparation in the in
between matches yeah wow I'm really
surprised they didn't have that much
time between games and Maxine
vashilograph clearly spent at least a
fair portion of that time looking at his
opening notes or maybe talking to a
coach saying what should I have done
this is risky though he has changed
things up the last two three moves are
new compared to the game we saw earlier
today but this was what Magnus Carlson
has prepared and look at this it's just
a crazy position that's blown open white
is a pawn up white has Castle Queen side
however now white is two pawns up and
Magnus sacrifices his queen look at the
speed they're playing both players now
17 moves and they both have more time
than they started the game with this is
opening preparation let's do a quick
count black has a queen white in return
has a bishop and three Pawns
that's a three-point deficit for white
but White's pieces are active White's
pawns are advancing
oh wow this is some of the deepest
opening preparation you'll have ever
seen this has probably been saved up
from uh World Championship matches by
Magnus uh this is how seriously he's
taking it this is how badly he wants to
win but uh also Queen sacrifices he does
have the flare for the artistic so this
is absolutely crazy the players Blitz
out up to this point have more time on
the clock that they start with and
Maxim's the first one to go into a think
tank and that can be a bit worrying with
black when white spawn is on C6 it's all
about peace activity and making sure
that black doesn't get his pieces
developed the coordination going notice
how that last move takes away key
squares from Black's Knights to offer
any trade especially that D7 Point next
what Magnus wants to do is get the H1
Rook to the D1 square and basically just
dominate the position with the pieces
but Bishop in three pawns for a queen it
shouldn't be enough shouldn't be enough
this isn't the best Queen in the world
this isn't the best Queen you will ever
see she's struggling for air right now
if she steps forward then you'll move on
the board Tanya The Rook would swing
across and it's more about these other
pieces
um also now if the queen moves this Pawn
might be uh up for grabs I must say
visually I really love White's position
is you always get a bit of a kick as a
chess player giving up material and
still having a healthy position you just
have the kind of pressure released your
queen down you can play uh kind of
freely here but then again if
objectively uh kind of things go wrong
you will be a queen down yeah visually I
agree with you but Maxim he's a
mathematician he's doing the math in
this position he's got a queen which is
worth nine points so versus six points
but it's really all about peace activity
here that Rook for me it can't
unfortunately go to that A7 Square to
try to develop because the bishop on E3
controls it look at the way Magnus is
using that extra Bishop to take away
Key's Quest from black he's just not
allowing the Harmony in no Maxim's
position Rook d8 a massive threat
massive threat that would Fork the queen
and the King if white gets time to play
that check so black has to give some
material back
how do you do this I think you have to
just block what else can you do you
cannot Block in this manner because
white actually has another strike this
would win the queen back immediately and
you've won a lot of material in the
process so you pretty much you have to
give back a whole piece if you have
actually the graph you can drop your
knight in the way of White's Rook to
block this deadly check and uh I mean
this is just chaos Tanya I think I need
15 hours let alone 15 minutes to work
out the consequences of this one well it
looks like Magnus has worked out all the
consequences at home because he's got
still more time than what he started
with and the only way to defend the
threat the one that you are pointing out
is on the board Magnus gets another
minor piece so that does add to that
material imbalance in favor of Magnus
and I'm expecting him to jump in with
the Knight to C6 is that a move that you
would consider here attacking that Rook
on E7 it looks super scary for black and
this is a massive threat Knight takes
Rook would be a fork
how do you deal with this if you move
the Rook away then White's other Rook
can come in oh wait maybe there's an
attack against this piece maybe this
bishop just moves and let's do a count
here right now Tanya in the current
position I need some help with the
counting here white has two pieces and
two pawns for a queen so added that all
up eight points for white nine points
for black white is ahead The Rook does
indeed move and now I'm expecting the
bishop to drop back I'm not sure which
Square it will use
maybe even this one on the side of the
board but either way this is going to be
crazy Magnus Carlsen bringing his A-game
with opening preparation here this is AI
inspired this opening choice
okay nice
this is the AI cup is this the first
game you wanna say that about or have we
seen that we've seen a few moves a few
ideas that's inspired but this is I mean
no human would ever dream of going to
into a mess like this unless they were
armed to the teeth with uh computer
preparation
and David I'm still thinking about how
we got here and it all happened so fast
I'm just wondering if it's a good moment
to just back up a little because Magnus
Carlsen just sacrificed the queen and
the first 15 moves of the game so if you
just do a little bit of an action replay
slow down and actually take it all in
I will slow down if I can I mean I still
need a lot of time to work this one out
um this position I'm backtracking now to
the end of the opening uh this position
we have seen earlier today and there
Maxine vashi Graf played a very slow
move he just pushed his pawn and uh
defended this Pawn chain uh eventually
he was in big trouble but held the draw
instead this time he initiated the chaos
it was black to start this whole process
sacrificing a pawn and uh White took up
the challenge black sidestepped
attacking the White Knight White's Queen
stepped forward and uh why even castle
queenside and this was the moment after
grabbing a second Pawn Magnus got his
Queen trapped and you can be forgiven
for thinking this is a blunder the White
Queen lacking squares now but Magnus had
calculated this he gave up this queen he
took a piece so this is where the
material imbalance started White Queen
dropped off he took a second piece black
regained some material and uh here we
see white having this material imbalance
very strong Bishop pair big threats on
the board and several pawns marching
forward and uh let's catch up with the
game position this is where the crazy
night sacrifice happened this had to be
played to prevent The Rook check on the
back Rank and now this game has evolved
Magnus does drop his Bishop back and two
pieces two pawns for a queen but white
has control and I think Magnus is really
happy with the outcome so maybe looking
away from Muhammad yarov in the two
matches that these two have now played I
don't think I've heard you guys said say
sacrifices more often than you have
actually with these two playing against
each other there's been a lot of them
that's true yeah I'd agree with you
there was a queen sacrifice that we had
uh for Bishop and three pawns to start
with and black sacrificed the knight uh
it's been fire on the board is it a
trend it's definitely a trend and these
two especially the first match between
them a couple of days ago when they were
throwing everything at each other I mean
it's the amount of respect they have the
kind of the amount that they love chess
they're just real purists in the fact
that they just want a fight they don't
care normally about these drawers now
that the results are so important or at
least in the last match that we had
earlier today uh where the results were
key there Maxine was maybe playing with
the results in mind playing for the draw
but now the safe kind of the handbrake
is off
um the safety net is gone and it's just
all about the win all about the beauty
as well and uh yeah Maxine's been
sacrificing porn since the start of
today but sacrificing a queen is another
level of course yeah but and even after
that for maxim as well he's been
sacrificing pieces back to get the
position under control but this is
anything but control right you pointed
out the material deficit here it's eight
versus nine mathematically in terms of
points and usually the evaluation bar
would love the extra points but the fact
that it's giving a slight Edge to
magnus's position it means that peace
activity here is strong enough for the
material deficit the one point count
deficit that Magnus has in the material
imbalance currently there's a threat on
the board the E6 Pawn is on the fire and
the maxim needs to take care of that as
white the one thing that I really want
to do is sidestep my king from the C
line there are so many pieces lined up
on the sea lion there is a black queen
the Knight the bishop and the king I
think the one move that white has to
take time out for would be king to be
won at some point though and wow Maxime
just ignores the threat of the E6 spawn
and instead brings up the queen to
create his own ideas yeah black does
have a queen after all she's fighting
against two Bishops and two pawns uh but
if she ever gets active we all know the
might of queens and I don't think white
should get him to take this Pawn with
his Rook at least because trading pieces
will only help the black queen give her
more life give her more activity and
also this deadly pin that Tanya
mentioned uh this will be fatal taking
the pawn with the bishop is maybe the
other tempting move but here black will
give up the piece uh black will give up
a rook for the bishop and at the very
end I think this pin again will be
decisive for example black can remove
the defender of this Knight next move
white will lose either one or maybe even
both of these two pieces Magnus
therefore does not get tempted up his
rook and this does give Maxime the time
to go back defend this ep6 Pawn that we
were trying to take and you'll move on
the board again Tanya you've got the
crystal ball out you're predicting the
future White's King just sidesteps
always I always recommend it if you
Castle Queen side in any game take
another time out to shuffle your king to
the corner Maxim actually does the same
he puts the black king in the corner out
of the eye line of White's Bishop this
is the Calm before the storm in this
game well I mean there's already been
one storm there's gonna be a hurricane
in the next few moves uh but yeah it
feels like both players just setting up
their pieces nicely uh just keeping them
safe and it's just about who can make
progress over the next few years who can
start the attacks yeah and while King B1
was an easy predict you want to sidestep
any ideas as they've been
starting from now on it's going to be
really hard to predict any move in this
position because it's so imbalanced and
so Dynamic but it's very important for
Magnus to play energetically because if
he allows the black queen and the Rook
to start combining and the pieces to get
out it could mean a big disaster for
white skiing so Magnus has to keep the
tempo going but how does he do that and
he starts with the H Pawn is he eyeing
it advancing all the way up to eight six
to open up some diagonals for the dark
Squad Bishop we did say this game was
inspired by AI alphazeera's favorite
move uh Pawn to H4 just throw this Pawn
as far forward as possible acts as a
battering ram create some holes create
some weaknesses around Black's King
black says okay I'll blockade now your
Pawn can set forward but not further
than that and uh very sensible giving
the king some ass and breathing space
you mentioned the queen and Rooks Tanya
the fact that they cannot move without
getting captured by this white knight is
incredible right now white has a knight
dominating those three pieces and uh
okay maybe at some point black will be
able to give back some material in order
to activate the queen but it's looking
impossible right now it's really kind of
sad for maximum that he has no active
piece play he's just reduced to playing
uh simple porn moves I'm expecting
Magnus to throw more pawns towards this
black king in the near future and you
asked this question at the start right
five minutes before the Grand Final
reset what did the players do I really
want to know what did Magnus do in these
five minutes because it feels like this
is a brand new Magnus that we're seeing
today yeah I this opening Choice it
nearly backfired on Maxim Vash the graph
in game uh three I believe of the match
today uh it's a lot of Chess we've had
but I was going to say earlier I didn't
want to sound too harsh I was gonna say
Jordan van Forrest one of magnus's
seconds for the 2020 uh one world
championship match has played this
several times as black and therefore
Magnus will have been aware of it
therefore Magnus will have studied it
and uh no the uh the ins and outs and
look at that quick chat David exactly
what you're saying Magnus using leftover
prep from his never world championship
games yeah I'm just speculating but it
seems very likely and the fact that
Maxim's walking into that deep dark
Forest that clearly magnus's uh
yeah studied deeply it shows a lot of
Courage but it can also backfire when
you take risks we've seen it in previous
days when you play your opponent's
openings or something that they know
really well you've got to be ready to be
hit by a surprise and clearly Maxim knew
everything up to move 17 18 but since
then he's been burning a lot of time on
the clock fashion and his position has
not been improving if anything it's
White's position that's easier to play
White has full control and throwing
pawns forward what does black even do
we've said you can't move pieces without
losing material it's a real dilemma
especially with half the time of his
opponent he tries to activate his Queen
in this direction but this can be shut
down firstly the white pawns can
continue marching or the white knight
can Retreat into the center
now what Maxima is hoping for is enough
time again to get the pieces into the
game so I think Rook to C8 would be the
natural follow-up to this uh to this
move and perhaps an eventual sacrifice
of material to neutralize some of the
pressure that we have Magnus doesn't
give him the time hits the queen and
defends the F3 Pawn Maxim continues with
the pressure so there's a double attack
in the position Magnus is going for
Maxim's King he doesn't care about the
pawns anymore yeah look at that
centralization we talk about controlling
the center of the board it's like soccer
football where you control the Midfield
you control the game and white pieces in
the middle there that uh that kind of
massive pieces looks so impressive but
as you say Tanya black is going Pawn
hunting will he be punished vashilograph
on the camera looks a bit down right now
he really does he's it feels as if whoa
a sacrifice from Magnus this time I
don't think this can be taken it's
poisoned but there are tactics in the
air I think vashadograph saw this maybe
hence his uh posture there but let's
just explain this sacrifice you cannot
take with the knight at least if you
take with the Knight whoops there's a
double attack a fork quite Elementary
stuff but next move the black queen
drops off if you take with a rook then
after Rook takes again it's poisoned you
cannot take this time with the Knight
either because yet again this recurring
theme of the fork Magnus trading off his
H Pawn which just dropped on the last
turn for Black's really important e-pawn
in the center looks really logical and
now all sorts of threats against this
black king
it's terrifying can you even allow that
Bishop to stay alive that Bishop lands
on D5 I'm hitting your Rook on the next
move look at the two snipers at the
center of the board Bishop lines up on
F5 creating a Kill Zone against uh
Black's King look at this Quest they
control Tanya these two Bishops yeah
just beautiful Bishops and Maxim doesn't
decide to give away some material to
neutralize that Bishop instead jumps in
with the queen to H2
this is clever at least now the bishop
will hesitate to move because uh at the
very least black could maybe even chop
off this Knight with his rook in the
center now this uh stares at the night
the queen stares at none at the night uh
double vision here but what else to do
it looks like you can at the very least
give a check I'm not sure this is
profitable but at least this would cut
out Rook takes Knight in those
variations the black king has to move
and now the white Bishop can step back
to the square you mentioned who do you
prefer here okay he's gone for it
immediately Magnus Carson I was gonna
say who do you prefer the might of these
two Bishops uh or the black queen in the
corner and then the maxim just Primo
because he just put the King on H7
instantly the move that we were looking
at after the check but Maxine plays it
voluntarily and the bar doesn't move
this is crazy maybe Maxine was worried
about some night checks maybe he was
worried about some sacrifices using uh
The Bishop's diagonal here but uh either
way Mark of Genius these two players
navigating the choppiest sees the
choppiest waters you'll ever imagine
doing it so quickly David what is King
87 I mean it's at least you slow down
for a minute that guy you were talking
about is this the game with the most
number of sacrifices I think this might
have overtaken the shock game yeah he's
sacrificing his rook in the corner and
then black I think will just simply
recapture and we suddenly have to do a
new count it's rook and Bishop and
one pawn two pawn two points thank you
Tanya uh for the queen so actually white
would be one point up here but at least
now you have gotten rid of white light
squared domination that Bishop maybe is
superior to a rook right now we talk
about points bishop worth three Rook
worth five but actually in this position
Bishop Nooks much more valuable now
there's one main rule in chess right
take Center take Center minus his pieces
they're just so much in the center why
is the bar not more excited for Magnus
well he doesn't have a queen I guess
black does so it's those two factors
white has a bit of material not enough
uh for the queen but the centralization
kind of balances that out and yeah I
mean any other position with this type
of control over the middle of the board
car and white would just be winning but
I think just the black queen
for now holding her own so take Center
and keep your queen ideally
keeping the queen in general is a good
idea unless you're a genius like these
guys unless it's a trade for the
opponent's Queen sacrificing Queens I
think the reason we think it's so
spectacular the reason we're always
amazed is because it happens so rarely
unless these guys are playing yeah and
look at MBL just like stretching just a
normal day at the office just playing
some insane chess here fighting to win
the Grand Final I can't believe these
guys so calm oh so common they bought
drops it stinks for white after this
last move it looks very logical Magnus
now trying to leave her open the black
king trying to explode the shelter
around it and we see the computer moves
just below the board there black only
has one move but wow the advantage is
growing and now it says over plus two in
Black's favor only if he finds the move
bringing his rook in the corner to the
open C file that would actually create a
devastating threat maybe Magnus is
underestimated the danger on the white
king that might be uh brewing and of
course Maxine finds it instantly a big
check the queen coming on to C2 is the
massive threat now Magnus has to deal
with and he does shake his head he
doesn't have the time to actually open
up Black's King side because of this new
threat the first threat of the game that
Maxim has created but David we were
talking about this if the Queen's in The
Rook find their Harmony then magnus's
King can be the one which is in danger
suddenly Queen to C2 check is a killer
blow it would hit the white king and hit
the white Rook for example if white
takes now this would likely end the game
black and happily safely I think take
this rook and white centralized pieces
not enough compensation here and it's
not just that threat Tanya I think what
he's missed maybe Magnus is he doesn't
have time to guard against this check
and stop black from taking this Knight
in the center maybe he should have
jumped out the way with the check
earlier because now for example if you
drop back your Bishop to cover this key
Square then Rook takes Knight wins two
pieces for the black rook and here we
don't even need to count black has a
queen for just a rook and a couple of
Pawns no more attack no more danger
Magnus might be in big big trouble right
now he for sure has missed the double
attack this double threat Queen to C2 a
killer blow
and it's head enhanced for Magnus I
think he realizes it he had done
everything right gotten his opening
preparation this absolutely crazy
position on the board which is exactly
what Magnus was hoping for and then this
last natural move trying to open up your
opponent's king but I think it comes
down to that point that you want to give
that check before get your knight out of
danger and this could prove to be very
costly for Magnus now Maxime down on the
clock but I have a feeling at this
moment it's going to level out
one of my big takeaways from this whole
tournament is that players when they
have their fate in their own hands for
example fedes needed to win the
tournament to have any chance uh needed
to win division two somehow they rise to
the occasion uh fedesev played his best
chess all week one division two did
everything he needed to do the punishy
Geary manager of they all made it deep
into the tournament because they needed
it to make it to the final and fashion
something inspired him this is another
level of Chess from him to be able to
firstly defend that position from
earlier somehow that black queen which
was paralyzed activating herself and
creating threats it's as if he's working
magic and it's all coming together all
on the same day against the world number
one this it's just incredible I've been
following and been a maxim fan for a
long time and been watching his games
but but this kind of Chess this kind of
accuracy this kind of
uh just merciless play and just not only
in tactically sharp position but in
strategic battles in opening battles and
the confidence he's showing I haven't
seen this from Maxine before this has
been incredible to watch it almost feels
like the Resurgence like the French
Renaissance all over again yeah and
here's uh what 33 now we have been
talking about how he's been changing up
his opening strategy imagine if he had
done that played everything under the
sun basically from when he was a
teenager do you think he could
have been maybe a world championship
Challenger in his 20s and maybe can he
be that in the future now yes there's
still a chance Magnus isn't playing
World Championship matches even if
Magnus was Maxine is showing now he can
hang with him uh when he's uh at his
best yeah he turns 33 soon and I think
in chess these days this generation
they're still hanging around long enough
it's going to be hard with the new uh
kind of the youngsters the teenagers but
still capable and clearly a Renaissance
I think you can always say I could have
done this I could have improved but
maximum part of his strengths were his
openings until a certain point when uh
kind of he was just too predictable so
it's it's hard to say but he's doing
everything right right now and that's a
key point he's always been one of the
very best in the world in the world
Elite top 10 for such a long time but it
was his narrow repertoire that kind of
just made it very difficult after a
point to progress to the next level
which for them is of course fighting for
the world championship title uh I think
he's worked on it the last couple of
years he mentioned it himself during the
pandemic especially tried to change that
up make his openings as versatile as the
rest of his play and we're seeing these
phenomenal results from him I'm actually
really looking forward to seeing what
Maxim and how he performs at the Grand
Swiss will he make it to the candidates
now grants this is going to be hard and
pretty much all the top players in the
world maybe apart from Magnus Goss and
will be playing so it's not going to be
easy but people are going to fear him at
least now the way he's been playing here
Fear Factor is huge in open tournaments
and right now he's still doing
everything correct traded off a set of
Rooks still in control for black
this whole scenario it reminds me of
what
civil Masters David where it was Hikaru
knock him up from the losers bracket
went on to play Fabiano caruana in the
grand final ticket to the Grand Final
reset and eventually won the whole thing
momentum maybe there as well the only
time the season we have had a grand
final result in division one this is the
second time
the only time we've seen someone rise
from the losers bracket to win a
tournament yeah yeah and wow okay just
looking below the screen only one move
to keep things alive for Magnus Carlson
right now it is losing a move his Bishop
just came from the D5 square but he has
to retreat White's light Square Bishop
back to the center uh back to the center
control those squares in the middle
they're natural
if you look at this position as a
one-off it is but he doesn't find it I
was going to say the one thing that will
make him not find it is the fact that
his Bishop just came from that square so
it's really hard psychologically to make
uh kind of to confirm that you've made a
mistake to just Retreat lose two moves
and the reason this is bad is because
Black's simply picking up an extra pawn
and it forces white to actually come
back with the Knight because now if you
go Bishop to D5 the move that you wanted
to make you end up losing a very key
Pawn in the position so Magnus with that
last move I think what he wanted to do
David was to actually defend that Knight
by retreating it to keep control on the
king side
is Knight D4 an option here yeah it
looks very healthy I guess there's no
threat what white has to try to do is to
break through on the H file this would
actually end in Checkmate if white could
safely check but Black's Queen controls
all checking squares and now Black's
Knight will come into the game and white
has lost his centralization the
beautiful coordination we saw with the
pieces in a little bubble in the middle
it's being broken white light squared
Bishop has moved away needlessly now
this bishop lacking squares it's only
got one safe square and uh the fight
goes on I will say that it's still not
easy but at least Black's Knight can
start activating maybe you go this way
or maybe you go this way into the
position
yeah Magnus he's trying this maxif
Ashley graph I I'm not trusting the bar
as much in a human encounter because it
could easily swing if Magnus coordinates
his pieces against the black king but
does look like Maxim has survived the
west and we do a quick count now it is a
queen for Just Two Bishops and a pawn
and the more pieces disappear the more
important that material balance will be
I completely agree with your point that
the eval Bar says that Maxim's
completely winning but it's still a very
random positions mistakes can happen
especially when we come down to that one
minute Mark which I think will happen
soon as long as Maxim's King is boxed up
on the H line and doesn't have an Escape
Route and there is this threat of The
Rook sliding down with a Checkmate on H1
chances are there because it really ties
down Black's Queen to defend that big
threat on the board but how does he keep
the position and the pressure as is
because Maxim is going to try to get out
of that which is why I really like your
suggestion of bringing the Knight
forward and first making sure that that
white Central Bishop gets out of the way
Kyle what you were pointing out the
control over the center has gone for
Magnus but Maxine still has that extra
Queen now and I think that trade Magnus
wanted as many pieces on the board as
possible the fact that one set of Rooks
has disappeared means that checkmating
blacks King is going to be far more
difficult and that's not a good sign for
white I'm expecting Maxine to activate
the Black Knight maybe in two different
directions he's just picking between uh
between those The Black Queen cannot
move she cannot allow a check from
White's Rook on H1 the black Rook
doesn't really want to move necessarily
it looks like it's on a perfect square
so process of elimination it's either
the Knight or pawns wow it pushes
forward setting a trap such concrete
play by Maxim he's just always going for
the most direct line given the
opportunity and I think that is the kind
of approach that you need when you're
playing against the Magnus the more I
look at this move the more I like it and
it wasn't even something that came into
my mind to be to be completely honest he
wants to pick up the E4 Pawn with a
check now you know I was going to say
setting a trap but actually maybe Magnus
has got a bit lucky here he can move his
King safely the white Bishop the white
Dart squared Bishop is poisoned black
cannot take it because the black queen
would suddenly lose control over the
corner Square the H1 square and one Rook
would swing and Checkmate blacks King so
black the queen here is actually a bit
stuck
I think he was trying to trick Magnus in
the process maybe missing something
himself I'm not sure this exchange this
transition has actually helped black
that much
wow uh really interesting we've been
talking about black skin stuck in a
mating net and that might be the one
thing that keeps Magnus alive in this
game and this is a best of two right so
it's so important with the white pieces
to at least find a way to get out of
this uh without a loss for Magnus
because the next game he starts with
black
suddenly what does Maxine play just to
show this variation on the board this
bishop cannot be captured suddenly we
would see Checkmate next move uh the
black queen would have to throw herself
in the way now but this is Checkmate
look how the white Bishop covers all of
the Escape squares for this King and if
you cannot take this bishop what do you
do you move earlier Knight D7 maybe
bring the Knight out I'm not sure which
direction Knight to D7 kicking this
bishop yeah makes a lot of sense the
bishop does have one safe Square he
moves his Rook across he's trying to pin
and win here uh Maxim also makes a lot
of sense and how does Magnus untangle
his pieces suddenly everything's hanging
in mid-air can you actually with the
same thread go Rook D2 and start
threatening a mate from the H2 Square I
think he would love to the problem right
now is Rook D2 I mean this is what he
wants to do you're right Tanya he would
love to give chat mate this would be
winning for white unfortunately just
about covering the square now the bishop
can be captured Magnus has to arrange
this in the right order not easy to do
this yeah
hanging by thread this one could be
decided in the next two or three moves
despite the bar saying it's less
dangerous for white in Practical terms
he's still balancing on the edge of a
knife how do you get the Rook to the
edge line I'm just thinking of where's
David because that's what's on magnus's
radar as well right now to create that
threat yeah he needs to get his Rook to
this square but it is covered still we
need help let's ask the engine yet again
it's that type of position it's so
irrational Queen for two Bishops and
while Magnus has a very narrow path to
survival actually if he doesn't find the
best move or maybe the second best move
he is toast he is doomed and the best
move is so difficult it looks like this
bishop is cutting off the black King's
Escape squares but you have to retreat
it to defend your Rook allowing Queen
takes Bishop because this is so
unnatural because now you can jump in
with a fork and this is not gonna happen
surely Tanya and for example we could
see an endgame Rook takes Rook black
giving back the queen but it is only
black who can win here with a rook
versus a bishop
I think this is actually losing the same
game I don't think Magnus is ever going
to play the best move here the second
one maybe on the board Rook to F1 this
is more likely I agree with you I like
that move because it does set up the
idea of going with that Rook even
further to F5 and then the threat of
getting it to H5 Rook F1 definitely
feels like the more human approach that
Magnus is really good with finding
retreating moves so I think he will find
that move Bishop to B3 the First Choice
by the engines but that answering end
game that we just saw I think it would
be the evaluation of that end game that
will make him not want to find that move
Magnus yeah he plays uh Rook to F1 so we
have a second recommended move there
minimizing the damage and black still
cannot go and take the dark squared
Bishop this would end in Checkmate if
black takes twice on the Square the
White Knight stands on as well Rook
takes and then the queen takes also this
Checkmate Black's King is caught in a
box in a mating net
so the black Queen's still frozen in the
center I like this move for Magnus I
think in Practical terms it still asks
some big questions and uh as Tanya
pointed out trying to get over to that H
file
if any check is the end of the game Rook
have five is a big threat
trying to get the Rook to that H line
nah
Black's got to try to fight against that
you have to fight against that
checkmating idea and it is coming for
you David do you see a way for maxim to
keep up the pressure and Maxim goes in
with the queen
so his idea is that after if you do go
up with The Rook 2 F5 how is he fighting
Checkmate I think he has to push a pawn
Black's uh g-pawn can cover some squares
but the evaluation bar doesn't approve
and I don't like it either it feels
unnatural I think Maxime is done to
panic because of the clock the queen was
centralized we talked about
centralization a lot this game but
Queen's in the middle of the board
control everything uh that Queen was
hitting pieces it was controlling
squares from afar uh I think Maxim is
actually losing a bit of control by
playing this move yes it's a one move
threat but the white Rook wanted to move
anyway and okay it's one minute each I
don't even know who the favorite is
anymore
I think this one could still go in all
three directions
it felt like it was a two result game
once Maxim got his pieces coordinated
but Magnus is back into it and he does
threaten a Checkmate in one on the board
Rook H5 a big threat Maxine he will play
the move uh G6 if you take on G4 I think
the material imbalance just works out in
White's favor in this end game you end
up with two pieces for a rook and that's
a happy happy trade for white yeah so
what's he even thinking about Maxim
under one minute now he has to play this
move otherwise he's losing he has to
prevent this Checkmate idea of The Rook
swinging across okay he does play
eventually Magnus will most likely shift
his Rook up one square and he's getting
active at least he's going to maybe take
this pawn and go around
but now it gets really random yeah both
players under a minute and the position
is absolutely Wild One a bad move one
inaccuracy from either of these two
players and it could be game over
yeah I think we will see a blunder set
in this it just feels like that type of
position and totally understandable
forgivable in any uh any human to go
astray it's just so weird this position
I mean it's just like their games from
two days ago irrational crazy what other
adjectives can I find beautiful
beautiful genius yeah okay he takes a
pawn Maxim greed he hopes is good here
attacking White's Knight as well in the
center I like that because if white was
to take that A6 spawn I think Maxine
would be happy to give up The Rook for
the two pieces and mag still keeping the
pressure on the king brings back the
Knight Maxim as well with the tempo
attacking that Knight not allowing white
any checks on the board and wow look at
that white only has one move otherwise
the advantage grows to plus six for
black and that move is never ever going
to be played I can guarantee it Magnus
is not going to drop his Knight back to
a square it can be captured I think
fashion grub is going to win this one
wow 92. that makes no sense never gonna
be played it literally hangs the knight
in one which means that Maxima is very
close to taking this one if Knight D2 is
the best move in this position to me it
looks like white is busted yeah White's
pieces just cannot deliver the killer
blow they cannot deliver a check
therefore one of them will fall they
have no coordination this is where you
need a queen or you need some pawns to
hold things together
look at him he's so frustrated right now
he's looking for something that doesn't
exist he drops his Bishop back this is
desperation this bishop is hanging does
black just simply capture it I think you
can take this piece and then and you
pick up the night watch out there was a
CH could you take he probably couldn't
have because Black's Queen was coming in
with a check and it would be Checkmate
on white Magnus doesn't have time to
capture on f8 because of Queen C4 check
yeah black has to move the Queen White
is actually threatening checkmate with a
rook slide into the corner but black has
the move he does give the check and it's
actually we mentioned it earlier the
first one to deliver a deadly check will
win this game but David the good news
for white is that the bishop can slide
back all the way to B2 to guard any
checks on the second rank here it's all
about the material it's Queen for Bishop
and Knight and yes white can block the
Checkmate prevent the Checkmate but
Black's king is not getting trapped
anymore it's actually an attacking piece
I think he can even just give up his
Queen for that night you can pick up the
rook and the Knight by sacrificing your
queen Maxim he may or may not go for
that but it feels like that should be
enough as well with the g-pawn marching
down the board
Magnus is on his last legs now that
black G Pawn is going to become a new
Queen nothing to do about it Bishop
clearly inferior to the black rook and
Maxim just has to be slightly careful 14
seconds just I like this move beautiful
centralization shoulders off white skin
and there's nothing that can stop the G
Pawn from queening Maxime is winning
this one go back with the Rook defend
the queen he might yes he does it it
does it white spawn stopped black spawn
about to become a new Queen Maxine takes
the lead Magnus Carlsen throws himself
back loses another game
Telegraph wins another game he takes the
lead in The Grand Final reset he is now
one game away from winning the AI cup
making just a massive performance here
at the Frenchman he is on fire today
just amazing this was so reminiscent of
the games in their first match it was
absolutely wild from the start Magnus
got the kind of position that he was
hoping for the material imbalance and it
looked like it was going to be magnus's
game but again Maxime so resourceful uh
just incredible stuff an absolute roller
coaster and wow Maxim's doing today what
I think few could have ever imagined and
believed in yeah incredible stuff they
now have five minutes now less than five
minutes for that final rapid game to
decide the Grand Final if Maxim wins or
it's a draw he will win the AI cup
Magnus has to win that game to take it
to a final Armageddon so four minutes
now until that game so let's dive into
this incredible game that we just saw
David yeah what a battle what a game
from literally move one from start to
finish it was crazy first opening
preparation both players coming well
armed and eventually ending in that
queen versus pieces imbalance and it was
here that Magnus made the final mistake
the final blunder that allowed black to
win he retreated his Knight but suddenly
realizing after the black Rook enters
that this Knight has no good squares to
use and black eventually converted a
material advantage If instead Magnus had
brought his Knight the other way the
other direction to attack the black Rook
we might have seen the game go on
suddenly white Rook able to slide back
and if anyone's King is in more danger
it might even be blacks a level position
all three results possible and this
would have been a dramatic end to the
game instead it was actually graph who
took the win
is it Maxim on fire today is it Magnus
not at his best or is it both
[Music]
uh it feels like Magnus got out of bed
on the wrong side or something slightly
off not just not quite sharp not quite
quick as uh he usually is but Maxine I
mean we should not take anything at all
away from him he's been just on fire
from move one today I agree with David
Magnus even when he's not at his best
he's still the best player in the world
so you really have to get your A-game on
and take the opportunity when you get it
and that's what Maxim has done from the
start of the day he takes the first set
and he takes the lead in the second one
as well against the well many might say
the goat Magnus Carlsen and it's uh it's
just incredible to watch it and he needs
only a draw now Kaya to make it to
Toronto with the white pieces with the
white pieces and what should we expect
now
I think more of the same exactly what he
did in the final game of the first match
uh before the reset I think he will just
play one E4 he'll sit he'll try and
Bully Magnus with this with the idea of
a draw I have you have traded do you
think Magnus is right now with the way
the day has gone because he
he's so emotional about these uh these
games and this results what do you think
is going on in his mind right now
frustration uh Magnus is great at
bouncing back he's probably better than
anyone else in history and it does take
two players to make a great match so I
still feel he has something up his
sleeve he will try and mix it up
um I think he's going to play better in
this last game than he has in the last
couple but he's still uphill struggle
winning with black you can never
guarantee it yeah can you guys believe
it this is uh the final rapid game in
the regular portion of the Champions
chest for 2023 coming up only the tour
finals left not only will this game
maybe decide the winner of the
tournament if we don't have an
Armageddon it's also gonna decide who
goes to Toronto if it is a win or a draw
for MBL he is going to Toronto he will
grab that final ticket fedo Sev watching
this now he must be feeling quite
nervous as well rooting for Magnus
Carlsen I think the only man more
frustrated than Magnus Carlson right now
in the Chess World is fair to save
watching that game thinking it could
have gone either way it was 50 50 for so
long and uh to see Maxim take it he's
gonna be hoping
nervous but I think
I think including fetasiv this this is
such an incredible match to see play out
and to see Maxine perform at this level
to see the kind of fights that we're
getting by both these players these
insane positions I think federalism yes
he's rooting for Magnus but he's also
really enjoying the chess that we've got
on the board yeah and Maxim mentioned to
us in the interview yesterday that well
uh chess is popular in France he said
maybe not as popular as in Norway but do
you think there's and please share with
us if you are in France and rooting for
a meal right now I mean the French fans
must be going crazy over this there are
a lot of French fans and federations
growing it's been a game on the up for a
long time they've got so many young
Grandmasters coming through clearly
Maxim is one of The Inspirations for
that he's been the top player of this uh
generation
um yeah both and only gonna grow
many years
so many of us in the chest World
actually expected Maxime to challenge
Magnus for the world championship title
but it's difficult the candidates are so
tough and it's never happened although I
think it was 2021 when Maxine was
leading it halfway through uh from the
first half of the candidates and it felt
like he was such a favorite but he
hasn't really gotten the job done and uh
again just incredible to see him play at
this level that he's performing in this
entire tournament the first match
between them really set the tone it sent
out the signal that it's not going to be
easy and yeah it's been just amazing to
watch this happen he's playing the chess
of his life maximum he is one rapid game
away from winning the AI cup luckily we
made a big bowl of popcorn this is the
last of it I'm just keeping it here with
me you guys have to analyze you have to
take us through the marvelous chest
coming up right now it's game two in the
Grand Final reset an mvl
he has been oh look at that Magnus
Carlsen is still frustrated this is live
of Magnus
that is an angry Magnus guy wow and I
mean he needs to put this behind him now
he is playing another game I've not seen
him like this because the guy never
loses and he's lost twice today yeah and
this frustration bringing this into a
must-win game for him yeah
that's good time today it's a must win
game with black and that shows how much
it means to Magnus he wins everything
and we take it for granted that he's
kind of just cruising through but it's
the passion it's the determination is
how much he wants to win and still
beating himself up he has to forget
because the game's starting now and I
think for anyone thinking that he's not
motivated to win this one because he
he's already through to Toronto what we
just saw on the screen it just shows how
much this means to him and here we go
the final rapid game in the AI Cup mvl
draw or win he wins the AI cup Magnus
has to win to take it to armaged on take
us through it good news for Magnus
Carlson and for all the fans at home
it's an open Sicilian that means it's
going to be exciting guaranteed no
matter what very few false drawing lines
in this one and a lot of pieces gonna
remain on the board for a long time the
pawn structure is going to be different
Magnus here playing the Khan variation I
believe uh pushing his Pawn forward to
A6 not deciding yet where to bring the
Black Knights out to and maximum I'm
surprised he went for this opening I've
got to admit
somebody or Russell limo keeping things
more claws the claws Sicilian was
something that we'd be expecting but
Maxim he's been showing that he wants to
play objectively where he feels is his
best chance and he goes through an open
Sicilian which will give Magnus his
chances but looking at magnus's camera
it feels like he's not only battling the
board but also his own mind right now
yeah and Maxim needs to try and strike
while Magnus is still uh composing
himself while he's still a bit
distracted with the earlier games the
earlier play now black is going for a
hedgehog formation something I know you
love uh Tanya white here has what we
call the maroxy bind white has pawns on
the E4 Square C4 squares trying to clamp
down preventing any pawn breaks but
black is rock solid black is really
really flexible and I know Magnus quite
likes these positions as well we've seen
him play these positions in the
Champions gesto with some great results
and again it's all about flexibility of
plans for black hair so you keep white
kind of guessing of where you're really
headed the first question is where does
Magnus develop the Bishop from f8 Bishop
to E7 is the normal course where you
place it in front of the king the d-pawn
moves one step forward then you decide
where you want to develop your queen
side Knight and Magnus makes the first
well it's not the most popular approach
in this position uh the slightly less
played Bishop to D6 It lines up with the
queen with a direct threat against the H
Pawn and the reason that this move isn't
played as often is because you want to
push that D Pawn to the square that the
bishop has just taken to complete your
development of the queen side pieces
feels like Magnus is trying to surprise
Maxine take him out of any potential
preparation here as you say not playing
the most common first move but there is
a threat to take White's Pawn on H2 with
a check and Maxim has to react he's
giving him decisions again that's
something you need to do when you want
to win you keep peace on the board you
give your opponent three or four choices
every move and
um something you said throughout this uh
this tournament Tanya every kind of game
is decided by incremental mistakes and
you just have to hope that giving your
opponent decision after decision after
decision will
slowly turn things in your favor and
that's the thing that works for Magnus
really well because he's the player who
can make maximum number of accurate best
moves move after move and very often for
his opponent they just collapse after
some point and in this one Magnus again
doing that approach where he gives
decisions provoking Maxine to push pawns
on the king side which later on can
become some sort of a target for black
he does use the pin the bishop goes to
the C5 Square to pin up the Knight Maxim
continuing with development to stop that
a lot of uh forcing moves being played
here by both players a lot of forcing
moves and the big question is who it
really favors it feels like Magnus has
lost a bit of time magnus's dark Square
Bishop has moved twice and it will get
traded off so it might even move for a
third time in the next few turns and
Maxine meanwhile has gained a lot of
space with the white Pawns
talk about central control like we have
been doing white has beautiful control
over the center here still roughly in
the balance but I think I would take
white here Tanya and uh for Magnus
Carlson that's not a great sign he's
still very cramped lacking Pawn breaks
lacking any potential attackers against
the white king
yes and he needs to decide where to
place his own King as well you want to
go towards the king side Castle towards
the king side but that could also mean
uh certain attacks that you have to
watch out for once the White Queen lands
on the king side there are two parts to
do this in in these kind of positions
the White Queen can go from F3 and then
go over to the other side of the board
Maxim chooses the other one he starts
with queen to D2 instead David
connecting the two Rooks it just feels
like whites managed to get the harmony
within the pieces and that D6 Pawn the D
line that you're highlighting right now
is a long term a point of contention wow
yeah I was expecting the White Road to
land there he uses another Square
hinting that he might want to propel
some pawns forward later on Maxim's
Rooks uh looked really nice here
supporting these far Advanced pawns and
watch out for a pawn storm in the center
as black what does black even do you're
the uh Queen of the Hedgehog
a lot of pressure right now to predict
magnuses and Maxim's next move but I'm
gonna gonna try now usually what black
really wants is to force white to take
on C5 because that helps you with your
structure and the first move that I
would be thinking about here is actually
making that happen with the knight from
F6 jumping onto G4 I'm glad to see the
valbar not react to that my idea is that
if you take on C5 there are two very uh
tempting ways to capture it but I I
think I would I would want to take it
with the B Pawn and the reason for that
is that I want to stop your e-pawn
moving up the board to E5 control that
I've improved my Center improve my
chances of attack along the B line and I
would be the one who's happier with this
trade than white so Knight G4 would be
on my radar in this position yeah I love
it Tanya uh just always looking up for
Pawn structure you called it that is uh
the stump of approval from the world
biggest stamp of approval and this
position on the board okay he takes with
the Deep one I'm surprised as well
especially in positions where you need
to win kind of imbalancing the pawn
structure here kind of having the
Central Pawn Mass black looks really
nice and healthy instead it's a slightly
more symmetrical Pawn structure but he's
banking maybe on the open file it looks
very tempting for wet to step forward in
the center uh kind of creating nice
squares nice inroads into the black camp
but black Brooks will centralize and at
least some open files some activity for
Magnus I think he would love as well uh
just to occupy this Square later on with
a piece
the question is what happens if white
kicks you back I'm not even going to
answer that because I'm going to pass
that question to Magnus I'm not sure
whether the Knight goes back in this
direction or even maybe this direction
just because I'm scared of getting hit
kicked around the board but uh yeah
that's the question for him right now
he's created some imbalance and that's
step one in a good situation
yeah that's the problem I get one more
right but not the second one
uh but Magnus here I think he's doing
what needs to be done to create his
chances he's opened up the d-line as
you're pointing out and it looks like
Black's rook and queen will be the one
that's closer to getting to that open
file a very good point they're made by
you that after white does kick out that
knight from G4 you probably do want to
get it to the edge of the board it's not
the general advice in chess but here
it's all about making sure that you
don't lose out on tempos and allowing
white to push those Central pawns with
Tempo would be very dangerous that would
just be asking for trouble because once
E5 happens the white knight from C3 also
lands on e4 it's not only an attacking
move towards the king side David but it
gives a really strong hold on that D6
Square yeah this is a big hole in the
black position this Square because you
have no dot Square Bishop you have no
pawns that can control it so it's an
outpost for White tonight's black needs
to fight against this maneuver and so
that's what I'm expecting from Russia
the graph I'm surprised he's pausing uh
either Pawn to E5 or first a kickback on
the night one of those two moves would
be the most logical and black have to
react but uh Magnus Carlsen do you think
he's got it out of his system yet no no
I've been looking at his camera he looks
frustrated he looks uh not too happy
with himself I don't think it's out of
his system
yeah that's and I'm not an expert but
I'm just looking at him I think on the
plus side for Magnus is maybe he's so
angry right now that he's playing
quickly the adrenaline's pumping uh he's
really kind of forced himself to
to wake up speed up yeah and also for
maxim he is so close now to just a huge
tournament victory for him in his career
at this point in his life how hard is it
to just sit there and like focus on the
next next move next move and not be like
oh if I win this I'm gonna post this on
Instagram you know that's what I think
about when I played Thomas
you're you're absolutely right I don't
think that even Maxime thought about
getting this far when the tournament
started it says one shot to make it he
has to go all the way through and then
most probably beat Magnus Carlsen who
will make it through to the finals these
are thoughts that probably didn't even
cross his mind and here he is he's done
it in the Grand Final and looking close
to do it in the Grand Final reset
it's uh it's a sign of a champion that
he doesn't let it get to his head right
now and he's focusing on the moves and
so far Kaya he's doing he's making all
the right ones on the board so I think
he's not thinking about the Instagram
are you guys thinking about it what will
you post after this I'll put something
with you guys the ladies in red the
ladies
full disclosure David was playing that
song uh in the studio before we went
live he was very nice yeah yeah we we've
had a really nice Friday pizza party
popcorn and first of all amazing chess
incredible chess I mean it takes two to
tango this has been an incredible match
uh throughout the week when they first
played a couple of days ago and today uh
both have contributed equally I think
for magnets of frustration is not only
about what happened in the last game but
what's been happening throughout the day
uh in March 1 as well it was the most
non-magnus chess that I have seen now in
each of the games even in the ones where
he had the advantage and the ones where
he got into trouble usually with my I
think was it Alexander alakayana said
for whom it was said you have to beat
him in the opening in the middle game
and the end game I mean it's true of any
top player these days it's true but I
feel like the Magnus you have to beat
him in all these three on every single
move uh but today Magnus has been off
form from the very start and even when
he wins matches he's so critical of his
shape he's so um you know he always
talks about the quality of his Play Over
the scoreline that the day ended with
and I think there's a lot of frustration
with the chess that he played today
starting from round one yeah starting
from game one when Magnus could have
actually forced to draw instead losing
in an end game really unlike him and uh
from then things have spiraled that
being said the more I look at this
position the more Maxine vashtag was
thinking uh the more optimistic I would
be feeling as black because White had no
obvious moves there and the one thing
the last thing you can allow is Black's
Knight on the edge of the board coming
back into the center and uh maximum now
he's ready to take that Knight if it
ever lands on the F5 Square he's putting
his Rooks back in the center kind of
recorrecting their position sometimes
you have to admit you've put a piece on
the wrong square and you have to improve
it take the time out to do so and I like
his last move but it cost him a bit of
time cost him about two three minutes
and yeah as Magnus I would be a bit more
optimistic now at least he's not going
to get checkmated I don't think how
white has the ammunition for that
um the space issue here isn't so drastic
for black
and it's a lot to do with that D4 Square
as well which doesn't really allow
White's knight from C2 to jump into
activity so ideas like from Knight to C2
to E3 to going over to the king side and
getting rid of a key defender on the
king side is not going to happen because
black has this jump with the Knight to
D4 these kind of positions David I agree
with you that black has got reasons to
feel like the opening is gone his way
right now you've developed all your
pieces the knight from H6 is the only
problem piece in the position for black
but the other good news is that white
doesn't have at least for me the idea of
G4 G5 is it's a bit much because you
really open up this A8 H1 diagonal
giving a long term long term play to
White blacks Queen and Bishop that can
line up to deliver Checkmate but with no
G4 G5 can you really take advantage of
Black's Knight at the edge of the board
probably not I mean this Knight will try
and jump in later it cannot now just to
show it will get eliminated and it's not
just the fact that it's traded off
running the black porn structure it's
more that white creates carves out an
outpost for his own Knight hitting the
queen maybe even picking up a Pawn on
the next move so black can't jump in yet
with the Knight but I'm wondering Tanya
uh you mentioned one move if the white
knight jumps away how does Maxine react
okay he's played it on the board Knight
takes Knight Magnus is going for it now
he's trying to change the pawn structure
he's got a pass Pawn on D4 and he's also
corrected the position of this Knight
the poor Knight on the edge he's
bringing it in there's a threat of a
night Fork hitting the two white Rooks
therefore one of the Rooks moose shifts
up maybe Maxim is going for checkmate
after all maybe he's trying to shift the
Rook to go for this week spot uh the
kind of the Achilles heel in Black's
position the H7 square but black does
have a beautiful Knight about to jump in
Suddenly It's yeah it's like a wave it's
kind of crashing against the Rocks but
uh that's good for Magnus it doesn't
mean it the position is dry anymore it
means there's life
and Knight E3 on the radar
what do we think here the position is
coming to the last few moves and there's
a big threat that white has the one that
you pointed out just two moves right
Rook a three Queen H5 and then you're
threatening a deadly mate on H7 uh you
never want to really make a move like
eight six to defend that David because
it will invite a lot of tactics
eventually if the white knight jumps on
to F6 and I think that's the reason why
Max Magnus has decided to actually trade
the bishop for the Knight on e4 because
nice is so much easier to guard the king
side you'll always have the option to go
G6 or 86 at the right moment to stop any
attack on this diagonal as you're
pointing out but for Magnus it is all
about the Deep on giving him the E3
square and a long-term passer also play
along the C line the C4 Pawn is a
weakness that white needs to watch out
for which is what doesn't allow white to
trade the light Squad Bishop with the
Knight on F5 that's right and he's
thinking right now of Ashley Graf maybe
he'll take with the bishop but then the
Black Knight will move it won't allow
itself to get traded and suddenly yeah
it is black with the better pieces some
lead especially this night it's what did
you call it yesterday a kraken a kraken
that's penis that is a kraken right
there Bracken yeah this is a monstrous
night with a lot of power and Magnus
he's turning the screw now it's more
strategic it's a slower type of position
no chaos like the previous game uh the
previous two games even and uh yeah
Magnus this is where he really thrives
it's as if the anger somehow is driving
him and it's calmed him down he's going
back to basics this is Magnus as he kind
of uh just as he cruises just simple
strategic position yeah it's like that
Beast right a wounded Beast is even more
dangerous because uh a wounded Kraken
yeah this one would be a big big Kraken
a mythical creature which is
extraordinary Barber if that Knight does
get to the E3 square but for Magnus Kai
we were talking about you know what's
his mindset he's feeling the frustration
and we saw all those emotions right at
the start of the game but it really
feels like he has used that to actually
fuel himself for this game and he's the
one who is in uh driver's seat right now
with the black pieces creating all these
chances and this is I think one of the
qualities out of the many that separates
him from the rest
yeah both of them have really high
ceilings I think out of the players just
below Magnus Carlson vashilograph is one
of those who has this ceiling when he's
on form I mean he can play like this but
sometimes less consistent and it's nice
to see him being
uh yeah just putting things together
just being in the zone constantly this
game however the clock times it's
normally Magnus who's been lower
throughout the day for the first time
really he's been kind of upping the pace
upping the speed and it's vashilograph
who's maybe it's the nurse maybe it's
the kind of momentous occasion getting
to him I was
do you think that's the reason this
whole math situation is getting to him
right now what he sacrificed the bishop
he's going for checkmate Checkmate but
it doesn't work
why is he sacrifice this the black king
has an escape score and Magnus
immediately blunders back apparently is
there a forced draw because what is a
piece down he's threatening Rook to F6
David yeah he's threatening to give a
nasty check with the white Rook suddenly
this game is sprung to life out of
nowhere out of the blue and maybe if
Ashley Graf is well according to the bar
at least holding with this counter
attack while Magnus thinks in this
position can we just do a quick action
replay of the last three moves because
uh beep hit the fan yeah something went
down here it was all about the sacrifice
before it's too late this Rook was
attacked nice way of putting that Tanya
he gave up this bishop and it shouldn't
work after a check actually it was in
this position Magnus with nine minutes
on the clock could have sealed the win
if he just pushed his Pawn forward one
square rather than two the difference
being that in this position white does
not have the time to bring his Rook up
the board because now black uh I was
gonna say can take this Pawn but no that
isn't uh the computer move apparently
this is very different after uh the
Black Knight takes this Rook I think
we'll see something very similar in the
game let's try and investigate the
difference in the current game position
Black's Knight can actually take another
piece but suddenly the White Queen
dropped back with the check and look
there's nowhere to go it's a draw King
to E7 and it's checkmate
if black goes back it's a draw and
that's enough of Ashley lagrov a
repetition of the position this is the
threat
Queen to G6 this would force a draw and
Maxine would win the tournaments how
does he defend against this Magnus
Carlson this is why actually he needed
the pawn back on F6 that is incredible
that's incredible and this is what just
makes it makes just so hard right you've
got these two pawn moves to fight
against the maid and that is the
difference between a win and a draw and
in this case it's the difference between
a championship right now wow F6 would
have won Magnus the game but the one
that he chose the decision that he made
it looks like his best option would now
just be to to take the rook and go into
a repetition yeah just to show this
again it's literally a coin toss it's
heads or tails you have to move this
Pawn one square or two uh to stop your
king getting checkmated you need to give
it some breathing space Max Magnus
immediately pushed his Pawn forward to
F5 but the detail would have been here
uh just to show it once again now Knight
takes Rook is possible because after the
White Queen drops back with a check it's
no longer possible to play Queen takes
E6 Checkmate there's a pawn in the way
on F6 and uh now for example after Queen
takes one black could block with his
rook and black would have an extra Rook
extra Knight and win the game now Mark
this facing this devastating
tournament-ending threat of Queen to G6
and there's nothing to do there's
nothing to do because Queen G6 is a
massive threat threatening Checkmate or
a rep Edition there and uh use that it's
a coin toss between two moves but at
this level it's got to be just
calculation right had Magnus just slowed
down he would have definitely seen this
Magnus in this position he played F5
instantly did not even pause and uh yeah
with something's up today but with more
time on his Glock with nine minutes he
should have been able to find a pawn to
F6 it's not obvious we do have the uh
evaluation bar here so we did see it
swing immediately we saw the truth but
uh Magnus he could have calculated it as
you say Tanya and now suddenly I think
he was just looking at this threat but
maybe forgetting with the tournament
situation A draw is enough for white
going to G6 devastating
and is it too late now David is there
any way for black to actually keep the
game going
I don't see it it's really really risky
to keep the game going the problem is
you can't really run with the King
either if you try it starting to run
with your king after a check or maybe
this is the best bet but I was going to
say a check here and look how this white
Rook plays A Part suddenly if the king
continues its Journey then Rook takes
pawn and the black king in huge trouble
yes you've got an extra Knight but white
has three pawns maybe four pawns soon
and an ongoing attack maybe this is the
best bet this I think this is going to
happen
I have a way to not end the game
immediately and it feels like the king
run is the only way even if it means an
objectively worse end game you're up a
piece for four pawns you still fight it
out there are still chances there still
some chances the one thing he cannot do
let's repeat it Knight takes Rook Being
Greedy would not work out Queen check
would force a repetition of moves
let's go back to Magnus Carson four
minutes now
is the kind of position guy you could
have 30 minutes on the clock and it
doesn't matter because you have to make
a decision that you're not going to be
happy with is it a blunder Magnus
Carlsen has blunded Queen takes C4
but why is this a blender we have to
work it out White's going to give a
check look at Maxine frowning as well
he's like are you sure check to go back
to E8 you can't go to E7 because of
Queen juice is this game over
black is getting checkmated look at
Magnus Carlson he knows it even a rook
trade will not save black here Rook
takes Rook is met by the white Pawn in
the sense of recapturing and black has
no checks black has no counter play it's
going to be Checkmate Maxim's going to
win the AI cup
oh my god do you think Magnus is going
to play this side or will he just reside
and look at that
oh
look Magnus Carlson
massive frustration he is about to lose
the Grand Final Magnus Carlsen
I look at Maxime he knows he's done it
Kaya yeah that is tension leaving
Maxine's body right now he can relax
because he's done the hard work
Checkmate is guaranteed there's nothing
to do black cannot defend this position
well we see Magnus hit the resign button
I think so this might see a Checkmate on
the board there's literally no way to
fight white is threatening to play Rook
takes Rook a trade of Rooks would allow
the white eporn to join the uh during
the battle and maybe even become a new
Queen yeah and mvl is starting to let
the emotion come to him he is starting
to realize he is the winner maximum the
Frenchman he wins the AI cup he banks
the ticket to Toronto he is going to the
tour finals he does the impossible he
beats Magnus Carlsen into matches on
fire what an incredible performance
and he must be so happy and Tanya how
happy are you for am I unbelievable I
mean what a performance by Maxine washer
lagrava Magnus Carlsen the strongest
player in the world his chassis out of
this world but today Maxim was the one
it was his day kayati beat Magnus twice
on the same day in a match play format I
I don't think anyone would have bet
against Magnus today this has been
incredible and a big congratulations to
Maxime the only path to Toronto and he
grabs that ticket describe to us David
what do you think about what you've seen
from mvl not only today but in this
tournament yeah I'm pleased for him back
to his best he looks happy he looks in
the zone in top form uh just incredible
chess as well thank you for entertaining
us Maxime uh I mean well played to
Magnus as we as I mentioned earlier
takes two to tango and uh it was
actually this position that Magnus did
let things slip Maxine went all in it
was a bit of a gamble it turned out that
this move is objectively incorrect but
maximum you've had the courage and
Fortune favored him here the sacrifice
of the bishop the White Queen coming in
threatening a nasty Checkmate but now
Magnus could have clinched Victory and a
comeback with Pawn to F6 as we showed
earlier he went with the pawn to the
wrong square and we saw the white Rook
come in the reason he resigned after
this check and a capture is because
Checkmate is unavoidable if Rook takes
Rook for example the white Pawn replaces
The Rook threat of Checkmate on E7 if
black guards that with a knight then
white makes a second Queen a check a
check and this would have been the end
Magnus resigned Maxime takes the
tournament he wins the AI cop he is
ready for Toronto Maxim
massive congratulations on this win
it was
a very exhausting week I think it shows
I can imagine and please
head on your heart right now how are you
um mostly exhausted actually so like
really
um sometimes when you put so much energy
into something like there's no
uh I mean I realized I won but I will
realize it's better in a few pure world
I think like right now
this was again like
such an intense weekend such an intense
too much is also today
an incredibly winning the AI cup but
also on the final day banking the final
ticket to Toronto you are ready now for
the tour finals what does that mean to
you
um no it means a lot
um I really didn't expect uh to qualify
somehow and to win this but
um I mean I played incredibly sharp this
week today I feel like I played a bit
worse actually but Magnus as well I
think
uh we both were
quite tired and like I don't know about
the quality of the Moose but at least I
was missing a lot of ideas for Magnus
and Magnus was also missing a lot of
ideas for me like that was not happening
two days ago
kindness all
making comeback
be impossible to beat him in two matches
what is the main reason you were able to
do that today
I think just
um uh well first of all this first match
I think I was quite dominated throughout
uh but I got this lucky break in game
one uh where he over pushed and then
gave up this opponent F2 thinking uh
probably that he was for single draw but
but actually wasn't and
um and then the next three games uh like
no actually the last game I got hit
under control but the next two games
came to entry I think I was
uh
quite like
on the verge of being much worse at
least and completely lost actually in
game three
and then the second match again like
um so this time very briefly this uh
this line to know what to do
um but then I forgot actually the
as a final move of my preparation was
King h8
um so I knew like it was kind of trouble
but then Magnus didn't take my work
and then
I don't know I was feeling like I was
close to winning actually
uh there was so much come to play for
him so many tactic tactical ideas I
didn't know what to do and then I ended
up winning that game
uh and then the last game I feel like I
messed up but
then I decided uh I should go for this
to sacrifice not suffer
because I don't feel like I would have
the energy to defend another
bad position
and it turned out great like I sort of
okay six hours considering King 8 as his
main option to play for win
uh I don't know
um like but I saw that Queen C4 was not
working and
the basically I thought you had to play
King AIDS if you wanted to to kill the
fight
and uh Maxim congratulations how much
confidence does this give you for future
challenges future tournaments in the
next few months
I'm in my kids they're not a great
feeling to apply this one and uh to have
written Magnus twice
in a day of course it's good even if I
don't think we saw the best version of
Magnus today from it
but still it is obviously an achievement
in itself
and yeah I'm looking forward of course
to to next tournaments uh of course
mostly I have my eyes on guns face now
uh which will be in advance hopefully I
I can play as well and then
then I think I love some chances
Maxine huge congratulations and yeah
thank you so much for entertaining us
with your amazing chest today and my
question is I think a little bit more
out of personal curiosity that I have
because I think there's so much to learn
from uh from what we saw today and I
want to ask you coming into this match
today having to play Magnus and you know
you have to beat him twice to make it to
Toronto what was your mindset going into
this match and how were you assessing
where your best chances are
oh yeah we're just taking it one game at
a time and of course again I got this
lucky break in game one of course if I
don't win it uh
to actually take the lead against
diagnosis
quite difficult
and but some of this happened because
um
yeah you have a question and lost we
send them initially being a pawn up
um and then I was taking it one game at
the time and you know not trying to to
push my leg too much not trying to be
too passive either because of course
that's not a good strategy against
Magnus but
um yeah somehow
this mix of solidity and uh
uh finding practical resources to
to get counter problem in this obviously
is one of those things that I'm very
good at at least I consider myself to be
very good at and
I did manage this today
um there's something I I feel I didn't
manage to well today like my calculation
was a bit shaky but
uh where it's kind of number uh
I was feeling tired already from the
start of the day and uh Swati it got
worse
fatigue can definitely be a fact and
like you're saying it's been a long week
for you Maxim when you won that first
set and going into this Grand Final
reset having done this first big task of
taking down Magnus in the first match uh
how were you thinking about your chances
at that point and then this crazy
sacrifice at the end were you able to
keep your cool or what thoughts of
Toronto already in your head
uh human Bishop H7 like
I don't know
like but I thought it's my best chance
and I couldn't find a win for him after
after book H6 I thought maybe King E8 I
was calculating some lines it was really
completely out of control
um
so then I again I thought also it might
disrupt the course of the game because
uh at that moment here the uh too much
flow going for him like uh all his moves
were were coming coming in easy and I
thought
um that's not what I want especially I'm
done three minutes or four minutes and
I just can apply pressure in Iran there
and play forever so now this
was a practical decision of course uh if
it closes by force and I look very
stupid but
uh
but yeah it worked out very well yeah
definitely did and yesterday Maxim you
mentioned some friends that have been
very important to you uh during some
difficult years now I have to tell you
it's Friday we've enjoyed some popcorn
here today
who will you now call who will you
celebrate this big victory with
who knows because I'm actually uh I
actually have a flight tomorrow I have
another tournament coming in so I mean
there's not gonna be any big celebration
tonight maybe tomorrow with my team in
European Club Cup oh
we'll see
I'll be there too much
oh I want to join in now
back to him
fantastic oh that sounds like a lot of
fun Maxim just huge congratulations on
your massive uh performance uh I think
we and very many people out there are
super happy for you and uh yeah just
enjoy this victory
yeah thank you thank you for joining us
the winner Maxim
he takes the AI cup beating Magnus
Carlsen in two matches incredible stuff
and not only that he takes that final
ticket to Toronto he is the eighth
player going to the tour finals wow
incredible uh stuff from like Sam let's
take a look
the stats from the Grand Final reset so
Magnus Carlsen coming from the winners
bracket meant Maxim had to win two
matches today and that's exactly what he
did again playing extremely accurate uh
David yeah that's right he said that
Magnus maybe not at his best but you
still need to perform incredibly high
and 92 accuracy average even in such
crazy Wild Games is impressive and I
want to mention the only blunder the one
blunder we see from Russia de grav there
was actually the move that clinched uh
the tournament Bishop takes H7 it was a
sacrifice that paid off it didn't
objectively work but it's uh really
reaped practical rewards there well
played Maxi yeah
Let's uh
support finals eight players Magnus
Carlsen started out with beating Hikaru
Nakamura Maxim he knocked his fellow
Frenchman alireza down to the losers
bracket and on day two Maxim he won the
winner in semi-finals against Chuck lid
mamajaro but in the winners final that
was an incredible match with Magnus
Carlson playing some fantastic chess
Maxim still lost that match in
Armageddon and was knocked down to the
losers final where he played Jana
pomniacci yesterday winning that in a
great fashion he made it through to the
Grand Final but everyone said well it's
going to be impossible to beat Magnus
Carlsen in two matches but he did maxiv
and here he is the winner of the a I cup
and uh yeah incredible stuff from Maxim
Bashir lagrav we also have to take a
look at the results from the other
divisions in the AI Cup this is division
two and we have been following
very closely because we knew if he won
division two he did have chances of
going to Toronto he did win division two
but it is Maxim taking that final taking
ticket winning division one in division
three we also had a grand final reset
there with Sam Seville beating Ralph
momodov in both matches there as well
the young American winning his third
division three is this a player you
think David that we might see more in
division two and one maybe next season
definitely some Serbian he's I'm gonna
call him Mr final because he made so
many finals in division three he also
made Final in division two in one of the
events he seemed to go far seemed to go
deep every time and maybe division one
next time
Toronto it's Toronto and these eight
players are going to Toronto for the
tour finals in December this lineup with
Magnus Carlsen hikar Nakamura uh
abdisator Karana Wesley so we have
lasovic we have Oliver and now we also
have mvl your reaction to that lineup
it's beautiful you got wall number one
wall number two wall number three wall
number five all the top level the elite
the creme de la cram of Chess in Toronto
fighting it out and I think Maxime a
very well deserving spot if the guy
beats Magnus twice on a day he has to be
in Toronto yeah
this is uh the tour standings a few of
these players making it through from
winning events a few of them making it
through from the tourist standings and
who's going to be your favorite the in
this lineup for David oh it's hard to
look past Magnus Carlson or Hikaru
Nakamura but I'll signal some of the
young guys as the dark horses uh alarisa
farooja uh or Nordic Abdus I'm gonna
just love watching all of them though
yeah yeah it's gonna be uh fantastic
happening in December but now we are
joined by uh Magnus Carlson after a long
day a long tournament Magnus uh how are
you feeling right now
um I'm disappointed
um obviously
um you know I was hoping to do
quite a bit better today but um you know
Maxim was uh was strong and
I um
I failed at the critical moment so
that's um I think
a fair outcome we're very used to seeing
you make comebacks if you do
occasionally lose a game everyone says
you are the best in the world I'm making
those comebacks why were you not able to
do that today
no as I said I messed up at the critical
moments today I wouldn't say that I felt
particularly bad coming in like I felt
um probably a bit better actually than I
had the last couple of days that I that
I played and
um I think she didn't yeah as they said
it didn't play perfectly but he played
in his his style
um complicated the game which is which
also generally I was fine with
um and um yeah at the critical moments
and especially in the first
Fabric and the um
he yeah he was better but um
yeah I'm a bit annoyed especially at the
first Target game that I um that I
missed something very simple there I
could have at some point I could have
taken his Rook
um instead of pushing a pawn and that
was just based on a very
simple oversight I just didn't see that
he could play Rook Cate and threaten
Queen C2 I was calculating other things
like if I'd seen that I would have taken
the rook and whatever I would have had
um
a very very safe decision and I think
presumably good winning chances so
you know things
often go my way I didn't today
tomorrow but yeah I think the margins
for for fun and
that's um yeah as I said I think it's uh
it's a fair outcome it was um it was
better today so
and I've had a few
matches here with Mike Sim we've we've
seen more
I think in one game today there was also
some uh opening things that sort of
resembled some AI maybe some prep you
had from the nepo match has AI paid
played a big part in your matches with
Maxim and maybe other matches as well
yeah as as I talked about earlier uh
like Peter uses neural nets all the time
I think called the
all the best players and the seconds too
so uh
yeah I mean it's it's always a Pity to
um to use some good opening preparation
like uh you saw that Mexican played
quickly so I don't think the queen cycle
line was was new to him and it is like
it's not given as bad at all by by
engines so
um it was to be be expected it's always
a Pity especially when I got such a good
position later to
uh to sort of waste that um
idea yeah
and uh yeah mine is so maximum he not
only beats the best player in the world
today in two matches he uh wins the the
tournament he qualifies for the tour
finals do you have some words about his
performance after he's been through some
difficult years
yeah I mean it's hard to find the more
deserving qualifier for the final
reading I mean
uh it's um yeah it's it's it's amazing I
think he was very very strong in the
speed test Championship as well and
[Music]
um
yeah uh over over the two and a half
matches that we played now he was um
she was better so um it's it's good to
see it's good to see my sim doing well
like there was never in any real reason
for him to
um you know all of a sudden the falling
off so
um I think this is the level that he's
always been been capable of playing at
and happy to see him back
nice and uh Magnus what's next for you
and how much are you looking forward to
those tour finals in December
yeah I'm traveling to Albania tomorrow
for the European Club cup and from there
right to Qatar for the Qatar Masters so
not a lot of uh not a lot of rest
um
but yeah I'm looking forward to I have a
lot of events not only those words of
story finals a couple of others
coming up before
[Music]
um
before the end of the year so it's gonna
be yeah it's gonna be exciting
very nice we heard rumors uh MBL wants
to uh celebrate and have a party
tomorrow when you guys arrive the same
destination I don't know if you will
attend that as well Magnus
no I mean
I have won a couple of events now in a
row
uh so I mean this this year on the tour
like I've won most of my matches I lost
a couple of really close ones I think
that's that's normal
um and I'm not gonna sit here and be
extremely disappointed by losing in the
Grand Final against such such a field I
always want to win
um but um
yeah he was he was very strong and I
failed at the critical moment so uh this
I'm definitely not not heartbroken by by
this by this loss glad to hear that
Magna thank you for uh joining us we
look forward so much to seeing you in
the tour of finals you will be the one
to be there the two-time Champions Jazz
tour champion
yeah thank you thank you for uh joining
us
a few months until that happens that's
gonna be in December you guys mentioned
Magnus as the favorite the one
to beat
um it's a long time until tour finals
but uh but yeah what do you expect
already now Tanya you have to beat the
best to be the best right and I think
it's very hard to bet against Magnus in
that door final just the year that he's
had he's won three events of the
Champions chest though the World Cup
winner uh he's just won every single
event that he's played this year and
this one as well making it to the finals
Magnus a huge favorite but I think the
feel that we have with Hikaru Nakamura
with Fabi with them wheel and all the
others it's going to be it's going to be
a fight it's going to be a big fight and
I'm really excited about it yeah I'm
really looking forward to that one eight
amazing players going to Toronto you can
also uh head to Toronto if you place a
bid for the nft trophy for the AI cup
owning the AI generated the trophy of
CCT event number six the AI cup comes
with the ticket to the 2023 tour finals
in Toronto in December and if you head
to chess
champss.io you can place your bid which
then comes with that uh very nice ticket
that was it for the AI cup we have a
champion his name is Maxim vashiella
Grove such a deserved champion and he
banks his ticket to Toronto David you
are traveling tomorrow as well going to
enter that uh MBL party I guess yeah
that's the only reason uh definitely not
for any tournaments or anything but uh
no that will be fun a lot of Chess still
for the rest of the year a lot to look
forward to yeah oh when we have another
winner we actually have to uh announce
because we had a competition today on
Instagram uh we wanted you guys to share
your pictures following the chess today
and we have brothers love saying
watching the AI cup from
Champions chess Tour on a London bus
getting home on this Friday evening
after a long week enjoy your weekend
people I love that and you will now
receive
this uh everything's wave mini thank you
everyone for sharing your pictures and
spending your Friday here with us I also
enjoyed so much spending my Friday here
with you guys oh it's been awesome guys
this is uh it's been such a great
tournament Thank God It's Friday and
what chess we had just an amazing way to
end yeah it's been a fantastic season so
far and the best is still ahead in
December can't wait no wait tour finals
coming up in December in Toronto
everyone thank you so much for watching
this week for watching today we will be
back with the tour finals in December
have a great weekend and a Friday
everyone but bye for now
[Music]
I think he's lost his head here a bit
and that's it Magnus resigns we are
heading to a grand final recent MBL he
is on fire the Frenchman whoa what oh my
gosh I love it David maximum wins
another game he takes the lead there's
no tracks black history
the Frenchman he wins the AI cup
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you